declared by the governor as a result of
the covid-19 pandemic and in accordance
with the governor's emergency order 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a committee
meeting of the Health and Human Services
elderly Affairs committee please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
listen
contemporaneously and if necessary
participate in this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone all necessary
access information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website notice for this meeting complies
with house rules 90 uh and with RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
360 or email
HTS leg. state.
n. Us in the event the public is a whole
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled Christina Dia committee
researcher will be the staff assisting
us please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting should be done
by roll call vote we will start the
meeting by taking a roll call
attendance when each member States his
or her presence please also State
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting this is required
unto right to know law and Madame clerk
would you please call the role um yes
thank you very much uh here we go
representative
Acton I'm here and alone in the
room representative
Cannon here
alone in my home in
summersworth representative
kushman I'm here in the committee room
representative Fon here uh
representative
gay representative
Kelsey I'm here at my home in Bedford
alone representative King here at the
yellow be
representative Kirk
kerk I'm here in my home in Freedom and
I am alone in the
room representative
Kofa so he sent me an email that he
never got a link to join um if Christina
could send him one I just sent an email
to her okay um representative McKay Pres
representative Marsh I'm presid in the
LL representative
McMahon representative
Merchant I am here my home in clemont
and I'm alone in the room but my wife is
somewhere in the house representative
Nelson here in Brookfield I am alone but
my wife's somewhere in the house
representative Nutter
upam um I'm here in nashwa alone in the
room representative
Solway representative Solway you're
muted thank you madam clerk I am here at
my home in Lee New Hampshire alone in my
office thank you representative
Shapiro here at my home in Keen alone in
the
room representative query sitting in for
representative snow I am here in
Manchester alone in my
house representative
Weber here in Walpole um alone in the
Woods uh I'm here in my home in my study
in boow uh my wife is elsewhere in the
house representative Pearson here in the
lob and we'll come back to
representative
kofalt yes I'm here in my home office in
Wilton I'm alone in the room but there
are other people in the house
representative gay is
present we have 20 present and one
absent as of now ranking member would
you feel comfortable in Sharing why
representative snow is not with
us uh yes um representative
snow um had a family bement his
son-in-law died suddenly last week so he
is uh tending to his family and we very
much appreciate representative quiry um
stepping in for him and I was going to
ask Madame clerk if we have roll call of
any sort I don't know whether we will
today or not but if so could
representative query be called last just
so that other people he gets a a flavor
of where things are going um I I know
that he is very well able of forming his
own opinions but he's new to us and that
way he can have as much information as
possible to inform his decision when we
get to him the chair will certainly
grant that request thank you very much I
appreciate it and welcome representative
he I'm opening the hearing on Senate
Bill 149 FN adopting on Theus
legislation on Health and Human
Services and Senator Dr Sherman is being
Dr Sherman today and I believe his Aid
will introduce this
bill and if the ab will put her hand up
so she can be called into the
meeting
I do believe that you said are we doing
Senate Bill
74 14 149 because I believe um it's uh
Senator Rosenwald to begin
149 Senator Rosenwald um is willing to
do that um I comfortable with that
Senator Sherman told me yesterday his
Aid would do that but I'm willing to uh
certainly accept uh Senator
Rosenwald thank you Mr chairman um happy
to be here from the state house for the
record I'm Senator Cindy Rosenwald from
District 13 which is most of nashwa and
I'm stepping in for Senator Sherman to
introduce Senate Bill 149 this is a bill
with three distinct Parts part one uh
for which I am the prime sponsor
clarifies that Behavioral Health
Services
count towards medical expenses incurred
by individuals who are part of the
Medicaid spend down program it does not
expand the Medicaid benefit in any way
just makes it clear in statute that
Mental Health Care is health care for
this program and therefore since it's
just clarifying but not expanding there
is not uh any expected cost to for this
bill to the Medicaid Program however
it's necessary due to some ongoing
confusion at some of the district
offices and the bill also requires
reporting to the HHS oversight committee
this year and next to ensure
accountability for fairly and uniformly
applying the benefit as required by law
the language of this bill was introduced
in the house last year and it passed and
came over to the Senate unfortunately it
got table due to the pandemic and didn't
move forward at the time but it is still
necessary part two of this bill is prime
sponsored by Senator Sharon Carson from
district 14 it makes some technical
changes to RSA 318 which is the pharmacy
statute and it just enhances Pharmacy
services in certain facilities through
the use of automated Pharmacy systems
part three sponsored by Senator gray of
district 6 provides some liability
protections so licensed Health
Facilities that were deemed to have been
complying with emergency orders state
and federal during the current Corona
virus Co 19 pandemic I believe the
department is here to answer
questions um if there are any about at
least Parts two and three and I thank
you for the opportunity to introduce
this
bill M Senator does anyone have any
questions specifically for Senator
Rosenwald about section
one
I'll give you a few minutes to read it
over
again just a comment this is uh the
chair recognizes representative McKay I
think this is the one that
representative snow has been talking
about any other comments or questions
for Senator rosenwall think I see
representative
Shapiro you're are recognized
sir thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you Senator Rosenwald um just to
clarify I do not think this is the um
same issue that representative snow has
been talking about this just clarifies
that mental health benefits should be
counted towards the spend down um
representative snow has U made it very
clear that he's concerned that there's
no money in the budget to pay for the
change to a um a
higher um maximum income you're um thank
you for two different issues I believe
yes um you are correct um this bill was
introduced last year by representative
Murphy it is not the same as House Bill
1639 I think was the number from last
year by represent Sena of snow you're
right that bill changed the threshold
for qualifying to be in the in andout
spend down program this bill just makes
it clear that if you're in the
program and um incur mental health
treatment costs those count towards your
spend
down any other questions of Senator
Rosenwald on
part
one seeing none the chair would like to
call on Senator
Carson for availability to answer
questions on part
two I don't see her on the list Senator
Carson is on the speaking list but she's
not on the right here list
okay then the chair will call on some of
the gray for part
three Senator gray with
us Mr
chair yeah I may I got an email from
Senator Carson a few of us did she will
not be able to uh make the hearing she
has a conflict as well the last minute
um she did ask for staff to present her
part and part two of Senate Bill 149
house Senate Bill 149 um I don't if
there staff on the zoom to speak to it
if they don't I can actually speak to it
as well thank you representative is a
staffer to Senator Carson available to
speak to part
two uh Mr chair I do see Grant bossy is
on the line and had has his Rand his
hand raised
chair
recognizes Mr bossy and I miss your
columns by the
way thank you very much Mr chairman I
miss writing them uh but I don't miss
the deadlines uh good morning Mr
chairman members of the committee my
name is Grant bossy I am the majority
policy director for the New Hampshire
Senate and I'm here today on behalf of
Senator Sharon Carson who had an
unanticipated family emergency and
appreciates the courtesy in letting me
introduce part two of Senate Bill 149 on
her behalf this bill clarifies the
ability of the Board of Pharmacy to
issue rulem for uh remote automated uh
Pharmacy machines um there was no
opposition to it in the Senate uh the
Senators agreed that this is a needed
modernization in how um Pharmaceuticals
are delivered particularly in Long-Term
Care Hospice and Correctional
institutions that these systems are safe
and secure and enhance both patient
safety and cost uh there are subject
matter experts uh here that are that can
testify uh to the technical parts of
this bill I understand there may be an
amendment that CA that comes in Senator
Carson is fine with that if uh the
committee believes that that amendment
is warranted uh and we think that the
Board of Pharmacy should be able to um
regulate these machines through Ru
making thank you very much for your time
any questions for Mr
bossy I believe that's repr was of
KARK yes thank you very much and perhaps
you can answer this question if not I'll
wait for other ones who can does this
include schedule Two
drugs uh I would have to defer to the uh
experts on that thank you and
representative
Woods uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr bosy for taking my question uh
just in terms of the time frame it says
U that uh uh this will be u rules no
later than January the 1st but takes
effects uh in 60 days um is that going
to be a mismatch by chance in terms of
getting rules in place within the
effective date is of the whole bill
authorizing the Board of Pharmacy to
start this ruem process and then the the
board would have to have the rules done
by uh by January so the effective date
is for the authorization not the rules
themselves which would then come later
okay thank you um a followup Mr
chair um just I just for my own
edification um uh a consultant
pharmacist um I'm not quite sure perhaps
yourself or even maybe represented
Merchant might help me out there not
sure exactly what role they might play
in this and what what it is uh I I would
be curious to find the answer to that as
well I'd have to defer representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you represent Woods for the question um
in long-term care it's required under
federal guidelines that each nursing
home has a pharmacist who acts as a
consultant to the nursing home and also
to the medical staff and the medical
team in regards to drug
therapy does that answer your
question no
no no not really what role does that
person play in in uh this part two in
terms of the uh uh
Pharmacy the role they play in as far as
the pharmacy is concerned it's not so
much on the supply chain which is what
this deals with it's more into the
utilization of the drugs within the
nursing home itself which is where their
Consulting comes into play and that's
one of the things I talked about with
Senator Carson and also some other folks
I'd like to introduce eventually amend
an amendment to the bill to strike out
sections 2 3 and four because it does
become sort of complicated and I don't
think they're needed number one I think
the current law actually allows the
Board of Pharmacy
to create rules if you will On The Board
of Pharmacy disagreed so therefore
Senator Carson on behalf of the
organization that wanted to utilize the
technology has introduced this
Bill thank you
representative any further question for
Mr
bossy on section
two s seeing none then the chair
recognizes again Senator gray or a staff
member to speak to section
three and whoever wishes to speak to
that please raise your
[Music]
hand
I don't see
[Music]
anybody all right with that we will then
Circle back and look uh to
those M Mr chair we had two two hands
come up
Grant uh Melissa St s raised her hand
and Grant bosy also did too but they're
both admitted into the room so they
should be ble to
speak
okay and before they do would
representative McMahon please introduce
himself he has just come into the
meeting well good morning all I
apologize I had the wrong uh Zoom
connection so that's why I got on about
five minutes late but just Charlie
McMahon representative out of Windham
and I'm alone at my office in home thank
you anyone to speak to section three who
has raised a
hand
okay so both Grant bossy and Melissa
Saint here raised their hands and been
admitted to the room to speak but I
don't it there may be a problem with
their audio I'm not sure uh Mr chairman
I can speak very very briefly on this on
behalf of uh Senator gray I I thought he
had intended to be here this morning he
may have had technical issues as well uh
I can't speak to the details of his
section but uh just on his behalf uh
this has to do with um healthc care
facilities providing care during an
declared emergency such as the one we
have right now during covid uh we think
this is a a uh timely update to our laws
um so that we don't need to operate uh
under the emergency declarations that we
have something in place in statute uh to
give facilities the flexibility they
need during a declared emergency and
once again I'd have to defer on any
questions but thank you for your
consideration well Senator gray likely
to be here because um we do have a
specific question for him regarding
section
three yeah I'm trying to uh determine
I'm trying to get him online now okay
thank you Mr chairman I have a very
broad one that Mr bossy may be able to
answer please State your question thank
you um so am I am I correct in thinking
that the basic
thrust of section
three is to limit the liability of
healthc care uh facilities that are
acting under emergency orders because
sometimes that those actions required
under an emergency order do not
necessarily comport exactly with
accepted practices in a non-emergency
would I be correct about
that
a representative I've have to defer I'm
simply not familiar with this section of
the bill I'm I'm trying to get Senator
gr here for you okay and and Mr chairman
I I think that probably somebody from
the hospital Association could could go
into it in more depth there may be
others as well I'm guessing uh we should
call Paula minahan into the
meeting Mr chair this is Melissa Saint
sier I I don't know if you can hear me
I'm I'm on the line and and I'm happy to
answer uh representative Weber's
questions as well as um provide you my
brief
testimony go
ahead thank you um Mr chair members of
the committee for the record my name is
Melissa ster I'm the chief legal officer
for the Department of Health and Human
Services and um as to representative
Weber's question this uh under RSA
21p facilities that perform Emergency
Management functions uh in for during an
during a state of
emergency can receive protection from
suit and um other kind of liability if
they are um
reasonably attempting to adhere to the
emergency orders that have been um
issued by the governor or by the
department um or anyone who has the
authority to issue an emergency order
and so that's what this um section is
attempting to do did that answer your
question yes it does thank you very much
great now we have M here is there
anybody else who has a question along
those lines for
her I do just want to point out one more
thing as well um if I if I
may thank you uh I just wanted to point
out the the federal piece of this so
centers for Medicare and Medicaid
services came out with many waivers um
that
that kind of changed the regulations um
made things more lenient uh gave the
nursing homes and hospitals and others
the ability to perform in a way that
would allow them to to meet the
emergency that was occurring and um and
and there's so many of them I can't even
I can't even tell you how many of them
there are um that that CMS came out with
the the one thing about putting the CMS
waivers into this statute and I just I
just wanted to point out that because
the W the waiver is issued by the
federal government its compliance the
compliance of the health facilities with
those waivers is up to the federal
government it's not up to the state to
make a determination as to whether or
not the state of New Hampshire to make a
determination as to whether or not those
facilities were in compliance or were
not in compliance with those regulations
so in in putting um
the federal laws or the federal waivers
I should say waivers to those
regulations in this it may give people a
little bit of a false hope or a false
sense of security that they won't be uh
held liable for um things that may have
occurred that were in line with the
waivers because it's really up to CMS to
make that decision one way or the other
so I just want to point that out uh
certainly the Department's you know not
not concerned but I just I just want the
committee to know um that that that is
something that we identified and just
wanted to point out so I happy to answer
any
questions same none uh let me ask again
is some of the gray on the
line Mr chairman I just heard from
Senator Gray he's currently chairing the
Senate electional Municipal Affairs
committee he is trying to get somebody
to take over that gavel so he can switch
zooms and join you uh and he's going to
get here as soon as he can thank you
very much I have um a number of people
signed up to testify about this bill but
because it's three bills um my guess is
that some of you are going to be
interested in one part and not another
and so let me ask those of you who have
signed up to testify are interested in
part one clarifying the Medicaid spin
down requirements please raise a hand
hand we're going to call on you do not
testify about part two or
three okay Senator gray is available
right now um hold the previous thought
and Senator gray please uh um speak to
part
three I think they just promoted me to a
panelist so I'm here
um you did did you guys have questions
from I'm told I'm Senator Gray from
district
6 the chair recognizes representative
Marsh with a question on part three uh
thank you Senator gray for uh joining us
uh the committee's received a number of
emails uh saying that an overdose
prevention uh program was removed from
this section of the bill in the Senate
uh could you clarify uh uh the details
of that
uh the there was a provision in there
for overdose and I believe to the best
of my uh memory you know it has been a
few weeks now U that we thought that
that was adequately covered in a
different bill that we were supporting
uh and so that it was removed from this
one thank you thank you any other
questions about part three facil
gray
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Senator gray for being here could
you have somebody send us a reference to
where the um other where the opp program
may be found in another legislation that
would be very helpful I will check on
that U and try to get it to you to
representative Weber thank you very much
Senator anyone else
see no
hands seeing no one thank you Senator
gray all right uh if you do have any
other questions please uh email them to
me I'm chairing a committee meeting on
the uh another Zoom link and I would
appreciate the
emails thank now I want to go back and
call those who are interested in
testifying on part one and part one only
to please raise your hand we will be
bringing you
in Melissa Saint SE is the only one res
all right Melissa Saint SI please I I
apologize I didn't lower my hand from
when I spoke earlier I will do so now
anyone else who is interested in
testifying on part
one
then we will move to part two um
the relative to automated Pharmacy
systems if you signed up to testify and
wish to speak to part two uh please
raise a hand and we'll bring you in one
at a
time Henry V is the only one with his
hand all right I read The Lure and um I
also read Jody Fen as well so you're
called in one or both hello uh good
morning Mr chairman this is Henry veu um
I'm here on behalf of Partners Pharmacy
and Jody fenin from Partners Pharmacy is
also here this morning um if possible if
we both could go at the same time I
think it'd be much more efficient for
your
committee yes go ahead yody are you
there yes yes I I do apologize I'm at an
airport so there's a lot of background
noise so on mute when I'm not speaking
all right um I I'll just give a little
history of why this section is in here
um so Partners Pharmacy approached uh
the Board of Pharmacy last June about uh
the ability to do automated Pharmacy
systems in long-term care facilities
here in New Hampshire and made a
presentation to the board uh last summer
um and the response from the board was
that um while it had no issues obviously
with uh the systems it felt that uh the
organization needed to uh come to the
legislature to get the statutory
authority to move forward with this um
which was a little confusing uh because
uh in RSA
3185 uh a 15 uh which speaks to
rulemaking Authority for the board it
directs the board to develop rules on
automated Pharmacy systems and long-term
care facilities additionally in RSA
318 uh 42 it speaks to automated
Pharmacy systems there too but um
nonetheless um we approached uh Senator
Carson uh to bring a bill in uh to give
the statutory authority to the board to
adopt these rules um and that is what
you have before you today um since this
bill has passed the Senate uh We've
Spoken uh with representative Merchant
um he's very familiar with uh Pharmacy
issues and um we also spoke with Bob
Stout who is uh a past chair of the
Board of Pharmacy and who was actually
uh working uh with a group uh including
some individuals on the board to try to
put uh some Draft rules together um and
representative Merchant I'll let him
speak to his Amendment but his Amendment
would make it much more simpler and
basically refer to what we believe is
already the statutory Authority in the
law and just basically direct the board
to develop the rules so um as Grant
bossy mentioned uh there was no
opposition at all to this in the Senate
um it is already being done in hospital
facilities
um and this would uh essentially allow
it in the long-term care facilities jod
uh is on the line two in case there are
any questions about these um uh systems
and I know there was a question about uh
uh what kinds of drugs are from
representative woods and I think jod
Jody uh is prepared to answer that
question so maybe Jody I'll toss it over
to
you thank you uh thank you Henry
um yes to answer the question first from
representative kerk um typically we
would put controlled substances into the
Automated machine along with
non-controlled substances um we would
follow whatever guidance there is or
registration that's required by the
individual State as well as uh obtaining
a DEA ads registration for off-site uh
storage or keep ing of controlled
substances that belong to the pharmacy
um and then we do have um very stringent
reconciliation processes to maintain the
um integrity and and security of those
Controlled Substances while they are off
site um I guess additionally I I will
just comment um that this automation has
been used since 2002 and I apologize for
the noise in the background um and
currently there are
approximately 14 plus of the automation
that we use um in nursing facilities um
in 13 different
states and um we find that it is
extremely beneficial it's been very
beneficial we've had the most
installations um ever in a year during
covid time because of the benefits of
medication availability right on site
for new Admissions and changes in
condition um additionally it does
benefit infection contr control because
the nurses are they get the medications
in a little envelope they administer and
then they you know shred destroy that
envelope there isn't any continual
handling of of medication cards or vials
or other packaging um and the security
measures of maintaining the controls in
the Automated machine with every
transaction being tracked um for every
person that logs in gets a medication
package meaning a licensed Health Care
person not just anyone um that is all
tracked and um has enhanced safety for
management of controlled substances in
the nursing
facilities so those are the those are
the Prime benefits of it does anyone
have any questions for me that I may
need to answer or be able to answer for
you representative
caner yes thank you very much yes uh
thank you for the answer on schedule to
the the thing I just want to understand
a little bit better and I think I got it
from what you're saying but I want to
clarify so these systems are like
basically a machine that will dispense
uh prepackaged the dose so is it
dispensing a unit dose for a given
individual at a given time uh or is it
just uh distrib disseminating or I
should say um dis dispensing the entire
set for all of that Wing or how does
this actually work certainly that that's
a great question um the medications we
there's a I'm going to call like an
automatic
run that's set up where all the
medications for like say residents of a
wing for their morning Med pass would be
packaged but they're packaged individual
resident it's labeled per resident the
medications with a description are on an
envelope and then the nurse has that to
administer to that specific resident
they can also obtain if there's a new
order or an emergency order individual
doses that are on the resident's profile
that would be packaged you know a one
you know onetime dose and all of that is
tracked to say when it was requested and
who obtained it who took it out of the
machine when it was packaged follow up
follow up and can it handle a PRN
medication as well absolutely absolutely
if it's on the patients profile after
it's been entered into the system by the
pharmacy and reviewed by the pharmacist
then a PRN dose can be removed with all
the parameters that exist on a PRN dose
such as frequency it can't be if it's um
can be given every four hours um as
needed they can't get it every two hours
they can only get it every 4 hours
there's a lock out on the time
frame okay thank
you any further questions uh
representative pushman thank you thank
you Mr chair thank
you can can the members hear me who are
at
home um question is um
for um the partners uh people can you
guys explain will this how will this
help um with new admits if there's
no like for instance in a nursing home
sometimes we'll get a new admission and
they have medication orders that we
don't have on site will this system help
that is their
um like a an an emergency kit in this
machine
that can
dispense medications we don't have on
site already yeah certainly
representative kushman how me how it
works there's um up to 176 medications
tablets or capsules in um available in
the machine and it is based on the
typical prescribing habits of the
Physicians and nurse practitioners and
um the practitioners in that area and
that we modify it to be unique and then
there's also emergency type meds IVs and
so forth um when a new admission comes
in let's say someone's admitted this
morning those orders come over to the
pharmacy electronically or faxed over
however the the facility transmits them
once they're entered into our operating
system and a pharmacist reviews them
meaning looks for allergies proper
dosing drug interactions and so forth
then as soon as the pharmacist literally
hits the key and says this order or you
know each of these indiv ual orders are
appropriate and approved within
approximately 2 minutes um just as long
as it takes for it to electronically
transfer the nurse could go to that
machine and get that first dose out um
so when someone comes in they don't have
to wait for the driver to deliver the
meds that evening they could get them
you know and start their medications the
vast majority of them um would be able
to be started um right from the machine
you know within a short period of time
after their ad and the facility provides
orders anything that's not in the
machine the pharmacy delivers you know
on an urgent basis um you know or with
the routine delivery depending on what
the need is um and I will go back to
representative coner the comment about
the Controlled Substances the pharmacy
obtains appropriate prescriptions to
meet all the um DEA requirements for
Controlled Substances um you know we we
have all of that documentation as well
so that that need doesn't change we need
to get the proper prescriptions from the
prescriber but we can take those
vs so thank you answer a question yes
thank you all right you're welcome well
we have the partners partners here um I
just want to make sure that you're okay
with the removal of sections two three
and four by Amendment because section
five says the board shall adopt rules so
are you okay should we get an amendment
removing two three and four yes sir go
ahead go ahead yes I'll I'll let you
speak to it too also Jody but yes uh
we're fine with that we basically just
want the Board of Pharmacy to feel
confident that they have the statutory
authority to move forward with this um
we approached the board back like I said
last June uh we have the January 1
2022 date in there to hopefully put this
on the front burner for the board uh to
to move forward with the rules so uh
we're fine uh with removing those other
uh sections those will get uh done in
the rules um and and the the um the
statute does speak to what the needs to
be included in the rules so um we're
fine with uh removing those sections if
that's what the committee wants to do
representative
Woods uh thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you Miss fenin and Mr AO for taking my
question uh most of them have been I had
several questions about the process uh
just uh you mentioned that if the
medication is not in uh the the cart as
as it's called on the floors um the it
can be refreshed uh from um a carrier
what's the turnaround say it's at 2 in
the morning uh and someone comes down
with a dire uh diagnosis and needs um um
say an antibiotic an IV antibi biotic or
something like that uh what what is the
reliable time frame uh not the average
but what's what's a reliable time frame
to get that
medication um that that time frame if
it's not available in the machine would
be what we we would typically commit to
for um you know stat urgent medication
which would probably be in the range of
you know two three hours which is which
is quite typical by the time you would
fill it in you know transport it to
wherever that would be um you know so
that commitment doesn't change just
because the automation is in the
building um you know we still hold by
that commitment we don't say you know
sorry we we'll send it tomorrow kind of
thing that doesn't you know we don't do
that we still hold to it um rapid
turnaround for Urgent
needs thank
you any further
questions well thank you so much for
bringing your testimony thank you any
thank
you have anything to share or ask on
part two from the people who signed up
to
speak please raise your
hand not seeing any hands not seeing any
hands then we'll move on to card three
relative to health facilities providing
care in the declared
emergency anyone wishing to speak to
part three please raise your
hand Mr chair we have three people uh
now four the first one is John fryberg
who I have allowed him to talk joh
fryberg welcome thank you Mr chairman
and members of the committee can you
hear me okay yes perfect good morning my
name is John fryberg and I'm the chief
legal officer of solution Health
Solution health is the not for-profit
parent organization of Elliott health
system in Manchester and Southern New
Hampshire health system in nashwa I'm
very grateful for the chance to briefly
speak to you this morning in favor of
part three of SB 149 uh I find it
fascinating and somewhat difficult to
wrap my head around that the term
covid-19 was entirely unknown to most of
us until about 14 months ago it was
announced as the name of the then
rapidly spreading novel Corona virus on
February 11th of last year between that
time and right around this time last
year in May our country our world um and
especially the healthc care and
Emergency Management Systems within our
communities faced unprecedented and in
many ways unforeseen challenges um over
the course of just days many of you will
recall healthc care facilities and their
personnel simultaneously grappled with
the challenge of on the one hand
systematically shutting down all normal
non-emergent activities just like
virtually all other areas of our society
uh complying with stay-at-home orders
and directives while at the very same
time and in parallel gearing up as never
before to ready ourselves for the
projected and potentially overwhelming
and unman manageable surges of infected
patients the patient surges did come
mercifully however again you will recall
in most regions of the United States New
Hampshire included hospitals and other
medical facilities were able to keep
Pace with spikes of patients in need of
Emergency Services both covid related
and otherwise health care facilities and
providers were able to effectively rise
to meet this emergency in large part
because state and federal authorities
ities issued various orders rules and
waivers permitting changes in the ways
that healthc care was delivered changes
necessary to respond to covid and which
would not have been permitted but for
such governmental permission s SP 149
part three is narrowly tailored to
ensure that New Hampshire law just like
virtually if not literally every other
state extends protection from civil
liability to licensed Healthcare
facilities and their personnel for
actions in compliance with a covid
related emergency order rule or waiver
from state or federal authorities
briefly a few examples of the actions to
comply with covid related orders rules
and waivers include the following
deferring or delaying non-emergent care
to support stay-at-home orders and
preserving precious resources such as
ventilators and PPE and Personnel
utilizing tah Health visits uh in
situations which insurance and
government payment pro programs would
not have
previously provided
reimbursement expanding inpatient
capacity by opening asc's Alternative
Care sites such as at Southern New
Hampshire University and in Lebanon and
in nasua and as well as locations uh on
H hospital and healthare campuses that
were not previously licensed for the
delivery of care but were licensed under
special emergency authorization from
Health and Human Services limiting and
prohibiting visitors in our facilities
triage screening ER patients and parking
lots and diverting non-co patients away
from ERS to other locations for
screening and stabilization sourcing and
utilizing PPE in non-traditional ways
and simplifying some of the
documentation and discharge planning
requirements that were previously
required uh especially by CMS on the
federal level now an often expressed
anxiety on the parts of Physicians
nurses and other Health Care
Professionals during this time and still
is whether these very same actions to
comply with government directives could
later give rise to possible civil
liability in the context of a negligence
claim in other words could following
these orders rules and or waivers be
pointed to as evidence of an action
below the standard of care during
so-called normal times the purpose of SB
149 part 3 is to avoid such an
inequitable situation such an untenable
situation to to protect those who acted
as directed under Emergency Management
Authority to in order to protect each of
us during the State of Emergency the New
Hampshire Department of Justice through
an opinion of the Attorney General dated
April 22nd 2020 confirmed that agent
that agency interprets RSA 21p as indeed
covering healthc care workers following
covid guidance as Emergency Management
activity while we in healthcare are
extremely grateful for this position of
the Department of Justice respectfully
an opinion from the executive branch is
simply persuasive not dispositive on the
matter and while we consider the AG's
opinion to be entirely correct and
persuasive it is no substitute for a
succinct and clear expression of the
legislator's intent so simply put 13
lines of legislation clarifying RSA 21p
is greatly preferable to a five-page
analysis from the executive branch as
helpful as the latter may be in closing
I would simply note that there was uh no
opposition in the Senate other than a
technical issue raised by the trial
lawers Association that we were able to
resolve through discussions and we added
on two uh final sentences to the
proposed language and that uh remedied
and assuaged them of any concerns and
this uh bill passed unanimously through
the Senate so again thank you for your
support of this important effort to
ensure that New Hampshire's Healthcare
facilities and providers are not later
penalized in the context of civil
litigation for what they were called
upon to do in order to protect each of
us our families and our communities
during this unprecedented Public Health
Emergency I've submitted written
testimony and I'm also happy to answer
any of your questions thank you very
much thank you councelor any questions
from the
committee um I think that is
representative
Shapiro I can't get unmuted to testify
the
Senate
[Music]
ahead Mr chair and thank you for taking
this question um apart from civil
liability I was wondering if there are
any issues with professional liability
in terms of Licensing and um code of
ethics for specific providers in terms
of if there are conflicts
between what they can do under emergency
orders and what their professional code
of ethics say
I'm I know this is a different issue but
is this covered at all yeah that's a
fantastic question and I think it's not
clearly covered by this because we tried
to narrowly draft this to dock into 21
P's immunity from civil liability I
think that will unfortunately be
something we have to work through with
the agencies the AG's office uh and with
the courts later down the road in a
perfect world which we're certainly not
in right now uh we would contemplate
that sort of professional uh um ethics
or lens your standard issue um I think
it one could make an argument pretty
persuasively that that's derivative of
this liability immunity but this does
not address that head-on representative
I think that's something to be worked
through uh with the courts and with
those licensing boards later uh but it's
a fantastic issue that I will put my
thinking cap on about and and see if we
can perhaps address
later thank you thank
you anyone else Mr chair
I have a question uh representative
fome thank you Mr chairman um thank you
Mr fber for taking my question I well as
I was reading this um what came to my
mind uh was the whole situation of
course in New York State uh where
infected patients were sent back to the
nursing homes which caused even
greater um spread of the virus in an in
a vulnerable
population
uh would there
be room in here if
a if someone did not take the time to
think through what that would
do
and it was ordered for them to do
it but um would they still be could they
still be held liable you know I'm just
thinking about the whole situation in
New York and how this might uh play out
in a situation like that yeah yeah so
that's a great example of where uh you
can't legislate an answer as this body
certainly knows better than I to every
possible permutation of the facts and
that's a great one that will probably uh
have to be dealt with down the road in
the courts we tried to provide language
that would allow us to have a
conversation around those sorts of
topics with the final the second to last
sentence indicating that this uh only
applies when there's an attempt or
reasonable attempt at compliance and
that language is used earlier on um the
that is intended to convey the fact this
is not a blanket immunity that when you
follow that you necessarily everything
relating to it is somehow inoculated
from liability but rather the party
asserting immunity would have to make
clear in plain and convince a finder a
fact that they indeed were complying
with the guidance or reasonably that's
the key word attempting to comply
unreasonable attempts or uh actions
beyond the four corners of the actual
guidance uh that may be derivative of
that guidance would not likely uh
provide that kind of immunity so there's
going to be a fact byct analysis uh on
on each case uh and and that's why that
language was put in there so that's
something to be worked out through the
courts later but we thought this was a
good framework to at least clarify some
of these parameters of liability
limitation and then deal with the actual
Nuance situation ations later through
the court so that's that's a great
example of where we'll have to figure
that out later but this gives us a great
jumping off point to make the arguments
much more clearly than the AG's opinion
um which again is helpful and persuasive
but not dispositive um gives
us thank you thank you representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question as a followup
to representative
alome it occurs to me that there are
actually two parts here and one is the
reasonable efforts of the actors were
talking about to follow an an order but
the other is the contents of the order
and am I correct in understanding that
this bill simply speaks to the
facilities that are try and
practitioners that are trying to carry
out the order rather than those who
issued the order where correctly or
incorrectly to begin
with 100% correct representative Weber
that's exactly what it's intended to
address not the latter only the former
okay thank you thank you anyone
else thank you very much
anyone wishing to
testify to section three please raise a
hand David Creer and Laura burn and Paul
men all right David Creer please from
biia of New
Hampshire hi thank you very much for
allowing me to speak and uh I'm actually
really happy I got to go after John
fryberg who did a much better job than I
would have uh so my testimony will be
very short uh the business and industry
Association of New Hampshire I should
say I'm David career director of public
policy at uh the business and industry
Association of New Hampshire uh Bia
supports part three of this bill uh we
have no position on the rest of it um
and the reason being is that healthc
care facilities are just trying to do
their best uh with uh providing care
during a pandemic which is Quite a feat
um and they shouldn't be uh subject to
lawsuits uh as a result of trying to
comply with emergency orders and trying
to do uh the best that they can during
the pandemic uh with that I'm happy to
take any questions um but like I said I
think uh John pyber did a much better
job at answering those
questions see no questions thank you
thank you chair recognizes Marissa Chase
from the New Hampshire Association for
justice good morning repres
Representatives can you hear me
okay yes yes thank you uh for the record
my name is Marissa Chase I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Association for justice uh Statewide
Professional Association of attorneys
and um I want to thank uh John fryberg
for the time he took in um working with
our organization and coming up with that
carefully crafted language you see in
part three um our fear was that this um
you know C originally codifying the
Attorney General's opinion without um
you know this better language I think um
that John and some of our folks hammered
out together um that it could be used
over broadly to construe into acts not
taken during an emergency so again we
are happy with this language again want
to thank attorney fryberg and um ask the
committee to support the language as
is thank you very much any
questions
thank you for your testimony thank
you recognizes Paul
Mahan good morning chairman members of
the committee for the record Paula minan
Senior vice president state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all
our hospitals in the state um we wish to
comment on part three only of Senate
Bill 149 and we are very supportive of
that section regarding health care
facilities providing care in a declared
emergency and as Mr Creer said um I will
do the same um attorney fryberg did an
excellent job outlining what the what
that section does um and I did um so I
will not repeat that um I just wanted to
express our um strong support for this
section of the bill I did provide a link
to the attorney general's um opinion
just for your edification and as um Miss
Chase said they did um amend the bill um
working together with attorney Friedberg
um which we are F which we completely
support um but I just thought it would
be helpful for your the record to have
the Attorney General's original opinion
back from April of 2020 um and I again
we support the bill and um thank you so
much for allowing us to provide our
comments any questions from M
mad
seeing one thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to speak to any part of this bill
Laura
burn Laura burn yes thank
you hello can you hear me yes oh great
hi um thank you for um taking my
comments I'm Laura burn I'm the
executive director of the HIV hcv
Resource Center Center in Lebanon New
Hampshire we're an aid service
organization and we run syringe service
programming in Grafton and Sullivan
County and in Vermont and um it was my
understanding that um this bill could
possibly pave the way for overdose
prevention centers although that part
got taken out so I was going to request
adding it back in um overdose prevention
programs are an evidence-based harm
reduction strategy that allows an
individual to consume drugs under the
supervision of Staff trained to
intervene um if that person
overdoses and um every year we see our
clients overdosing and die so it would
be just one other great strategy to um
reduce the likelihood of fatal overdose
they also enhance con connections to
critical Social Services by offering
referrals to substance use disorder
treatment housing medical and Mental
Health Care other social services
there're about6 65 over dust prevention
programs operating in 10 countries in
the
world um research has also demonstrated
these programs decrease the use of
Emergency Medical Services and reduce
public drug use and syringe debris so I
just wanted to request if there was the
possibility of forming a study
commission to study the impact of
opening overd us prevention center in
New Hampshire thank you if anyone wishes
to work with Laura Buren on an
amendment that is ruled Germain to the
bill for us to look at when we exec the
bill next week please contact Miss
burn thank you thank you um
representative
McKay I may have missed this but the
under the fiscal note it says that they
have been unable to come up with a
fiscal note and that on available it
would be sent to the Senate I wonder if
there is a
f if so we should know
that I'm reading it that this is the
Senate's fiscal
note but I don't
know yeah um we will be executing this
Bill next week and that's something that
the fiscal note writers could be asked
so
there yes um if you look on the general
court website the current talking
recognizing
um representative
kushman who is doing some research um I
was just looking at the bill on the
general court website and it does have a
fiscal note and it um there are zeros
across every section of the fiscal
note is this fiscal note the same as
this fiscal
note I didn't get that one I didn't get
that one
either so but
probably representative McKay do you
have that fiscal
note okay gosh I mean why should I be
the chosen one but I have a fiscal note
and representative Keem does as well
so I have it it was sent to our um email
it was emailed to
us
okay yes uh representative H um chairman
Pearson uh with regards to Laura Baron's
uh
request
um uh Senator Gray he's not here so I
can't ask him mentioned that they took
that out that section out because there
was a bill another bill that covered
that and does anyone know what that bill
number is by any
chance Senator Grace said that he would
be getting back to us with what that
bill is and once again we have until
next week to nail that down because if
another bill covers this the point
becomes Moot and if not if we discover
that in the next few days that either
this doesn't exist or it isn't in to the
degree we'd like then any one or more of
us can work with Miss burn to come up
with an amendment that we will look at
during the exec session next
week point of procedure Mr
chairman State your point uh thank you
uh couple of things one of which is I
wonder if Miss Dyer could be asked to
resend the fiscal note when she has a
minute and secondly I
wonder uh if you could perhaps call
Senator Waters who is waiting to testify
on this particular issue and who has
actually sent us the bill as originally
drafted so he might be able to clarify
an awful lot of those issues thank you
very much uh Senator Waters is cent of
the waters in the
room also if I can just point out
Christina has just sent that s SP 149
fiscal note and I've just checked it it
is what's currently on the PDF of the
website okay is Senator Waters in the
room uh yes Mr chairman thank you sir
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee Senator David Waters from
District 4 and I was the the original
sponsor of the bill that became part of
this Omnibus on harm reduction overdose
prevention program and um I thinkk I
thank the committee for giving me a
moment and The Advocates who wanted to
um bring this before you for a moment to
talk um you had some description of it a
little bit earlier and if you at the
language of the bill um you'll see what
was before the Senate and I just want to
note um that Senator gray and the and
and all the members of the Senate Health
Human Services voted in favor of
this and it passed the Senate on the
floor from the policy committee 23
to1 it was sent to finance and there was
some objection raised uh to it uh in the
finance and that turned the vote when it
came back to the
floor Senator gray um I won't speak for
him but there were several parts removed
from this bill and uh it's possible that
there were some other part um that had
other things in legislation but I will
say that we do not have harm reduction
programs and overdose prevention
programs like this uh anywhere else or
any other bill that I'm I'm aware
of and um what the point of this bill is
is harm reduction and uh you know I
really applaud governor sonunu for
setting up the doorways program um I
serve on the governor's Commission
Alcohol and Other Drugs and certainly
New Hampshire has made great strides and
many efforts and spent uh you know money
and um also receive money through the
federal delegation to help deal with the
um opioid crisis and we have made a lot
of progress but people in the recovery
Community feel that the one missing
piece all along has been harm
reduction that if we create these um
sites where people can consume drugs uh
under
supervision um where they can uh receive
medical advice and care if necessary
that this is a great next step in
fighting the opioid crisis and frankly
would save lives in New Hampshire right
now the important thing to note about
this uh proposal is it is entirely
enabling
legislation it enables a municipality to
make a decision through the public a
vote of the public body after public
hearings to Institute such a program it
may in fact look very familiar to you
because it is patterned almost exactly
upon the uh legislation you remember
representative Hannon and uh Senator
gray and I and others worked on for the
needle exchange program so it set up in
Ju in just that way that um there would
be criteria established through Rules by
Health and Human
Services as to what kind of
organization uh would be able to host
such a site and there's very
particular um listing here of the kinds
of um facility and also the kinds of
staff and the and particularly the kinds
of services that would need to be
offered there again quite similar to
what we see uh in Needle Exchange um
program what is also crucial here is
that this program could be adopted by
the public body of municipality only
after it taken certain steps
particularly with local law
enforcement uh with health and human
services and others to ensure that
public concerns are met and the public G
good is served by it it also asked that
Health and Human Services would conduct
a review and study of such a program so
we would have some real data as to how
it works for us as was mentioned there
are 165 programs in 10 different uh
countries um for a little context the
United States uh Philadelphia was on
track to establish uh one and there have
been two different Court rulings down
there and the governor asked them to
delay due to covid and implementing it
um so that's a little uncertain though I
will say that the um New Administration
has mentioned harm reduction programs
and overdose prevention programs for the
uh first time and there's some sense
that they will be looked upon favorably
uh by the federal
government so um I I save lives um I
think it's a program that as described
here would work that's what health human
services and the Senate voted for it
unanimously and we had a 23 to1 vote on
the policy um but some objections were
raised about providing such a service um
some objections were raised about
whether they could be S safely operated
and then and some objections were raised
about really um philosophically saying
that uh this is this is people who was
addicted as own fault and the state um
Can has provided a lot of services but
um shouldn't do this so I don't mean to
represent what my some of my colleagues
said but I think it's important for you
to hear why what was a unanimous vote
nearly as unanimous um was overturned at
another point in time um I think it's
worth considering for your committee um
if it decides that it doesn't want to
add this back into the bill and wants to
consider a um a study I'd be happy to
work with The Advocates on that but
again Mr chairman I really want to thank
you so much for allowing the opportunity
for this to get to to discuss uh before
you this is a large drill in a busy day
so I'd be happy to take any questions uh
the chair has a question says
representative Mark Pearson it has been
said that the substance of your part
three is covered in another bill
um what is that other
Bill thank you m thanks for the question
I again I I won't speak for Senator gr
but I'm not aware that there is any such
Bill and as I said there were several
parts of this that were removed and
perhaps that's that's what he's
remembering but I I don't want to speak
for him but um that that was not
something that was brought up either in
the hearing or on either of the debates
on the Senate
4 my followup question
is uh the bill that we have before us
presently
subject to an amendment on part two is
probably going to sail out of here
that's my guess but if part your part
three were added it sounds like there
may be a sticking spot in the Senate and
if it were added it might jeopardize the
entire new
bill um might a better way be adding a
line item that makes a study committee
on
um harm reduction facilities in your
opinion well thank you for that followup
and um you know I I uh respect your the
wisdom of the house and um I think this
is an important way to save lives and if
it seems that a study um out based on
what is outlined uh in in here would be
a way to move forward I I think that is
a is a is an excellent idea and thank
you my fear would be that if we passed
it with your section three added and it
goes to a committee of conference the
Senate might reiterate its objection to
your part free and the whole thing dies
so that is the reason behind my maybe a
study committee to bring forth a harm
reduction program bill as a standalone
Bill might not only serve what you're
trying to do but keep the Pres Bill we
have before Us
Alive um thank you for that I be happy
to work with any member of the committee
to craft such an amendment with The
Advocates and thank you again and thank
you Senator and if there are folks in
this committee who would like to work
with Senator waters for an amendment to
add a study committee please be in touch
with
him there are still
questionsa uh Weber's hand up thank you
um I I have I have a comment on the uh
process of of Committees of
conference uh there's no reason why if
one gets into a committee of conference
and that
particular aspect of the be bill becomes
a sticking point it is absolutely
possible that the whole thing dies but
the other possibility of course is that
it's just removed again so it's not an
All or Nothing proposition but I concede
that there are issues
of that that need to be uh tactics that
need to be considered but my question
for Senator Waters is that
um when the bill when the section was
removed in the finance committee I
understand some of the uh policy
objections but were there actual Finance
objections in the finance committee or
were the objections there on a policy
basis thank you for your question uh I'm
not aware of any objections on a on a
financial basis um Health and Human
Services didn't bring forward any
concerns about cost uh and it was felt
that grants that certainly would be a
lot of Grant support for um this if a
municipality decide to move forward it
really was um some objections which you
know it had passed 23 to1 before but
some objections
arose after that and that you know that
that happens sometimes doesn't it but uh
there were not there were not um Finance
uh objections
um that I that I'm aware of and ever
being
made thank you very much representative
Woods no I my hands not up sorry it
might be floaters after my eye surgery
okay uh is there any other hand up just
uh former representative Hannon wants to
testify former representative and
alumnus of this committee Hannon you are
recognized to speak
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee uh my name is Joe Hannon uh
like you heard others say that I was
very involved with the syringe uh
service Bill uh with Senator Waters and
Senator gray and and many of you also on
this committee
um the fact that it was removed I
understand some of the objections but I
do think that at the very least it needs
to be studied at a little bit more of a
level than just a committee level I
think it should be studied as a
commission
uh I have uh submitted uh actual
language that'll save everyone some time
everyone wants to work on a bill I
already have the language completely
drafted if he'd like to amend it in some
way that's fine I'd be happy to discuss
it but I submitted that to
representative salaway and I believe he
shared it with other members of the
committee I'm not sure if everyone has
it yet um so I I've been actively
involved with seren service programs in
the state and that was a big step in
harm reduction uh in this in New
Hampshire in 2020 according to the
office of National Drug control policy
overdose deaths Rose by
16.6% based on comparison between
January and April of the previous year
Nationwide in New Hampshire that wasn't
the case Manchester saw a 28% decrease
in opioid related overdose deaths in
2020 compared to
2019 um there was a serin service
program that was instituted not long
before that in Manchester and also so we
had one previously in the Sea Coast we
had done a survey of our residents and
over 3,000 overdoses had been reversed
by members of our uh Exchange program in
the Queen City 3,000 overdoses since the
Inception uh at the in in that City
that's more than were reversed in the
hospitals and by the the paramedics in
that area not to diminish their their
efforts but the efforts were uh most
substantial in the front lines with the
people who were actually involved in the
process so I'd like to also say that uh
if we do a study commission we can study
the standards for bre practices look at
the data that's been out there like the
previous speaker La burn said this has
been involved in at least 10 other
countries there are over 165 programs
around the world we could also discuss
and study the feasibility of
implementing these programs in New
Hampshire where can they be best
utilized if at all so even if you're not
in favor of such a program for whatever
reason reason that commission would have
the ability to discuss whether it's
actually feasible and where it can be
best done in New Hampshire um I'd be
happy to take any questions but this is
something that is absolutely
life-saving um if we can reduce overdose
deaths and overdoses in general by
having these kind of facilities in the
future possibly we could decrease HIV
hepatitis C transmission overdose deaths
we can increase referrals to treatment
and Recovery Services and other
um other other services for social
services for people that are high risk
or homeless uninsured or low income and
also and this is a very timely issue uh
overdoses and uh infections and other
problems associated with improper uh
substance use could be um actually do
contribute to hospital usage and
increased uses in the H increased uses
in the hospital can actually take away
uh the time of healthc care providers to
treat other illnesses like covid
infections and other life-threatening
illnesses so this does free up this the
uh Health Care um system we have it also
will save an incredible amount of money
and uh not just money in tangible assets
but in in the fact that it will also
save lives and um help get people into
treatment and recovery so I the language
is there if I'd like to uh I'd like I'd
be happy to work with anyone in the
future and um I'd be happy to take any
questions whatsoever thank
youa
F thank you uh chairman Pearson um thank
you Mr Hannon for taking my question I
have recently been appointed to uh the
drug overdose fatality review commission
um so I would really like to get the
language uh sent to me for your
Amendment um I have not familiarized
myself too much yet with this new
commission I've been assigned to but
would that be an appropriate commission
that already exists that could could uh
review
this uh absolutely I don't believe it
was on um it's it's actually in the on
the list I have 12 members but on
obviously this is just a basic framework
uh a lot of it was taken from the
syringe uh the the the commission to
study hypodermic needles and syringes
which I was the chair of that commission
um we did change it a little bit uh to
add a few members but I'd be happy to
add that commission to this
list okay um yeah if you would follow
send me that I'm sorry yes
yes I'll send it to all members of the
committee for the questions for your
representative
Solway uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you representative Hannon for taking my
question uh uh so a a two-part question
please um Senator gray alluded to Prior
legislation that obviated the need for
this section of the bill do you have any
familiarity with that
legislation uh I haven't talked to
Senator gray recently but I I can I will
ask him I haven't seen any specific
legislation and I I went through the
last Senate calendar to see if there
were amendments but maybe there's
something else that I'm I missed okay uh
thank you a followup Please Mr chairman
um uh would it be appropriate for us to
bring in two amendments this is the
recommendation of uh one of my
colleagues um uh representative Weber uh
one that would bring back the original
language and a second amendment to
establish a commission uh so that we can
go either way we then have a choice in
executive
session options are good
okay uh thank you very much and thanks
to representative Weber thank
you I saw a hand I thought I did I guess
I
didn't representative
McKay like representative fos I also was
recently appointed to the
opioid trust
fund and it's been I think it has like
23 members it's a huge organization
but again it deals with
financing and it's brand new Senator
rosenal is the first chair I'm the bus
chair so again I think it's pertinent to
this
question thank you representative
McKay last
call see see no hands from anyone uh
this closes the hearing on Senate Bill
149 for the record by the deadline 35
people signed in in support two in
opposition one
neutral and in terms of one we next meet
I have been shooting for next
Tuesday and uh I'm told that is not
available a room with equipment is not
so they suggested Monday I reminded them
the deadline for notification is passed
on that and now we're trying to figure
out between Wednesday and Thursday and
when I know you'll know but um we've got
some possibilities of amendments to come
forth on this please get them done
earlier rather than later and circulate
them to all of us so we can read them
[Music]
ahead now I open the hearing on Senate
Bill 74 relative to Advanced directives
for Health Care
decisions and again uh listed as Prime
sponsor Senator Sherman but as Dr
Sherman he is busy today who's going to
introduce Senate B 74 to Us remote
Senate State House 100 has it hand
remote
100 I represent Pearson chairman Pearson
members of the committee for the record
my name is Jenny Horgan I am the
legislative Aid to Senator Tom Sherman
and if it's all right with you I'd like
to introduce Senate Bill 74 on behalf of
Senator Sherman it is certainly all
right with me go ahead wonderful thank
you chairman and members of the
committee um very grateful and happy to
be in front of you all to see so many
familiar faces today Senate Bill 74 is
relative to Advanced directives for
Health Care decisions and I have a
letter that we did submit to the
committee that Senator Sherman requested
that I read into the record if that is
okay it is okay all right so to The
Honorable members of the House committee
on Health and Human Services and elderly
Affairs for the record my name is
Senator Tom Sherman representing Senate
District 24 which includes 11 towns on
the New Hampshire sea coasts I apologize
for not being able to be there in person
but I am scheduled to be working at the
hospital in end ocopy today I've asked
my legislative Aid Jenny Horan to read
this introduction of my bill Senate Bill
74 relative to Advanced directives for
healthcare decisions this bill was
brought to me by a coalition of people
who work in health care the legal
profession and patient advocacy the goal
of the bill is to update the New
Hampshire statute relative to Advanced
direct directives surrogacy living wills
pulst and other processes that ensure
New Hampshire residents Healthcare
directives are documented in the event
they are no longer able to make their
own health care decisions there are
several people here today with a great
deal of expertise on these issues who
will be testifying before your committee
they should be able to answer any
questions you may have while the bill
does make several adjustments in
terminology and some processes the only
significant policy change is in access
to potentially life-saving research
studies this represents one of the
lessons learned through the covid
pandemic representatives of Dartmouth
Hitchcock are prepared to answer any
questions you may have on this component
of the bill I would like to take this
opportunity to express my profound
gratitude to the many stakeholders who
spent more than 20 hours meeting and
wordsmithing this bill to address every
concern raised this included
representatives of the hospitals
hospices pal of care providers elder law
attorneys the Catholic dicese and many
other provider and advocacy groups
having worked with patients for more
than 35 years as a doctor and having
helped so many of them and their
families work through these difficult
and of often painful decisions I know
firsthand how important this process is
to ensuring that we respect patients
wishes I believe this bill is essential
to making that process as clear as
possible for patients their families and
providers finally I would like to thank
the committee for hearing and
considering the bill I am available if
you have any questions that remain
unanswered after today's testimony
respectfully submitted Senator Tom
Sherman and that would conclude my
testimony Mr chairperson and I would
respectfully ask that you wait for any
questions to be given to the experts as
they are much more well prepared to
answer them than me
you read so well though thank
[Music]
you the chair recognizes Paula minahan
uh again from the the Hampshire Hospital
Association to speak in support of this
bill good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee for the record Paula minan
Senior vice president state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all
our hospitals we are in strong support
of Senate Bill 74 and we do want to
thank Senator Sherman for agreeing to
sponsor this important piece of
legislation we also would like to extend
our thanks to two co-sponsors on your
committee including Representatives
Marsh and woods I will provide you with
a bit of background on the work of the
New Hampshire healthc care decisions
Coalition and why they believe RSA 37j
needed to be amended this bill before
you today is a result of many months of
thoughtful work by the members of the
Coalition some of whom are with you
today and will be testifying they are
experts in the various professions of
pallative Care Medicine Health Care law
in caring for patients I also have with
me today my colleague Peter Ames who's
the executive director of the foundation
for Healthy Communities which is an
affiliate of the hospital Association
whose staff is responsible for
overseeing the healthc care decisions
Coalition I will ask Peter to speak um
if you would oblige um in a minute to
explain the focus of the Coalition but
before that I would like um the
committee to understand that the
Coalition worked over the summer to
draft some modifications to the statute
as rep as Senator Sherman outlined um
what and one of the some of the goals
were to make the language of the various
forms living will durable power of
attorney for Health Care clearer and use
customer friendly language um remove
time constraints on surrogacy and add
surrogate to in addition to an agent
throughout the statute um substitute
practitioner in place of using um
listing healthc care various Healthcare
Providers to make it easier um included
pulst and other sets of physician orders
as allowable forms of portable durable
power um excuse me do not resuscitate
orders clarify that the living will is a
guidance document um that clarifies
individual's wishes and that the
overriding document is the durable power
of attorney for Health Care um
established 18 years old as the minimum
age for surrogacy and being an agent and
uses terminology to reflect um what is
currently used in medical um settings
also Senator Sherman asked that the
statute use gender neutral terminology
which we did throughout the document it
is a very large um St U bill and I
understand that and that's why we have a
lot of um individuals um on that can
address um the legal and the CL clinical
um components so I will defer to them
but um I just wanted to mention that um
after the bill was heard in the Senate
um Senator Sherman did bring together
number of interested stakeholders again
that will be testifying we did spend um
have extensive discussions um some of
them went over two hours at length and
so um with everyone's input encouraged
and and considered the final that is the
final product of the work of the
stakeholder group is what you are seeing
in front of you today um the amended
Bill did pass out of the Senate HHS
committee five to nothing and then
subsequently passed on a unanimous vote
of 24 to nothing in the Senate on April
1 and we are very proud of that because
that shows to me um the significant
input from all the stakeholders that
were interested in this topic um I do
want to make clear that we um that we
did not attempt to change long-standing
policy relative to this statute and as
Senator Sherman had indicated when he
agreed to sponsor the bill he does not
want to weaken the statute he wanted to
make it easier for patients and their
loved ones to understand the forms and
to complete them to properly Express
their wishes and for the providers that
care for these patients to follow those
wishes we are in very strong support of
Senate Bill 74 and we ask that you
support the Bill thank you for the
opportunity to comment and if you would
oblige I would um like to ask my
colleague Peter Ames to speak with the
committee for a few
minutes recogniz Peter Ames and thank
you Miss
mad great good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee my name is
Peter ases I'm the executive director at
the foundation for healthy communities
and I want to thank you for this
opportunity to speak with you this
morning the foundation for Healthy
Communities is an affiliate of the Namer
Hospital Association as you just heard
we are a quality improvement
organization dedicated to advancing
health for all people in New Hampshire
through engaged Partnerships one of
these Partnerships is our healthc care
decisions Coalition which is dedicated
to helping patients make clear
thoughtful decisions about their care in
a way that best reflects their values we
support providers and families in
helping patients understand their
options and choices the healthcare
decisions Coalition has been in
existence since the early 2000s and its
prime primary focus is on educating um
medical providers and the public about
Advanced Care planning and the relevant
fors this Coalition is comprised of
professionals that represent Health Care
Emergency Management legal ethical and
patient advocate constituencies the
Coalition is a forum to discuss relevant
issues related to Advanced Care planning
and addresses many timely topics that
come up on this
issue one of our key deliverables is we
hold trainings twice a year for
professionals in the state on the
Advanced Care planning forms and how
help help their patients with these
conversations we we published these
commonly used Advanced Care planning
guide and the forms and so we received
many inquiries regarding the form and
the state law this gives us a good sense
of the questions that are out there um
both with healthc Care Professionals as
well as the public and from this and
what you'll hear from the Coalition
members is that we have seen where some
of the shortcomings may be and confusion
is caused
the Coalition members have raised the
suggestions outlined in the bill as a
result of what we have heard from the
public and from healthc Care
Professionals and those that deal with
the form and the statute we believe that
these changes uh before you today will
help ensure that the wishes of the
patients whatever they may be will be
clearly understood and executed when the
time comes with that I again want to
thank you for this opportunity to speak
to you and I'd be happy to ask answer
any questions you may have this is the
chairman uh representative mark PE do
you have the bill in front of
you the bill in front of me I can pull
it right up thank
you
now I have it up yes good uh page
23 lines 30 and
following m 30 to surate yes is that
correct line in accordance with an agent
or surrogate May revoke
the DNR or a pulsed for a principal who
lacks capacity to make Health Care
decisions but presumably that person was
capable of making those decisions where
those decisions were first made it says
to me that when a person no longer has
the
capacity people change the desires of
the principle of the individual that
that's what it says seems to say to me
and in this paragraph it's at a health
care facility in the next paragraph it
is outside of Health Care Facility same
language except the venue has
changed to me seems to say that when a
person no longer has capacity people can
go against that person's Express written
desires is that correct am I reading it
correctly I'm GNA have to defer that
question to some of the legal experts
who I know will be testifying later um
what I will say is what we want to do is
ensure that the person that a patient
designates as their surrogate has
clearly understood uh lanes that they
can operate in and so that's what um
we're wishing to clarify but as far as
the Precision of your question I would
ask to defer that to some other legal
folks who'll be testifying later my
apolog any questions Mr
Ames I I see a hand waving it looks like
representative kerk's
hand thank you and um if if uh if if Mr
Ames is the appropriate person that's
one thing that I wanted to check on on
page four line
34 where we have the
definitions um in that we have the
definition of post which states that it
means a form that contains a set of
emergency orders but would it also be
appropriate for us to Define find what
the acronym stands for because I could
never find the acronym actually spelled
out in the bill and I think that acronym
meetings do change over time um and
pulst is a little newer than DNR would
there be any objection to just simply uh
identifying that it's a what is it
physician order life sustaining
treatment that just have that in
parenthesis so it clarifies what the
acronym stands for would that be
okay yeah I think as far as changing the
the B leave that to other folks to make
the decision if that would be
appropriate pulst as you mentioned you
know is a acronym um and it's commonly
used one in the field but I understand
your point about making sure it's
clearly understood because it does
represent thank you um chairman may I um
this is Paula may I
speak can you hear
me yes you may um so there are others
that could address this I believe um Dr
um Phil Lawson is on the phone and I
think he can address this um post um is
now considered not really an acronym um
representative kerk is right it used to
be but nationally they're moving to just
having puls be actually um the name if
you will moving from an acronym to the
um the what it um just referring to
pulst as as a a name in in and of itself
so um we actually had some experts that
deal with post a lot and again if if Dr
Lawson is on the phone I think he can um
he can he can address this more
effectively but that was intentional um
as to why we we did created the
definition the way we did um we actually
had quite a bit of discussion about that
actually um so but we'll I'll let Dr
Lawson um talk about that sure is going
in a different direction uh
representative fulson um thank you
chairman um thank you uh Miss Mahan uh
can you please tell us what the original
anacronym for poost
was it is um physici order life
sustaining treatment I believe and maybe
practitioner order I'm not 100% sure but
life sustaining treatment again um Dr
Lawson is a paliative care doctor and
utilizes pulst forms he can explain exp
Lain um how they how they are utilized
but that's my I believe what the
original acronym there is an amend there
is excuse me a statute um for puls in
our state law um it is really more um
kind of enabling legislation um it's not
um but it's something actually that came
up during one of our um discussions that
that statute may need to be modified to
be more clear um and um kind of bring it
up to the National Standard which um New
Hampshire is trying to follow a number
of states follow um the pulse national
standards um because representative kerk
is right this is a new um relatively new
um um addition to to physician ordering
um emergency medical orders so it it did
come up um but not in the context of
changing this particular
statute you representative thank you m
manahan and Mr angs and uh are there any
other questions for uh Peter am
executive director of the foundation of
Healthy
Communities um I I don't see who's
behind the waving hand represent Marsh
representative Marsh oh okay thank you
thank you uh you may be able to answer
this question better than than Peter did
but the chair asked about uh the
sections of the bill on page uh 23 and
24 whether they would allow someone to
revoke someone's uh DNR order at a later
date when they became incompetent am I
correct that under current law that is
allowed but the way this bill changes
existing law is it adds the phrase in
accordance with RSA 137 j6 which might
turn to page eight in the bill is a
requirement to act in accordance with
the principal wishes and best interests
so in fact what this bill does is limit
the the ability for someone to change
someone's orders when they lose
competency later in life yes I I agree
with you representative Marsh I was
doing the same to make sure the cross
reference but again there are some um
lawyers on the phone that I think could
also address that question um if um if
attorney Hannah is on the phone or
attorney Hillman I think both of them
could um properly address that as well
and clarify any other um legal questions
so thank you for that question thank you
then the chair we'll um recognize um
attorney Helman to speak to this
point and if you have prepared remarks
for something else please hold out to
them address that question chairman but
representative Merchant still had his
hand up for these people testify I
understand thank you please call up
uh attorney Helman yes this is Attorney
Ben Benjamin syracusa Hillman would you
like me to just address the the question
um yes regarding page 23 to 24 okay uh
good good morning uh my name is Benjamin
Syracuse Hillman I'm an attorney at uh
Shaheen and Gordon and I was one of the
members of the stakeholder groups that
worked on the bill and I'll look forward
to testifying at at greater length um
later on in the in the meeting but
regarding the question uh that was asked
um I agree with the the clarification
that the representative have stated
regarding um the change to existing law
is to actually add the phrase in
accordance with RSA 137
j6 um I would also add though I think
more significantly and and Dr Lawson can
perhaps address this as well a do not
resuscitate order or a pulst order um
those are medical orders done by a um by
a physician or other practitioner so as
distinct from a durable power of
attorney for health healthare living
will or other directive documents signed
by an individual patient um the the
orders being reference to are medical
orders so the statute does not the
proposed Bill does not give an indivi uh
an agent or surrogate the ability to
revoke an advanced directive the ability
to revoke a durable power of attorney
for healthcare or living will signed by
the patient what it does do is it allows
the agent to consent or the surrogate to
consent to physician revoking a
physician order um and and again that
has to be done in a way consistent with
the principal best interests and and
expressed
wishes that really doesn't quite explain
it enough for me if a person s of Mind
signs a statement do not resuscitate me
is that the end of the story or May
others countermand
that if an individual signs an advanced
directive and in that directive provides
instructions that they do not wish
resuscitation that directive itself
cannot
be cannot be set aside by the agent that
directive would the agent would have no
power to revoke that directive but what
we're speaking of here is a medical do
not resuscitate order which an
individual cannot do for themselves it
has to be done by a practitioner um and
so if an individual's practitioner does
a do not resuscitate order consistent
with the wishes of the individual and
the individual is
incapacitated the agent or surrogate if
based on a determination that that was
consistent with the patient's wishes and
best interests would have the ability to
consent to the practitioner revoking
that order so they can't they cannot
revoke a written statement of the
individual but they can consent to a to
a a medical practitioner revoking the
medical practitioner's order do not
resuscitate or pulst order let me na it
down if an individual says do not
resuscitate me May the a doctor change
that I'm sorry sir I I I couldn't
understand the last thing you said it
the connection wasn't great if an
individual signs of sound mind signs a
DNR let's leave a out of it for a minute
May a
physician revoke
that an individual cannot sign their own
DNR it has to be done by a physician so
so there is no such thing as an
individual doing their own DNR an
individual can sign an advanced
directive so an individual can express
their wish in the directive that they do
not wish to be resuscitated under
various circumstances but then for that
to have practical effect it is typically
embodied in a medical order by their
practitioner the practitioner has the
ability to alter or amend their medical
order but not the individual's own
underlying statement that gave rise to
that
order representative kushman thank you
Mr chairman can you explain in what
circumstance a doctor would be revoking
such an order
I would like to refer to defer to Dr
Lawson as a um medical provider who who
would be able to give a better answer to
that
question okay while we're trying to mail
down this answer uh the chair will then
recognize Dr Lawson to speak to
this with with respect Mr chairman
several of us had questions of the
person who was
testifying that might CL clarify this if
he were allowed to finish with all of
our questions it's very unusual to jump
from person to person to person to
person in the course of testimony I've
never seen it done before ever uh so I
just want to register that but I I did
have a question that I thought might
help clarify if I could have asked it of
the original person but you're the chair
well it's unusual for me to do the
handoff where one testifier calls on
another testifier who calls on another
testifier but I find myself doing this
because I I believe myself and I'm
looking at a few other people do not
have an answer to our question that
explains it adequately to us but
normally we finish with the first person
and and then the next person who comes
takes up the work as it were and answers
the questions that were not appropriate
for the earlier person ra rather than
calling people in and then putting them
back out again and and and it it's
generally the practice that we hold the
questions for the person who's the
appropriate person but we don't just
call that person up to testify on one
question and then send them back and go
back to the person before I do thank you
for that and I'm going in a different
direction I'm calling on Dr Lawson to
try to nail down an answer to this
question under what circumstances May a
person's expressed desire do not
resuscitate me can't that be overruled
by someone else so I've been told that
Dr Lawson can answer
this sorry I I hope you can hear me now
yes we can right so I'm Dr Philip Lawson
I'm a paliative care consultant at
Littleton Regional Health Care I'm also
an emergency department physician and
practiced as a primary care clinician at
amusa community health for about 20
years uh I do have extensive experience
in this and and I'm one of the trainers
that Peter uh referred to in his
introduction in answer to this question
um the short answer is yes but the long
answer is in very rare
circumstance uh I think representative
kushman asked for specific circumstance
uh one might be a situation where a
person had an advanced cancer had a
temporary loss of
capacity had signed a do not attempt
resuscitation
order understanding their prognosis was
poor and a new therapy arose that was
exceptionally effective and could
significantly change their uh prognosis
and the durable power of attorney in
that circumstance May interet
the individual's wishes to be one where
they would want to change that order
there are
innumerable and
unpredictable potential circumstances
from a medical
perspective that could lead to a change
in prognosis and it is impossible to
fully predict all the potential
circumstances that may occur in the
future in regards to what is going to
occur to an
individual uh regarding their medical
treatment and for this reason although
there are concerns as you imply with the
ability of a durable power to override a
previous uh
request in some the medical field
certainly believes and it is our
experience that the benefits
significantly outweigh the risks and
harms when it comes to the issue of a
durable power of attorney's authority to
override a previous um statement that
has always been the case in existing law
and it is always the standard of
practice in SB
74 our goal was to strengthen that by
the reference to the necessity for an
individual including the agent as well
as the medical team to honor the wishes
of the patient to refer back to that
section as uh representative Marsh uh
discussed so it is an issue uh
representative but in the opinion of the
medical community and certainly the
healthc care decisions
Coalition the benefits of continuing to
allow that
Authority outweigh the potential harms I
hope that answers your question it does
doctor now the Chairman's happy
everybody can be happy
again um we go back to where were we
with people's hands up is it with uh
Peter
angs or Laura minahan those of you who
once had your hands up want to put them
back up and who were you wanting to
speak to representative
Weber well I'm now wanting to speak to
the good doctor if I may oh yeah as a
followup to your line of
questioning um and I have two if I might
the first
is just a straight question is it
possible that one of the important
functions of this
language is so that if the surrogate who
knows or or the agent or the surrogate
who knows the patient well believes that
a practitioner acting in all good faith
simply got the patient's wishes
wrong the agent or surrogate may require
the practitioner who in all good faith
got it wrong to do what the agent or
surrogate really really thinks that the
individual
wanted is that one of the purposes of
this uh yes I mean and that always has
been the case representative Weber as
well a agent or surrogate or anyone in
fact acting on behalf of a a patient
although legally we refer to the
hierarchy of legal Authority in reality
medically we have family meetings we get
together everybody and we sit down and
we work for consensus to best understand
the values and the goals and wishes of
the individual who is unable to advocate
for themselves and that that's the
standard of care um but yes um and if
there was irre ilable differences where
a clinician a
practitioner could not agree that would
be a situation that would go to an
Ethics Committee um as an example that
would be where the next step would be to
to help resolve that there are very very
few situations and in my experience we
are a a unfortunately overly legally
driven you know profession medically and
so I I have not encountered in in my 30
plus years of practice a situation where
a clinician absolutely you know refused
to um respond to a surrogate agent you
know when an
appropriate family meeting Ethics
Committee and other you know uh
potential Avenues suggested other forms
for the the way to go what happens in
those scenarios is the clinician exits
or refers to another clinician to take
over care that's the standard of
practice when there's an irreconcilable
difference and and may I ask a followup
Mr
chairman yes uh this would be a
hypothetical and it's it's based on my
lived experience back in the days when
we only had living Wheels but um I had
an aunt who told me from the time I was
18 until the time I was 35 that she
never wanted to be taken to the hospital
never wanted any treatment never wanted
to leave her home and she never wanted
to be resuscitated or have any kind of
invasive treatment
whatsoever and when she experienced a
bowel blockage when I was 35 she asked
to be driven to the
hospital she consented knowingly and
voluntarily to a series of Fairly
invasive
tests and the question became and and as
that was going on she became unable to
speak for herself so I got a phone call
and I had a document that said she did
not want any invasive procedures
whatsoever but I also had somebody who
had just that week consented to three of
them and who everybody I spoke to who
knew her well said she is still fighting
she really wants to fight uh what do we
do now and I would have in in that case
I was going to Advocate against what her
living will said would this provision
cover that
situation yes most definitely um it
would so the living will uh presently as
proposed is a document of
guidance
um it does not carry legal Authority the
living will section unto itself but acts
as guidance for the agent or
surrogate again the agent or surrogate
must act in the best interest of the
patient as best understood at the time
but your example representative Weber is
a good one and not an unusual one um and
it goes in both directions you know um
people can't predict when they make
decisions when they complete an advanced
directive
um their environment the people they're
talking to the people that are
counseling them and assisting them in
the process you know are assessing a
situation at the time that can't
adequately predict or know what the
future will hold in all sorts of Realms
I mean there in just think of the
pandemic and you know all that's changed
over the course of it in regards to
medical treatment there are incredibly
unpredictable changes in events and
environments that must allow us to act
act in the best interest of the patient
at the time as we can best understand it
with the best guidance that we can have
and this document we have tried to
simplify we have tried to make clear and
we've tried to allow for that standard
of Medical Practice to occur and for the
document not to force treatments that
would clearly be contrary to the best
interests of the person if they were
capable of telling us that at the time
as we can best understand
thank you and as a a former elder law
attorney and former Ethics Committee
panelist thank you all for your work on
the
bill and thank you Dr representative on
this very narrow
issue before we go back to our usually
scheduled program uh anybody with a hand
up on this specific issue I think I see
representative Merchant's hand up I do
it sort of speaks to the issue um the
issue I have as I listen to this
conversation in the bill currently we
have
inserted forms although the language
does say that could be
substantially equal to the form my
concern is I listen to this
conversation that this is very Dynamic
um and forms probably will have to
change once the form goes into statute
it's very difficult to change the form
would it be possible to have the forms
developed by the Department of Health
and Human Services through rulemaking
therefore allowing through the agency
and rulemaking authority over time to
change the form and modify it based upon
this healthy conversation we're having
today so we don't somehow inadvertently
get ourselves into a pickle because we
have a form in the statute that really
becomes difficult to change if we need
to change
it
the way if you want to look at the forms
that's on page 16 starts on
line 33 and goes on um I just would like
to see it move towards a rulemaking
Authority by the Department of Health
Human Services so that they would have
the ability to create a form uh in
through Ru making and again the form
could be done through Ru making that is
substantially like it but over time as
things do evolve we're not locking
ourselves into one type of form that may
ultimately need to be changed and again
I'm not an attorney but sometimes when
you look at a form that goes into
statute and if you change it even though
it does allow for it to be substantially
changed I think by default people going
to go to the form in the statute because
it's legally I again I Look to people
like perent web or somebody else is an
attorney but I think they're going to
default to this one because it's in
statute a wonderful question who's it
addressed to
address it to Peter
MREs thank you representative Merchant
for the question so we have operated
with the form in statute currently so um
that has been place where people have
gone to reference the form that's what
we produce um off of so we're looking
just for these changes to be added to
the form now which again are trying to
keep the um long-standing policy in
place and just provide for clarity so
we're comfortable with the changes as
they are um amending this statute um
because we feel it captures what needs
to be addressed at this time and this is
Paula minan from the hospital
Association we also um there are other
there are other statutes that have forms
in them um I'm thinking of next of kin
um there's another I worked on that a
couple years ago um that that form is
actually embedded into the law um there
are other I mean we have done this in
other um statutes so we Act we actually
I think Ru making would add a comp a
level of complexity that I'm not sure um
would be helpful um and I would I would
actually um I mean not to do it right
this second but when attorney Hilman um
he works with this every day um in his
job as an elder law attorney so um I
think he can address this as well um as
to why it it works the way um it
currently is contemplated so um thank
you
representative Marsh uh thank you Mr
chairman this is for Dr Lawson here um
as as someone who uh spent a great deal
of time in his career working with
people who may have had a longstanding
DNR order but may have had an acute
issue they wanted to take care of uh
would I not be correct that the
distinction you were trying to make
clear to the committee was the
Physicians do not DNR order might be
temporarily suspended uh for the purpose
of taking care an acute issu such as for
instance a person in a long-term care
facility who wanted have
cataractes yes representative Marsha um
absolutely there are numerous
circumstances where DNR orders are
rescinded uh inoperative is one of them
so almost all institutions for example
when a patient is going under
anesthesia by policy of the institution
have a order to resend a DNR and there
are numerous circumstance es where
people choose to have dnrs rescinded
there are people who choose to be a DNR
in the
community for instance but be a full
code while they're
hospitalized where your chances of
success
statistically are you know about three
times four times as good while you're in
the inpatient so there are numerous
circumstances where patients will uh
request resending or changing in DNR
order it is a fluid
process thank you for
that well where are we Kar is hand
what's that want Des question
representative kerk thank you because I
had a question that was really very
similar because a DNR because you have a
hopeless situation is very different
than an interoperative arrest now you
said the patient can resend in various
times but it sounds like you're saying
it automatically can occur usually most
ins tions enter operatively um or that
they have that choice of in a hospital
versus out of Hospital arrest but I
didn't see that on the form of how they
parse that out is that something that
would be taken care of individually with
the uh practitioner uh between the
provider and practitioner or how do they
parse out those differences which are
somewhat difficult I think for people to
understand the difference between a
simple arrest interoperative and an
arrest when you were on your way out and
the act of dying as we is the phrase
that is used here where it's a very
different reason can you clarify how
that would
work yes I I take it that's addressed to
me representative kerk yeah I pres yes I
think I think Dr Lawson that' be best to
you yeah so um absolutely so there are
situations like you um discuss where it
is by policy and automatically done and
then there are situations where it is an
agreement between the patient Andor
their surrogate or agent and the
clinician involved and it it is a fluid
process the it's it's too unfortunately
too complicated and there are too many
different situations to try to stipulate
it in law and I'll give you an example
of a analgous situation and that is a
person's capacity so you know by law you
either have capacity or you don't but in
reality from a medical sense you can
have capacity to make certain decisions
ISS but not have capacity to make other
more complex decisions and your capacity
can wax and WS so as people with for
instance mild to moderate dementia uh
you know Sundown using the the street
term or or get more Delirious in the
evening they could have capacity in the
morning and not have capacity in the
evening so these things are fluid and
like most medical things are complicated
vary over time and
cannot be
legally you know parsed out um without
getting into Big Trouble in my
experience I do not see anyone's hand up
but we'll give one last call to
discussing DNR before we go back to how
we normally do things is that a hand up
or just a scratch okay that was a
scratch oh representative day thank you
Mr chairman and uh thank you all for
taking my question because I'm not sure
who to direct it at uh all of this is
new to me so I apologize for the novess
of my question where where is it spelled
out what ought I say does it spell out
that the medical provider whatever
terminology want to use for the medical
person in charge of a
patient where is this said in stone that
the medical provider has the final
utmost say in interpreting the DNR
rather than an agent of the uh
patient that was it was
cited in some of the
answers but that's the standing right
now
representative Weber do you wish to
address that I saw your your light
on no me um if if you want me to an I'll
be glad to take a stab at it it's
unusual um saw was the Box around you
was lit which usually means somebody
want is trying to speak so that's why
called on
you or defer it to
someone I would be happy to answer
it uh the the DNR order as um the
attorney spoke is a medical order
written by a practitioner the word in
the law is practitioner and so the the
practitioner writes the order like
that's actually what happens so nobody
else can write an order an agent can't
write an order in a medical record um
only a practitioner can and that so
that's I mean it's it's as simple as
that from my perspective maybe Ben or
one of the attorneys would like to
answer in more
complexity any of the
attorneys able to answer representative
Gay's
question
um I
chair yes go
ahead I'm sorry I don't know if it was
directed at me or at attorney a
representative Weber I was just I guess
I would just add that I I don't have
anything to add to what attorney lawon
said in terms of the distinction between
the agent's ability to make a decision
and what needs to be embodied in order
by the by The
Physician yes thank you for taking my
additional question which is how exactly
do you go what is the process to go from
a patient's DNR which is let's say it's
in it's supported by uh its agent or uh
whatever the right word is for the
person speaking for the person who wrote
the DML how do you go from a p patient's
DNR to a medical
DNR what what drives the the provider's
decision to write the DNR do you have to
we're always told we have to bring those
orders with to every doctor when I take
my mother to many different doctors we
had to make sure that each of them was
aware of what her uh documents were but
how do you transfer that into the ual
medical order at what time is that
transferred how does this happen thank
you I can answer that I think I'm
probably in the best position Dr Lawson
here again um the so this is a common uh
issue many people
misconstrue an advanced directive for a
medical order and advanced directives
are not MediCal orders the advanced
directive is purely a document that
states
wishes for the future and an advanced
directive does not come into
effect until the patient has been
documented to have lost capacity and to
fulfill any of the preset components of
the advanced directive so an advanced
directive itself is not a medical order
under any
circumstances so you could say anything
in an advanced directive and if you
suddenly died at home emergency
Personnel are obligated to initiate CPR
irrespective of what's written in your
Advanced Directive because it is not in
effect because you have not been
documented by a medical practitioner to
have lost capacity so that's the first
thing an advanced directive is a
directive for the future it is not a
medical order the medical order is the
DNR or or pul form and those puls forms
or DN R forms the pink or yellow forms
are completed by the practitioner at the
request of the patient or their agent or
surrogate um depending on the
circumstance or advised by the
practitioner um so the process has to be
a meeting um an appointment or a meeting
or an in hospital consultation or or
wherever the venue is uh to have an
appropriate discussion around the
benefits and risks associated with such
an order and then the order actually
being written and the accepted orders in
the state of New Hampshire include the
pink portable DNR assuming SB 74 moves
forward it would include the yellow
pulst form which has a DNR and then any
order within an
institution that is consistent with the
policies and practices of the
institution and and those are the only
accepted medical orders so it is a the
process by which an advanced directive
which I think you're talking about
representative moving to a DNR
order is a specific interaction between
a practitioner and a patient Andor their
family and and or surrogate or agent um
where that order is
written it's really really common
misconception about probably 50% of more
of the patients who come to see me in
paliative care consult consultation have
an advanced directive that's all they
have and they think they have an A DNR
order and they don't and they will
receive
CPR when EMS is called when 911 is
called from home irrespective of what
that advanced directive say says it's a
good I appreciate you bringing up the
point because hopefully it's educating
quite a few people um there what what
they say in their advance directive is
not a medical order until it has been
made into a medical
order so very helpful thank you um I
think I'd like to attempt to go back to
the normal way of doing things and call
on a few other people who haven't spoken
yet coming back to the original uh group
that we brought in on one specific thing
with that the chair would like to
recognize Robert Dunn who was part of
this group and represents the Roman
Catholic dasis of Manchester New
Hampshire
so welcome to Mr
Don uh good morning Mr chair members of
the
committee uh thank you for uh the
opportunity to to testify I'm blob dun
theor dor of public policy for the Roman
Catholic dasis of Manchester and I'm
speaking today in support of SB
74 um I won't go into too much detail
because I know there's a lot of folks
that um are going to um go uh over the
various provisions of the bill uh uh
with much more of a fine tooth comb um
so I just want to make a couple of
comments here at the outset um first off
our views on end of Life Care start with
the fundamental conviction that each
human being was created in God's image
and likeness and that therefore every
person at every moment of life has a
Priceless dignity that can never be
diminished or taken away even when a
person is in the extremities of illness
or death
itself um and so from Catholic
perspective we believe that this calls
us to avoid the opposite extremes of the
deliberate hastening of death on the one
hand and the use of treatment that under
the circumstances doesn't have a
reasonable hope of benefit or
constitutes an excessive burden on the
other and U so the
dasis has actually published a booklet
that's called three beliefs that
explains Catholic views on end of life
care and that tries to assist New
Hampshire Catholics in setting up their
durable Powers of Attorney for health
care and based on that experience we
think that SB 74 makes improvements to
the advanced directive law that's in
place
today um and I know you're going to hear
about these in more detail um I'd
highlight um things I think that you'll
hear about um about how the bill clarifi
that uh end of life treatment Provisions
in an advanced directive are connected
to the person having an advanced life
limiting um essentially what we would
probably colloquially refer to as a
terminal illness and it and it
importantly lays out how a balancing of
burdens and benefits is involved in the
making of decisions regarding end of
Life Care um the provisions that you've
been uh hearing about already ready that
um kind of helped to make it uh the case
that uh decisions are being made on an
updated basis on the most recent
information that folks have are also
notable um and the bill clarifies that
those outof state orders and posts are
only effective in New Hampshire to the
degree that they substantively conform
to New Hampshire law and finally I just
want to point out very significantly
that SB 74 once again reiterates that
our law doesn't condone or legalize
physician assisted
suicide now um I do want to note that
there are certain aspects of the current
law specifically Provisions that relate
to permanent unconsciousness and
medically administered nutrition and
hydration which we have opposed over the
years because these Provisions don't
Accord with our views on what should be
considered basic obligations of care and
because those Provisions are largely
unchanged by Senate Bill
74 I do want to emphasize that in
supporting Senate Bill 74 we're not
altering our position on those
Provisions but as I said um we think
that the version of the advanced
directive law that would be in effect
after the passage of Senate bill 74
would be an improvement over the version
that's in effect today and that's why
we're supporting the bill uh so thank
you for your consideration of our views
and with that I'll close any questions
for Mr dun from the
committee well thank you sir for all
your hard work on this group and for
your bringing the uh um position of the
Roman Catholic
dasis the chair would now like to call
we have a few people signed up in
opposition and I want to get to them
before we go any further I I believe
former representative Kathleen
Souza is on the list wishing to
testify and anyone want to testify could
please raise your hand to bring you to
the top of the
list is Kathleen soua in the meeting I'm
not seeing her on the attendees list
okay then representative Erica Leon from
Barry um thank you Mr chair and
honorable members of the committee for
the record I am representative Erica
Leon of Derry I stand in strong
opposition to this bill as it turns a
weighty decision ision into an overly
simple
form what looks like a simple
designation of medical decision maker
actually flips current policy on its
head right now it's easy to say that
only your designated agent can make
these choices by filling out only part
one and not part two of the current form
with this bill there is no clear way to
do this and no language to protect that
as a specific declaration that is a huge
problem if you pass this will we need a
bereaved family members to sue to see
how it plays out in court
this morning I emailed my the committee
my concerns in this bill in bullet point
format I have many serious concerns
about how this bill shifts consent from
opt-in to opt out on experimental
therapies and honoring State statements
of incapacitated patients on how it
reduces the rights of practitioners to
follow their conscience on how it Blends
Alzheimer's disease with an irreversible
coma and how it removes family beyond
the agent or surgant from care planning
decisions when they are
incapacitated perhaps even more
terrifying in right now if a patient
wants their agent or practitioner to
ignore what they say when they are
incapacitated they need to specifically
opt in by writing that on the
form if you sign the forms as proposed
in
s74 your doctor and your agent can
ignore your please for care or your
refusal of treatment a patient with
Alzheimer's can be ignored if they just
form this sign the form as written on S
SP
74 I understand just how wey it is to
stop fighting death as my father's
Advanced Directive allowed the family to
make the decision and then stay with
them for his final moments final days
where we could say those necessary
things and to literally hear him say I
love you with his dying breath this Bill
had it applied to us would have let the
hospital not treat his sepsis and denied
that closure to all of us especially
closure to him as it had been over two
decades for the family that was in that
room to be
together so this bill this bill makes
the form so simple and uncomplicated
that an average patient won't understand
just how much autonomy they give up the
form looks like any other rote form that
patients
signed with some of the changes it
actually allows a doctor you've never
met to sterilize you if you're in a coma
from an accident and it should not be
that easy to sign away those rights I
urge you to kill this bill by voting in
expedient to legislate please just pull
a plug uh thank you and I will take
questions
any questions for representative
Leon uh representative
gay thank you thank you
um uh representative Leon could you
again cite some of the points per line
uh that you are saying would have
interfered with your family being with
your father or the sterilization
something right because this is rather
detailed it would be very helpful since
you have cited them thank you
representative gay I I do understand
that I I dropped a lot of things on you
so it's good to back these up if you go
to page six um and start at line 29 this
is where it changes the capacity and the
ability to refuse treatment or to ask
for treatment right now the part that's
struck out starting at line 36 and
Contin to page seven it requires that
the principal it says that um treatment
may not be given or withheld from the
principal over the principal's objection
unless the principal's Advanced
Direction includes the following
statement initialed by the principal
even if I am incapacitated and I object
to treatment treatment may be given to
me against my objection the new language
says that the the agent or surrogate
acting on the principal's behalf um
consent to treatment or withholding of
treatment from the principal even over
the principal's objection unless the
durable power of attorney for healthcare
provides otherwise that puts the onus on
somebody who is filling out what will be
a two-page sheet that looks like it's
just naming the person to make those
choices to know that that's within the
law especially because that's not even
within the disclosure
statement um if you'd like me um
representative gay would you like me to
look for to pull up another one of those
like the St ization that one's on page 8
line
12 so right now it in um page 8 line 12
it still prevents them the agent from
consenting to psychosurgery or
electroconvulsive shock therapy and
instead of just striking out an
experimental treatment of any kind it
also Strikes Out sterilization and
that's in direct conflict with the
disclosure form that is provided for in
the statute um so the disclosure form is
would be in conflict with the underlying
RSA um with the fact that sterilization
is struck
out and um the
in and um the part that would have made
that change for my father is right now
is right now you have to when you fill
out the Advanced healthc Care directive
form there's the two sections there's
the durable power power of attorney for
healthcare and then there's a living
will and in New Hampshire statute the
way that it's written now the living
will just gives that direction for a
physician a physician um uh assistant or
an advanced practice nurse to make those
decisions about incapacity and then
making those end of life decisions so if
you don't want to have a doctor that you
may not have ever met before make those
choices for you then you just do not
sign that part and you are not giving
those rights
away that is not something that's
providing Ed for in this bill in the new
statute as amended by SP
74 I honestly would have to hire a
lawyer to know how to put that into my
directive because I don't want to give
away that autonomy I would rather be in
limbo until they can find somebody to
make that choice for me than to allow a
doctor well well-meaning as they may be
to decide that I shouldn't have that
cont that sustaining
care follow up oh would you be so kind
as to put these concerns into writing to
send us since it is
complex um thank you representative I
actually I'm sure you've had a huge
number of emails about this bill I sent
one to you all this morning from my
legislative email that does have the
bullet points of the lines I do
apologize the one of them I forgot to
have the page reference so in the one
where it's the language striking out um
the right of a principal to reserve
these end of life decisions to only
their agent that's on page 11 line 16-34
I had uh forgotten to have that page as
I was typing this
up thank you very
much any other questions for
representative
Leon I do not see any hands except for
the hand of Representative kushman thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
um can you speak to your concerns
about um the incapacity blending uh
between you know say someone who has
Alzheimer's disease um with imminent
death um thank you representative yes
this is um
this the biggest concern here is the
ability to override somebody's um the
one that we look to for about overriding
their wishes and their expressed
interests because if somebody is in a
coma or something else like that right
at the end of life and they're Delirious
that's one level of incapacity that it
that would make
sense I could I could see a time where
you would ignore what somebody's saying
because they might be talking about all
sorts of other nonsensical things and a
provider might want to override those
decisions because they clearly don't
have much of a grasp of reality
you ALS right now with incapacity
there's not any sort of separation from
ma major neurocognitive disorders like
Alzheimer's um there are other states
that do have a provision for major
neurocognitive disorders where there can
be treatment that's given against the
patient's will either for um being put
into a locked memory facility for being
given medications that they don't
otherwise consent to but that's not
within the same blanket statement like
we are trying to put into law here
that's something that's well considered
for these longstanding incapacities and
there's there's just not much treatment
of that here um we we're not respecting
the difference between an Alzheimer's
patient and somebody who's who's just on
the verge of
death thank you thank you any further
questions for the
representative I do not see
any then
see thank you representative for your
your testimony and answering our
questions thank
you let's see where were we let's Circle
back to Paul
minahan she's already part of the group
she can just
talk thank you let's Circle back then to
um Peter Ames if you're still with
us yes thank you Mr chairman I Mark some
earlier cover everything I wanted to
address so again thank you for the
[Music]
opportunity anything further either from
you or for you for Mr
Ames
see nothing I have my hand up I'm sorry
yes go ahead I I'm not sure who this
would be most appropriate for but there
was just one spot that I was a little
bit confused and just wanted explanation
page
26 lines 20 to
23 if you could just clarify what that
means and why it's there I just was a
little bit
uncertain I mean it sounds like it gives
permission for a person to not treat
sorry practitioner to choose to not
treat a patient is that all it's
doing I can ask you to reference those
lines once more for me it's page 26
lines 20 through 2
uh3 thank
you it appears that it just says if that
the practitioner is not obligated to
treat someone who lacks decision-making
capacity and I'm curious why that's
[Music]
there yeah so that um piece is part of
current law um so we're not looking to
change that aspect of it just clarify
the words you see there
y okay thank
you uh representative krishman thank you
Mr chairman I have a question for you do
does so I I see there was language and
I'm I apologize I'm not finding it right
at the moment um but it removes the
right of providers and Facilities to opt
out of dnrs or living wills can you
explain why that
um why that's supported in this
bill 23 line 16 it's page 23 line 16 and
it's sorry it's page six L
3 okay page
six yeah if I could represent I might
want to refer that that to um attorney
Kate Hana who could probably best speak
to that aspect of the
change and would the person I did not
catch the name that you referred us to
yep attorney Kate Hannah okay I will
call then Kate Hannah attorney Kate
Hannah if you're in the meeting to
explain uh for the representative page
six lines 3
to6 I don't do not see her in the list
okay Mr chair I would ask that people be
allowed to testify that we get to all
people and let them testify completely
because I think there are people lined
up who are going to explain these things
who are the appropriate thing people to
explain them and who have them in their
testimony if only we could get to it as
a
whole I'm looking at the list of the
people before me who have signed up to
testify I've called on virtually
everyone but let me call on those I have
not called on the chair represent uh
recognizes Gina Bol who's a lobbyist
with Granite State home health and
hospice Association and you may uh bring
your testimony T miss
bcus good morning Mr chairman can you
hear me
yes uh good afternoon actually it's it's
not afternoon yet it's still morning uh
I am Gina balkus CEO of the Granite
State home health and hospice
Association we Advocate on issues that
affect Home Care Hospice and paliative
care providers and the patients they
serve our Association members care for
individuals from birth through end of
life primarily in people's homes and we
are part of the healthc Care decisions
Coalition that carefully considered this
statute and we worked with stakeholders
to draft improvements the association
strongly supports Senate Bill
74 medicine is changed much during the
past 30 years since New Hampshire
enacted its Advanced Directive laws but
what has not changed is the respect for
the individual's right to choose medical
treatment they want and decline medical
treatment they do not want ensuring that
an individual's wishes are honored at
end of life when the person may be
unable to articulate their wishes is the
core of the legislation that the late
Senator Susan mlan championed in the
late 80s and early 90s and it remains
the core of Senate Bill 74 that was
passed by the Senate I think it's
important for you to know that New
Hampshire's current law is clunky and
often difficult to understand Senate
Bill 74 improves New Hampshire's
Advanced Directive law by clarifying
definitions and simply simplifying much
of what I would call the legal EAS in
the existing form it will also make it
easier for health care providers to
honor patients wishes without having to
seek legal counsel or judicial
orders and it will allow for smoother
handouts I I'm sorry handoffs between
providers allowing medical orders to
follow the patient across the Continuum
of
Care one major Improvement is on page 15
of the bill the disclosure statement
which must accompany the advanced
directive document has been revised from
the lengthy legal J jargon that is
currently in the law to concise simple
language it covers all the same points
in the current law that an individual
should know prior to signing an advanced
directive another Improvement relates to
surrogacy in the existing law there is
confusion as to whether the surrogate
has the same Authority as an appointed
agent in all
circumstances some legal councils have
advised that a surrogate such as a wife
a husband or an adult child may not be
able to consent to withholding or
withdrawal a life sustaining treatment
because New Hampshire's existing law
only allows an agent to do that with
Express written permission in an
advanced directive but here's the Catch
22 a person becomes a surrogate because
there is no written Advanced Directive
so Senate Bill 74 eliminates the
requirement that an individual expressly
P permit in writing the withholding and
withdrawal of life sustaining treatment
although somebody can certainly um write
that into their
document this has been a cause of great
confusion for agents providers and
especially for family members who are
surrogate decision makers it has also
been problematic when providers
encounter an outof State advance
directive that does not have this
requirement Senate Bill 7 4 recognizes
DNR orders pulse and their counterparts
from other states and this means that a
practitioner order for life- sustaining
treatment can accompany a patient in
whatever setting they may be a hospital
a nursing home or at home with a home
care or hospice providers and this is so
important to honoring an individual's
wish across the Continuum of
Care lastly we strongly support the
provision on page 26 lines 24 through 29
that extends The Authority for a
surrogate decision maker from 90 to 180
days this is important for hospice
patients it makes it less likely that
families will need to go through the
guardianship process and their loved
ones final
days on behalf of New Hampshire's Home
Care Hospice and paliative care
providers and the patients they serve I
ask that you recommend Senate Bill 74 as
ought to pass
and I will take a stab Mr chairman if
you allow me to answer a couple of the
questions that have come up so one of
the points that I just wanted to make is
that actually on page six I think it was
representative kushman who asked about
page six lines 3 through six that says
any health care provider or residential
care provider which does not recognize
dnrs or living
wills um should post a sign sign um that
was deleted because to be honest we know
of no provider that has such a sign uh
that was actually put in um in um sort
of halfhazard in the Senate during one
um during several years ago when the
statute was being revised but there is
still in this this bill there are
Provisions that allow both an a
practitioner as an individual to um to
basically um transfer a patient to
another provider if they feel they canot
comply with the living will and also for
a provider and in in this statute a
facility is defined as a provider an
individual practitioner is divined like
a physician or a nurse practitioner is
defined as a practitioner so it's still
in there it's just this sign um
requirement is taken out um the other
thing that I wanted to just point out is
that um and I'm looking on page eight uh
in in uh response to one of the speakers
uh who testified earlier page eight line
five still
maintains that uh an agent cannot
consent to voluntary sterilization it is
still in the statute it was crossed out
someplace else in the statute because
there things were moved around that's
all um and I I will be happy to answer
any other questions that um that um well
I will attempt to answer any questions
that others might have representative G
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um if a practitioner
finds that they
cannot uh they cannot they they are not
comfortable following the
um the patients
directives you said they can pass that
patient transfer that patient to another
practitioner is that a requirement in
this
bill but they do if they do not feel
like they can follow what they've been
asking to do they do have to inform the
the agent or the surrogate and I and I'm
actually looking for the section right
now
P I'm
sorry page nine Lin 30 through 34 was
crossed out um that requires the
informing of the patient and the
patient's
family but it's been struck from this
bill
you said page nine y lines 30 through 34
but that's where it's struck so I I
don't see yes it was I believe it was
moved to another section and I'm just um
live and following seems to pick up the
[Music]
theme I I think it's on page N9 line 35
on where it talks about making the
necessary arrangements without
delay it'd immediately follow us the
truck
section yes yes it is definitely in
there um that they Pro the provider that
the the practitioner must inform the
family uh or the the agent or the
surrogate and shall assist in arranging
for transfer to another um provider to
another
practitioner um so it is in there any
sections simply moved around 35 and
following as fulfilling
that they are still required to fulfill
that that yes yeah we see it we see it
any other questions from Miss
balkus yes Mr chairman uh sounds like
representative Merchant it is thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mrs
vus um in talking about experimental
care when I look at
the page 17 folks and looking at line
34 it says Li Su standing cement within
the limits of generally accepted
standards of care experimental therapy
normally does not become accepted
General standards of care until it's
been accepted generally speaking that's
why it's
experimental in saying that statement
then it first per say excludes the use
of experimental care because if I select
that I'm not specifically addressing the
issue of experimental care so should the
form in include an option in there for
the patient to select experimental care
in addition to generally accepted care
so I am going to yield to uh either the
attorneys who are on the call or to uh
Dr Lawson who may be on the call
um and uh I'm not sure if Lindsay
Courtney from Dartmouth Hitchcock has
signed up to testify the experimental
treatment provisions of the statute or
um or of special concern to Dartmouth
Hitchcock CH Matthew h from Dartmouth as
his hand raised probably answer that
question yes from Dartmouth Hitchcock
Matthew last name Matthew hope h o u d
Matthew h from Dar Hitchcock is
recognized to answer that
question yes um thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is Matthew Hood uh vice
president of government relations at
Dartmouth
Hitchcock uh I'm I was raising my hand
to testify to the experimental
treatments and clinical trial sections
in general which I'm happy do to do but
I will um hold on that to answer
representative Merchants question
uh pertaining to whether or not the form
has been updated uh to give that
specific distinguished category of
choice and the answer to that is
yes if I may Mr
chairman uh thank you um Mr Hood so
there's no conflict between generally
accepted healthare standards and
experimental
care um so I so I know that this is
becoming a common theme in this uh
hearing that I would defer that question
to one of the Physicians uh or frankly I
could get the question answered by our
legal council um what I thought the
question was is has the uh durable Power
of Attorney form been amended to reflect
the agent uh authority to consent to a
clinical trial and the answer to that is
yes
so if I understand Mr chairman if I may
under the Ural power that's where it's
addressed not in the living
will it it's in it's in the um my
understanding and I'm happy to be
corrected but my understanding is that
is in the instruction to the um durable
power form it's in the statute if you
look at the form further down as you
would pointed out it's it's
there I'd like to get a legal opinion
because when I read this I hear your
point um I see it as a conflict because
I don't see experimental care becoming
generally acceptable Healthcare
standards until they've been through the
experiment and things have been signed
off on if you will accepted by the
medical community at large so in saying
that the way it's worded I just think it
could be ambiguous and possibly
conflicting with what's
there
if I may if I may um speak to the
experimental treatment clinical trial
Section with representative Merchants
question follow-up question in mind it
may provide Clarity for that just about
to ask you to do that thank thank you
very much and um by by way of
background uh this issue came to light
uh in the early stages of
covid-19 um because there existed
situations across the country but
frankly also in the states where patent
patients were suffering severe symptoms
of covid and were brought into the
hospitals darmouth Hitchcock certainly
but but not alone and other hospitals as
well where there were potential
experimental treatments available but
provid providers were unable to
administer those because the patient was
unable to give consent whether they were
intubated or
otherwise even if there was a a spouse
or an agent who wanted to consent on
behalf of the
patient that could not happen because of
the prohibition in statute to giving an
agent giving consent to experimental
treatments this was literally um life or
death and uh we appreciative of the
governor's office giving an executive
order that suspends essentially that
prohibition with respect to those
suffering severe
covid um symptoms the legislature
followed suit and largely codified that
executive order but it sunsets at the
end of June this year which is why this
provision was added to uh Senate Bill
74 without I acknowledge the limitation
to co um and so let me speak to what the
provision would allow which it would
give Authority in certain limited
circumstances for an agent or surrogate
to consent to experimental treatments or
clinical trials they include that the
situation be
life-threatening uh disease or condition
or a serious disease or condition that
would result in impairment of
function that there's no alternative
therapy
available and that it's authorized by an
internal review board consistent and
consistent with relevant state and
federal regulations and finally it's a
this is applicable where the advance
directive is silent such that the
principle can can
decline in the document and such
Authority would not be
available so working with other
stakeholders um colleague uh
stakeholders at the disability rights
Center and others we constrained the
language with respect to authorization
of agent surrogate for experimental
treatments or clinical
trials I'll close with that section and
because I think Miss bulus referenced
that the prohibitions that existed with
respect to sterilization and involuntary
uh commitment remain there there was a
strikeout of of the sterilization piece
in one one place but it remains in
section B of five so I I just wanted to
reiterate that and I'm happy to answer
questions um uh that I
can does anyone have a question that he
can
answer um let's see representative
kushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you can you tell me if if
this bill were to pass would everyone
who has um completed the current forms
for advanced directives and durable
power of attorney then need to go back
to um a lawyer and have the process
started
over uh that's a uh thank you that's a
great question representative kushman I
appreciate it it was a discussion of of
topic um on the numerous calls that were
referenced um but that's a question I'm
going to deferred to the attorneys on
the phone call to answer that question
thank
my understanding just briefly is that
the answer is no but I but I want to
defer so you have a a a full or legal
answer to to your
question I see representative Nelson's
hand
up and please
unmute this point I'm totally confused
because there seems to be some
conflicting ideas uh one of the things I
thought I heard earlier was that the
person could have in
writing that they do not want to be
resuscitated but the hospital or
whatever can override
that on the other hand what I just heard
doesn't seem to go that way and I'm just
confused as to what's happening because
it's I don't know maybe just
me uh well representative I've been on
I've been on the uh the hearing for the
duration so uh with respect to the
conversation about what a what
a um hospital or provider can or cannot
do
uh you've heard the same things I have
with respect to this
provision a principal can do any number
of things they can say I want any manner
of experimental treatment doesn't have
to be life- saving doesn't have to be a
serious illness or condition that's one
scenario they can do they can also say I
don't want any and that is to be
respected and then the third is they can
be silent and it's the situation of
Silence that I'm discussing which is
what are then in the absence of of uh uh
selection is an agent or a surrogate
entitled to do with respect to clinical
trials or experimental treatments I hope
that that clarifies in this
scenario I guess uh when you said that
uh you f you Hospital whatever can give
experimental drugs without the would
override everything if the hospital
wanted to um that seems to conflict with
some of the things that were said
earlier that's just me sorry about that
yeah no well I would want to be clear
for the record um that that is not as
not what I intended to say in fact uh
what the reason that we raised this
issue and inclusion in Senate Bill 74
was that our providers could
not um give experimental treatments in
the absence of consent and the Agents
could not because the statute precluded
it thank
you any further questions for this
speaker
chman um I think I see representative
Merchant's hand up thank you Mr chairman
I'll still go back to
Mr Hood um would you be opposed to
modifying the form language in the bill
so it specifically
says that the patient consents to
experimental care in addition to life
threatening so there's two options there
one is strictly looking at the generally
accepted as well as an option for
including experiment experimental
care that way there it's specific on the
form so the patient has to sign off on
it not something that's embeded into the
bill somewhere else that refers back to
it so the form itself is very clear that
I agree to experimental care as well as
General accepted Health Care at the same
time so it's two options for the patient
one strictly generally accepted care two
that provision plus experimental
care so representative Merion I'm I'm
certainly amenable to Clarity of uh
language and the only caveat that I
would give is that this has been a
thoroughly involved stakeholder
engagement process and I can't speak for
the entirety of the group that being
said we can convene to determine if that
would be amendable to the larger group
and we will endeavor to do
that thank you if you decide to pull
together a group before we EX on it I be
glad to be part of
it and might I suggest uh Mr hood that
um at least in addition to bringing the
group your group back together you bring
those legislators who have had various
questions this this is not clear so that
the any Amendment to the form could be
done by both us who wish to participate
and the group who pulled all this
together and the reason I suggest that
is I would hate to have just us do
it
I'm sorry Mr chair I I just missed the
last part of what you said I apologize I
would not want just us or just we
legislators in an exec session to modify
the form so if your group wishes to come
back to modify the form it should
include any
legislators that have objections so that
our concerns about what's not in the
form would be incorporated um that's
more of a state than anything else thank
you I I I heard that this time good
thank you representative um uh Weber was
next thank you Mr chairman and I think
we are
getting very much into the
weeds here so for for Mr
Hood am I correct in understanding as an
overview
that what
this um amendment to existing statute
does is that
overall it
clarifies ways in which a principal may
want to
specify any one of the whole range of
things that they either want to have
happen and or that they do not want to
have
happen and that then there is language
and and if they have
specified then that is generally
speaking except in very narrow
situations what's going to happen and
that the rest of the statute deals with
what you do when the principal has been
silent about their wishes and how you
best aim to give effect to what it is or
was that the principle has stated that
they wanted either now or in the
past yes so I could say two things
representative Weber one is um with
respect to the the summary that you just
described and the section that I spoke
to the answer is yes the other piece
that I'd like to point out to
representative Merchant and the others
on the call is there there are
instructions and and maybe you saw this
but on on page 16 it starts on line 14
and then there's there's what I think
was intended to be very clear I want to
participate in medical clinical trials
and then I don't and so when I reach out
to representative Merchant I My Hope Is
that I will ascertain if if that lacks
Clarity in this
context and may I have a followup Mr
chairman yes
please if I can remember what the
followup is because my brain just
bounced sorry representative I I I took
you on a detour there with a number two
I apologize that's okay
um and oh and here is my follow-up
question as as somebody who is very
aware of Hospital
procedure is it not
true that there are many many relig I
groups um humanist
groups groups who promote thinking on
these very difficult issues of end of
life decision making who get together
just as as we had testimony from the
Catholic dasis that they have an entire
booklet of
guidance for those who wish
to make sure that their ADV Advanced
directives follow their
beliefs that there are any number of
other groups who help potential patients
long before they become patients explore
what they might or might not want to
include in one of these documents and
that it is not at the behest of an
attorney or anything else but that you
can add directions in that reflect your
own personal thoughts that come out of
any number of different kinds of
discussions uh none of which are
specified in the
statute yes Clarity from any uh source
is
welcome representative Marsh and one one
further followup if I can is is it not
true that sometimes those discussion
groups result in the execution at the
end of them of a document personal to
the individual
participants I'm sorry representative
Weber could you could you just restate
the question I uh well let me state it a
different
way um when I was on the Ethics
Committee at Brattleboro Memorial
Hospital we often had workshops for
people on how to fill out these
documents and it was just community
members y'all come and at the end of
those
meetings um sometimes community members
would want to fill out the forms right
then and there and it was the way of
ending that series of meetings should
they choose to do so is it not true that
there are various groups of various
sorts that do that now with respect to
the these
documents I'm sure that there are I you
know I my testimony is constrained to to
Dartmouth Hitchcock's experience and and
um Dr burin Who's no longer um
practicing in the in the Nash area was a
leader in the advanced directive space
for Dartmouth Hitchcock and and he
certainly and we tried to raise
awareness about about um the importance
of engaging in the process of planning
for that event
and and I guess what I was trying to uh
focus on and lost sight of is that that
does not necessarily mean having to go
out and hire a lawyer there are lots of
other ways to engage in the planning
process with people who have been
involved in it that are no cost
thoughtful and with with various
resources available to people yeah yes
thank you
and our Medical Center this is
representative Pearson in the chair our
Medical Center in Kingston regularly has
these workshops and helps people work
through the forums representative Marsh
uh thank you Mr chairman I was intending
to ask Matthew uh whether page 16 lines
12 through 15 was precisely the choice
that representative Merchant wanted to
add by Amendment and I believe he
already answered the question thank you
anyone else from Mr
Hood
or doctor Hood excuse me nope nope
Matthew want to be clear uh I am not a
physician I am a lawyer by
training counselor
Hood anyone else it's very kind Mr chair
welcome um I do see a hand up for
representative Weber is it a new hand or
an old
hand
do I see any other hands
up I seeing any hands up on my
screen like six or five we have five my
apologies I had my hand up I had not
lowered it and then I got a phone call
so my apologies both for the noise and
some attendees with hands up but there
all people that You' previously called
so okay um I will Circle back to them I
want to make sure that everybody on my
list who wishes to speak to us has the
opportunity and the last one I have on
the list that is given me is Mr Robert
Wells of Manchester and if you're still
in the meeting thank you for your
perseverance and we're calling you um to
speak if you
wish oh thank you uh my name is Robert
Wells uh I live in Hopkinton New
Hampshire I've been practicing in the
field of estate planning for almost 50
years um and I would like to defer to
Ben who has the detailed information
that you may want on the bill itself
since he and Jinger Shen were members of
a committee of which I'm also a member
that really worked uh hand inand with
the group to bring this bill to uh
fruition uh so I don't have that kind of
detailed information but let me make a
comment
one of the concerns I have had as a
practitioner for these many many years
with respect to the Health Care
directives is a concern about the
medical community and how they can
respond to the current document the
current document is not helpful to the
medical community because they have to
keep going back to the document as a
patient progresses through various
stages of uh of illness with the new
document we have the medical profession
is more able to deal with the patient in
a way consistent with what the patient
may want and with an ongoing dialogue
with the agent with respect to what the
principal may want so I think this
change uh is is very very helpful I go
all the way back to Susan mlan when she
in 1980 uh got introduced and passed the
living will which was then vetoed by
then Governor John sonunu but
fortunately it was his veto was
overruled subsequent to that we have had
the evolution of healthc care Powers
post etc etc but what this bill does is
it allows the physician and other
medical practitioners to deal with a
patient uh and in discussion with the
agent in a way which is very very
effective uh we now know that our
primary doctor is not in the hospital
it's a hospitalist who's in the doctor
or in the hospital hospital or an
intensivist they may not have a
communication with the patient in terms
of what he or she may want so the agent
then becomes critical uh with respect to
what uh the principal wants as I help
clients work with these current
documents and with in the future with
the future document is you have to have
an agent who is an effective advocate
for you not someone who just sits there
and doesn't do anything and just accepts
whatever comes their way they must be an
advocate and they must be able to
confront the medical community with
concerns and with issues uh and I think
that happens and I know all the doctors
that I know and other medical
practitioners do everything they can but
it is not easy for them to keep going
back to the healthc care directive as
time moves on with respect to the
treatment of a patient so this new
document practically speaking takes care
of that problem um having done this for
so many years and having worked with so
many patient so many clients uh whose
parents or children or others who were
involved with a health care power and
the living will they are all so very
very thankful we have this document but
they do confess that it is complicated
sometimes for them to deal with the
medical community because of the manner
by which the current document is written
so I would strongly urge that you pass
this tremendous work hours and hours and
hours of work by so many people to get
us to where we are today it would be a
shame to turn this back um I do believe
strongly that uh a patient rights are
protected uh people are not going to go
out and act willling nilly with respect
to the termination of someone's life I
think that is highly irresponsible uh
thinking on anyone's part so again I
would advocate for the passage of this
but I would turn over to my colleague uh
Ben to answer specific questions about
the development of the document because
he and Jinger Shen were the members of
our committee who work so closely with
this group I'd be happy to answer any
questions remind me again of Ben's name
please it's Benjamin Syracuse Hillman he
spoke earlier thank you all right I will
call back Benjamin syracusa Hillman um
and take it from
there great thank thank you um chair and
members of the committee um so I am I'm
Benjamin Syracuse Hillman as I mentioned
earlier I'm an attorney at Shaheen and
Gordon in conquer and do Focus my
practice on um estate planning elder law
and probate
litigation uh I'm testifying today on my
own behalf um as well as on the behalf
of the New Hampshire chapter of the
National Academy of elder law attorneys
which is a membership organization of
about 80 attorneys um who represent
elders and persons with disabilities in
our
state as well as the group that uh Bob
Wells just mention the legislative
working group of New Hampshire trust and
Estates attorneys which is an informal
group of about 40 attorneys to convene
approximately monthly to work on
legislation um both groups strongly
support SB 74 uh Ginger Shen um from the
trust and Estates working group um and I
on behalf of that group and Nayla
actively participated in the working
groups that Senator Sherman convened
following the Bill's initial
introduction there was an in-depth
process featuring a robust exchange of
views from stakeholders representing
many different perspectives and the
legislative text was worked through very
carefully to try to accommodate all of
those various interests and to reach
compromises between differing interests
and I'm glad we've gotten to a place
where um each of the various groups have
participated although some were actually
opposed to the bill at the beginning um
um including nla that I was a part of uh
came to a place where we were we were in
support of the
legislation uh the resulting legislation
substantially modernizes our Advanced
Directive law I think most importantly
from my perspective it takes a set of
forms that was confusing and required a
high level of education and knowledge to
read and digest and substantially
modified those forms to make them easier
to read and understand and we expected
individuals whether they're working with
an attorney a medical practitioner a
social worker a family member or by
themselves to complete this form will
now be able to do so in a manner that
better reflects their wishes and
expresses their preferences as compared
with the existing
form the the disclosure statement at the
start of the form um also has been made
substantially clearer more userfriendly
and uh the use of jargon has been
brought down to a minimum so again our
Our Hope and our expectation is that it
just makes it much easier to use and
understand um a couple of the questions
have have touched on changes and I'm
going to get I'm going to try to address
some of the specific questions I heard
earlier in a moment um but but for now I
wanted to mention I mean the the purpose
of the legislation in part was to change
certain defaults that were contrary to
the preferences of the vast majority of
individuals completing the forms um and
the result of those defaults was that it
was often likely that the form was
completed in either a contradictory way
or in a way that um did not actually
reflect the preferences of the
individuals completing the form and I
know you know Dr Lawson may be able to
speak to that more as well um but in
streamlining and simplifying our goal um
was to was to make it um as as likely as
possible that an individual completing
the form is expressing their wishes
affirmatively about who their agent is
and in the case of the living will um
what uh what they would want um you know
in the event that they were unable to
make healthc care decisions for
themselves um you've already heard about
the uh clinical trial and experimental
treatment provision and the importance
of those um I think the legislation also
takes account of the fact you've heard
about this as well that there are now a
wide variety of types of documents in
use by which an individual can express
preferences about their care and it
makes clear that an agent or surrogate
um is is required to honor and respect
those Express preferences whether they
are in the living will or in a different
document or or orally um and the couple
of other things about the legislation um
it cleans up inconsistent uses of
language and inconsistent terms that had
crept into the statute as well as
redundancies as a res as a result of
Prior piece meal changes um it also
allows for the virtual witnessing of
advanced directives and while we expect
that the vast majority of individuals
will continue to sign these directives
before two live Witnesses or a notary um
as historically has been the case the
statute does enable those um who are not
able to do that perhaps because they're
homebound or otherwise unable to
assemble Witnesses or a notary with them
in person to be able to execute
directives with remote witnessing um and
that's something that has been happening
during the pandemic in other contexts um
as a result originally the executive
order and then subsequently um
legislation and I know those of us in
the estate planning field um while it
has not substituted for uh in-person
signings which remain um you know an
important and primary part of how how
this takes place um in in situations
where they're necessary it's very
helpful um and finally uh the
legislation as you've heard updates the
surgy statute so that those individuals
who have not chosen agents which I think
is actually a majority of folks in New
Hampshire will be able to have a person
empowered to make medical decisions uh
while still maintaining important limits
on that Authority um and the same
guideline guidance and limitations that
apply to agents will also apply to
surgat um the authority of a serate will
end after 180 days unless the patient is
determining determined to be actively
dying um which you heard Gina balkus
testify about earlier why that's
important um and that's up from 90 days
in current law um this was a carefully
negoti iated balance which the folks
involved felt allowed for surrogate
decision making on um a short and
medium-term basis and allowing for
families to avoid needing to rush to get
a guardianship um for purposes of making
end of life decisions during what can
what can already be a very difficult uh
time in in one's life in one's family
life um but also maintaining the limit
on surrogacy um so that surrogacy does
not become a long-term alternative to a
guardianship um of the person where
someone has not done an advanced
directive um and the the law maintains
existing protections that allow any
interested person to pursue a
guardianship petition at which point
once appointed a court appointed
Guardian would be able to act instead of
a medical practitioner appointed
surrogate um I I do want to address um
um some of the questions that I heard um
come up earlier and in earlier testimony
and earlier questions um some of these
have been addressed by others um but I
think there's a few we haven't really
gotten to yet um so one is uh what
appears at the bottom of page six of the
bill um it's in uh J5 Roman 4 um this
idea of um treatment uh against
objection so in in New Hampshire law
right now it provides that if one is
incapacitated um and objects to
treatment treatment may not be given
over their objection unless there there
is an affirmative statement in the
advanced directive authorizing it and
this provision which as far as I know is
very unusual I don't know that any other
states have this sort of provision um
can make it very difficult when you have
an individual who has been determined by
their physician to be incapable of
making medical decisions for themselves
and does have an agent acting um but who
nevertheless
articulates um you know a verbal
objection uh to to and that could be
either to treatment or to the lack of
you know to a lack of treatment um and
regardless even if those objections are
entirely um incoherent or not in
someone's interest you know the the way
the law is is worded right now um they
have to be honored or respected and then
the only um real option is to go to
court and get a guardianship so someone
has the power to override those in
addition because of that there are a
number of facilities in our state um
particularly facilities um that treat uh
patients with uh you know severe
Dementia or that have memory care units
who if if there's an Advanced Directive
and the the no box is checked meaning no
I do not authorize treatment over my
objection will
require the um agent to go to court and
get a guardianship before they'll admit
someone under the agent's Authority be
their reasoning being well if the if the
patient says you know take me home I
want to go home you know I want to sign
myself out the agent would have no
ability to consent to the individual
staying in the facility um and so a lot
of facilities are not willing to take
that risk even if that's not a a present
issue I have found in my practice when I
explain to folks the implications of
this and the implications of this
question um I'd say well over 80% choose
to allow treatment over their objection
meaning to allow the agent to make the
final decision um and so you know the
agent under j6 is required to listen to
the principle required to adhere to
their wishes however expressed in
writing or orally um and so we felt on
balance you know there was adequate
protection for uh patients wishes being
honored um while still not putting
individuals who need medical care um and
their agents in in a difficult position
um that said the uh I heard testimony
saying well no you know you don't you
don't even know that now when you sign
the form and that that is not the case
um at the top of page 16 in the
disclosure statement it explains that
you know you can add that back in that
you can put that limit on your agent um
if you wish to do so and again in my
experience it's it's well under 20% of
individuals who who want that limitation
in there um we uh heard questions about
removing the rights of hospitals and
Facilities to opt out and I think as was
pointed out at both the bottom of page
nine and at the top of page 10 there is
language in the bill that acknowledges
you know how that works requires
transfer both for the individual
practitioner at the bottom of page nine
in Roman 2 and then in what will be New
Roman 3 at the on page 10 and um
addressing the healthc care provider or
residential care provider um being able
to opt out um there was a uh question um
I think from representative kushman
about will people need to complete new
forms um 137 j16 in the existing statute
which is not being amended by S SP 74 um
said referring to documents executed
prior to enactment says nothing in this
chapter limits the enforceability of an
advanced Direct Ive or similar
instrument validly executed under prior
New Hampshire law um that was considered
and deliberately left in so that um we
recognize that you know there there's
going to be even if this bill passes you
know the old form will probably remain
in uh prevalent in circulation for at
least the next decade and we want to
make sure that you know individuals who
have done these forms in the past and
expressed their wishes will will
obviously continue to have those wishes
honored um and they can do a new form if
they wish but no one's going to have to
you know rush to their doctor or their
PCP to to do a new form you know the day
that this law passes if it does um I I
believe that uh oh and then finally
there was um representative Merchant
your question about the um living will
and could it be amended um I don't want
to speak for the broader group I'd
certainly be um you know willing to be
part of a dialogue about that and I
think that would be helpful the one
thing I can say is we did consider
having a separate section of the form
relating to experimental treatment given
the various options that the statute
gives and ultimately decided against
that for the reason that um the the
medical practitioners in the group
advise us that this is a you know a
fairly rare circumstance when this comes
into um when this becomes relevant for
an individual and the more questions the
more sections we add to the form um you
know the more confusing it becomes the
less likely it is somebody successfully
completes the entire form and so our
goal was really to to keep the form as
simple as possible to maximize the
chance that someone can complete it and
complete it accurately and reflecting
their wishes while um you know putting
in the disclosure statement itself which
is required to be with the form uh the
various other options and explanations
so on page 16 in the disclosure
statement it says the law allows your
agent to put you in a clinical trial or
to agree to new or experimental
treatment um and you know and states the
conditions that are the default and then
says you may change this by writing in
the form and then there's two options
below um and so you know rather than
having that be a separate section of the
form that's how we decided to address it
I do see um representative Merchant what
your you know your comment about why you
know in the living will having that
language in a might be um inadvertently
read to limit um someone's ability to
consent to experimental treatment I
would point out the living will is not
legally binding it's designed as
guidance and I do think the law the
statute itself and the disclosure form
makes clear what the agents Authority is
in this respect but I'd certainly be
open to a a dialogue about you know can
this be made even clearer because
obviously bringing in um questions from
folks seeing this for the first time um
it's always helpful to to step back and
reconsider um you know could another
tweak be made because uh you know we we
we tried very hard and we spent many
hours but I'm I'm sure we didn't get it
done perfectly um
thank you for for listening and I'm
happy to take any
questions thank you Mr hman I think it's
very helpful for the committee to know
the time and effort and compromises that
went into preparing this bill do we have
questions for Mr
Hol go ahead thank you chairman um Mr
Helman thank you for taking my question
um this is a really simple one but these
are the kinds of things we get asked uh
that earlier people spoke to uh
workshops that have happened where
people can go to and get guidance on how
to fill out these forms and they want to
just fill them out right then and there
and um but this is a legal document uh
what if a person shows up at the
hospital because they haven't gotten to
the lawyer yet turned it into a legal
document but they've got it all written
out by hand would that have any standing
at
all
yes I mean there is no the document
needs to be either witnessed by two
individuals or notorized so something
that someone has purely handwritten um
you know wouldn't qualify legally as an
advanced directive that said um if they
had an agent or or a surrogate appointed
um under
137 j6 um you know there is a
requirement that the agent or surrogate
make Healthcare decisions in accordance
with their knowledge of the principal
wishes and religious or moral beliefs as
stated orally in writing or otherwise
communicated by the principal um and
then if those wishes are unknown in
accordance with their assessment of best
interests and in accordance with
accepted medical practice so I think in
that case you refer um you know if I was
uh I don't generally advise hospitals um
but if if if I was if I had a hospital
with my client saying you know can the
agent honor this can this be honored I
would say absolutely because um the that
that's the principal's communication you
know as long as there weren't questions
about authenticity but that's the
principal's communication and under j6
you know the agent or surrogate uh would
need to honor
it follow thank you um and that
surrogate can be um assigned
by
the
caregiver uh by that I'm I'm looking for
the list of possible people that they
could pick from starting 25 yeah
starting with closest relatives so um
say cousin uh Sally knows um knows me
really well and and saw me write this
out and we talked about it um and the
doctor said hey she seems to know you
well you seem to know her well you can
be a
surrogate and then then it would have
some impact then for the surrogate to
say no look we've already we've
discussed these things and written them
down it just wasn't signed by an
attorney or a
notary exactly right so if there was no
valid appointment of an agent you know
no formal document designating an agent
then the surrogacy statute would come
into play and you have that order that
hierarchical order um in the statute um
and then the once that person is
designated formally as the decision
maker they are then charged with
adhering to you know all of those things
I referenced in j6 so yes I think
practically if um you know if this
person is the closest person and there
isn't a you know a higher level you know
spouse or an adult child or parent you
know who can come in then and and we get
to that level and it even it even goes
down to friends so it doesn't have to be
um even a relative uh you know that the
idea of the surrogacy statute is that
person can then you know be the one who
makes decisions in the event a family
conflict where you have more than one
person who is claiming to speak for the
principal that's when you're going to
have to go to court and get a
guardianship um but let's say even in
the situation you described say you had
a you know someone who was higher up on
the list who didn't you know who the
cousin said well they don't know them as
well you know I should really be the
decision maker here the cousin could
still go and petition for Guardianship
and argue to a probate judge that really
they should be the decision maker not
the adult child who hasn't been involved
in their life for 20 years and that's a
decision that you know the the medical
practitioner is not going to be in a
good position to make but that's why we
have probate courts and probate judges
who can assess and make you know a
decision that they feel is in the best
interest of the of the individual thank
you for clarifying that very good
questions from Mr
H yes
represent thank you uh I have a question
on the concerning overriding of patients
wishes so you you gave the example of
someone who has advanced dementia and
that the need for this override to be in
the bill came from uh policies of uh
Memory Care units and the like of
requiring family members to go get a
guardianship um I have a little trouble
with taking that up because I I sort of
think that it should be required to go
to court to override a patient's wishes
wishes could you expound on um why you
would believe it's appropriate to not
require a more serious and thorough
investigation and determination of that
guardianship um yes thank you for the
question representative kushman um you
know I I think what the way I would
think about it is for my perspective at
least is um you know what is the way
that the legislature can best honor
individual preferences and in my
experience the vast majority of
individuals who complete an advanced
directive do so because they want
another individual to be able to make
decisions for them a trusted uh you know
family member or close friend to be able
to make decisions for them in the event
that they've been determined that
they're not able to make decisions for
themselves so I I think there are number
of safeguards one is that the whole
Advanced Directive is not in place
unless uh you know unless one's
practitioner has determined based on you
know the prevailing medical standard
that this individual is not does not
have capacity to make decisions for
themselves so if someone has capacity to
make decisions for themselves it doesn't
matter what they've put in the document
you know they're the ones making the
decisions but if we're in that box where
the document has been activated and
individual is making decisions um you
know the vast majority of people want
that individual to be able to make
decisions for them even contrary to what
they are are expressing at the time for
those people who do not feel that way
who say no I do not you know it makes me
uncomfortable I do not want to give up
that level of autonomy even if a
doctor's determined that I can't make
decisions you know I don't trust that I
I still want whatever I express verbally
to be honored the form and the law still
allows for that so they can still put in
their durable power of attorney for
healthcare no you know my agent cannot
make decisions over my expressed obje
ction or you know if I if I articulate
the decision that I want even if I've
been found incapacitated my agent can't
make a decision to the contrary you know
without going to court I'd say finally
even for individuals who um have
expressed you know the view that they
want an override um to be able to happen
uh you know in that in but I'm deeming
sort of like the 80% of of New Hampshire
folks that I've interacted with uh if
you then got to the point where they
felt like their agent was acting
contrary to their interests you know
they or another family member could
always petition the probate court I mean
if they have capacity they could revoke
the directive um if they didn't have
capacity um and again we sort of
assuming that if it's activated that
that at least their doctors determin
they don't have capacity um either they
individually or with the assistance of a
family member or friend nevertheless
could petition the probate court to um
have their directive voked and so and or
have somebody else appointed so to me
it's a question of both preserving
autonomy for the individuals who want to
make that decision while also not
putting the vast majority of people in a
position where like they've named an
agent and they think that agent can make
decisions for them but in fact there's
this limit that they didn't really
understand or contemplate um and now the
agent has to go to court and get a
guardianship have follow you may have a
follow thank you for answering my
question question um I believe that you
alluded to that that um it's disclosed
in the disclosure um but I that they
have the
option um to explicitly state that they
don't want their their
um desires overridden by an agent but is
there I believe this bill and so can you
tell me if this bill removes the
requirement to make sure that the
signing reads the
disclosure yeah so I think I understand
the question so just to point out um for
clarification where it is in the
disclosure it's um the bottom of page 15
and the top of page 16 the bottom of 15
says you know with few exceptions your
agent will make decisions for you when
you're unable to make them for yourself
and some people do not want to allow
their agent to make some decisions and
you can write in um and then the last WR
WR in item which is lines 5 to six on
page 16 says to agree to treatment even
if I object to it in the moment after
I've lost the ability to make Healthcare
decisions for myself um so I just want
to clarify that that's where it is
getting um to the specific
question
um you know and then the form itself
says you can write in you can write in
limits um and I'm sorry now that I went
on the tangent I forgot your specific
question do you mind articulating it
again I'm sorry okay I know that the
form itself says you can write in your
own um your own instructions but it
doesn't say explicitly you can write
what the disclosure mentions and is
there a provision in the bill and on the
form that
requires the person signing the form to
read the
disclosure ah I understand does is there
I I get the question so the statute used
the current statute requires that the
disclosure be
signed um we uh removed that provision
in the proposed Bill and I'm on page 13
lines 27 to 29 so we maintain the
provision saying that every person
wishing to execute an advanced directive
shall be provided with the disclosure
statement um but remove the provision
saying that they're required to sign a
statement acknowledging that they've
received it and the reason why we
proposed to remove that is because um
you know we were trying to eliminate
barriers to completing and and and
making a valid Advanced Directive um and
under current law an individual not only
has to sign the disclosure statement
they have to sign the durable power of
attorney for healthcare and they have to
sign the living will so in theory there
were you know three separate places an
individual had to sign and in the effort
to make the document easier and not have
have um sort of artificial legal
barriers to completion we we said you
know there's there's one we're going to
have one signature place so there is not
a separate Signature Place for the
disclosure statement but there is still
that affirmative requirement that the
disclosure statement accompany the
advanced
directive could I
speak who is this this is Bob Wells uh
Mr Wells I will recognize you later if
you raise your hand but I we don't let
the public ask questions of members of
the public that's uh not the way the
committee are do you have any further
followups are you
done um I'm just wondering if the
sponsors of the bill I guess it's for
the sponsor
so thank
you any further questions from Mr
H um I guess I would just add if I may
representative kushman I mean certainly
you know as I said there were a lot of
decisions and compromises that went into
this but if if a group does get convened
to discuss some of the concerns that
have been addressed and you feel that
having a separate Signature Place for
the disclosure statement is something
that would allay that concern you know I
think certainly all these things are
open to discussion right you're the
you're the legislators it's ultimately
up to you you know what you wish to
happen so I just I didn't want to I just
wanted to give the answer as to why we
made the decision but not to say that
you know the concern isn't a valid one
or one that you know could be considered
or
addressed take extra time thank you very
much seeing no further hands Dr Lawson
representative Weber you have a question
uh my question is simply to ask the
chair at the appropriate time to
recognize uh Mr Wells who is a member of
this rotating panel to ask answer to
give his answer to the question that was
just opposed to um
Mr uh Hillman because he also had some
clarification I believe the chair's
intention was to recognize Dr Lawson and
then Mr Wells so we will get to that
thank you are there any for Mr Helman
before we move
along thank you um and I think I can
answer that question as well um or maybe
what Bob was going to suggest but I
didn't introduced myself when answering
questions previously I did
want sorry go ahead Dr Lawson you're
supposed to wait until you get
recognized by the chair oh I apologize
very good you make I didn't know we was
speaking because somebody just started
before I recognized you but you may
continue thank you um yeah so Dr Lawson
I practice at Littleton Regional
Healthcare in a number of roles uh and
have sat for its existence on the
healthc Care Coalition I I did want to
just recognize before the committee
attorney Kate Hannah who spent
exorbitant amounts of time you know
probably in the range of 50 hours
volunteer time on this and is unable to
to be here due to personal health
reasons um but I just wanted to
recognize her for the record and and her
incredible institutional knowledge and
expertise and participation in this um
we all Ben Kate myself and others have
has spent exhaustive hours addressing
this with with multiple stakehold
holders you know going word for word
really through the the law multiple
times um uh Ben addressed most of what
my testimony was uh focused on so I Will
Not Duplicate that but I did want to
focus on a couple things um number one
uh represent of kushman in regards to an
answer to your question the the bottom
of the dpoa statement spefic
specifically says please review the
disclosure statement that is attached to
this Advanced Directive for examples on
how you might limit your agents
Authority and we felt that in
combination with the inclusion or necess
necessity to include the disclosure
statement um would be adequate for
people who may want to uh have some
limitations or have some questions in
regards to how they might limit the
durable power it's important to
understand that all the issues around
experimental treatment around uh
treatment against objection the override
Clause you're referring to these are all
things where you're not making specific
statements about what you want you're
making specific statements about the
authority you're giving to your durable
power whether the durable power is going
to be able to allow certain things or
not um it's really important to
understand and and Peter may be able to
Peter ases may be able to State this
year's data but of people who present a
hospital it's well under 50% like high
30s per who have an advanced
directive the majority of the people we
care for do not have an advanced
directive do not come in and often come
in without
capacity and the law needs to address
those people in respectful ways that can
respect their best wishes as best we can
understand them and as an example the
treatment against objection Clause when
the default is that they have to
sign to allow treatment against
objection in the
moment that provides an incredible
barrier to this wide range of
exceedingly de you know demented
Advanced dementia patients suffering
from Advanced dementia Who present do do
not have an advanced directive are
swinging at the nurses pulling out their
IVs highly agitated
and this is every day in the hospital
you know this is this is not an unusual
thing this is every day and to not be
able to treat them and to not allow the
family to okay us giving medication to
treat their agitation or to help calm
them is abominable it's horrible we we
can't legally do it you know honestly we
do it anyway we take the legal risk but
it's definitively against the law
as it's stated and if we were to replace
that
default to force signing to to treat
against objection we would be back in
that state this is one of the most
important improvements in my clinical
opinion in the law uh is that adjustment
to uh make the default the allowance for
the durable power of attorney with the
medical team to come up with the best
possible approach to challenging
situations as opposed to not allow any
treatment against objection are multiple
psychogeriatric patients who suffer from
dementia and paranoia um they cannot be
transferred to Specialty Care to a
psychogeriatric unit if they have not
signed that so that's over 50% and
actually most of these folks who suffer
from these conditions don't fill out
Advanced directus for what should be
obvious reasons they don't have the
support they're generally Indigent they
are suspicious to begin with and they
cannot be treated in a psychogeriatric
unit they end up sitting in a regular
like our critical access Hospital often
for months at a
time because we can't transfer them
because they they are saying no I don't
want to be transferred despite the fact
they're suffering from an advanced
psychiatric condition that's profoundly
impairing their
capacity um so these are hopefully that
explains
sort sort of the the reason for
adjusting that treatment against
capacity uh default that is not I've
read at least 50 different Advanced
directives from jurisdictions throughout
the world and most of the US states and
this is very specific and only in New
Hampshire I understand Live Free or Die
but
unfortunately this in my opinion
clinically pushes it to a state that
harms far more than helps um so that's
that's you know kind of my point on the
treatment against objection component uh
speaking to um uh representative lot's
concerns I uh I had trouble
understanding them and some of them were
misrepresentations but in existing law
the durable power of attorney has the
authority to override the living will
the way it is now uh the that's very
specific in present law and so this
document you know does explicitly try to
simplify the situation our goal here
primarily is to give people the
opportunity to get past the barriers to
at least comp completing the durable
power of attorney so they can at least
decide and speak with who they want to
make decisions for them and to put down
some specific you know uh statements
about their wishes but we expect that
other forms as uh representative Weber
referred to they're numerous
available where they can be assisted to
go into much more complexity and much
more depth about their wishes in
specific circumstances the moment we add
those to the durable Power of Attorney
form whether and I would be strongly
against adding the experimental
treatment options in the actual form the
moment we do that it provides a
tremendous
barrier experimental treatment for
people who've lost capacity outside of a
pandemic situation is exceedingly rare
and having to go through that discussion
if you're filling out an advanced
directive with a patient and the
complicated possible options is going to
provide a significant barrier to
completion um when it's a something that
we very rarely
encounter so that that was really
focused on the pandemic and and
situations of that sort where
experimental treatment or un you know
yet to be unproven treatment maybe maybe
um appropriate and meet the standard of
care so that that kind of covers the
stuff that hasn't already be covered I
wanted I wanted just to refocus on the
the relevance and the importance of j6
and the strong belief of the committee
uh that we have to do everything
possible to respect and to honor a
patient's values and wishes that's the
goal here and this
adjustment uh and Improvement
significant impr Improvement in my
opinion the in the law does that it's
been a you know a process of tremendous
compromise of tremendous work on the
part of a huge number of people for
really the better part of the last year
and and I really appreciate your time
and the ability to speak and and would
like to answer any questions or uh or
certainly be available offline by email
or otherwise to discuss you know the the
clinical or medical aspects of it so so
thank you for the
time thank you Dr lson uh represent
Weber did you still have a question or
you intended to lower your
hand I guess I'll go back to it it's it
again it was the treatment against um
what the patient is declaring when the
patient may not have capacity to make
for decision making and
um would this address am I correct in
thinking that this would address the
situation
that I encountered when I served as
guardian for elders that I had not known
previously but who needed a courta
appointed decision maker and if I spoke
to one of those people and asked her do
you want an operation she would say
no so that's declaring that she doesn't
want it if I asked the
question Dr Smith says you need an
operation is that okay she would say
yes and then if I asked so you do want
an operation she would say
no so that gets us into a terrible bind
I mean in that situation I simply had
the decision-making Authority but I was
bound even then to follow her wishes as
best I could follow them so does this
not resolve the problem of um the answer
you get depends sometimes times in the
real world on how you ask the
question yes I think that's correct
representative Weber I um and it just to
clarify it's not may have lost capacity
it legally H the patient has lost
capacity um they have to have been
formally assessed and that has to be a
formal process by which they've been
deemed to have lost capacity so this i i
people this is an tremendously confusing
you know part this this is to to go
through this with patients every time
you fill out an advanced directive is
incredibly confusing and people get
caught up in this this only refers to
people who have been deemed to have lost
capacity so you're out of it you don't
you cannot understand your medical
condition you cannot understand the
options for treatment or the potential
consequences of choosing those options
that has been formally assessed you've
lost it you don't have that ability
right that that's the preset situation
this doesn't apply except in that
situation it is in the moment it doesn't
refer as As I understood represent leot
to suggest to statements made in the
past when you did have capacity it only
refers in the moment to the
specific actions verbal physical
otherwise that the patient may be
showing um in their state of loss of
capacity and those statements are often
confused they're often contradictory
they often change minute by minute hour
by hour day by day and uh so it's it's
very very difficult um to interpret and
absolutely we all know that that um
individuals particularly loved ones can
significantly change what people who are
confused say um by the way they ask the
question and that that can happen and um
I believe that the present setup of the
default being to allow treatment over
objection after loss of
capacity with the option to say
otherwise with a limit on the durable
power I believe that that puts us firmly
in the best position to honor wishes I
encounter frequently situations where
that has not been completed by those who
either haven't completed an advanced
directive or didn't sign that component
of section B of the present Advanced
Direction
Where patients are suffering where
either practitioners are forced to do an
illegal act or they follow the law and
the patient suffers tremendously to the
shock of the family members of why the
clinical team is not intervening I
encounter that you know that comes up
frequently the alternative case where
there is you you know a a situation of
someone who has purposefully not signed
it or or and and we don't act you know
according that is definitely a concern
it's definitely a risk but again go back
to j6 and focus on j6 that's the core we
keep referencing back to it because of
how important it is that we do our best
as a team of people caring for someone
to honor their wishes as best we could
and if we believe that not responding to
their objection after loss of capacity
is the best that's how we would proceed
the present law allows that no matter
you know what the patient has
signed sorry the present
s74 you know allows that whereas the
previous law does not that we're
presently
under thank you for that are there any
more questions for Mr for Dr
Lawson representative
mer thank you Mr chairman and I'll so
thank you Dr Lawson um it sounds like
the critical piece here is having the
conversation with the patient while
they're still able to comprehend it
their
decisions um as I listen to
representative Weber being appointed by
a court the
more
documentation some way along the way
that the patient has consented whatever
we're talking about it sounds like it's
easier on the legal system it's also
easier on the medical system so is that
a fair statement of trying to ascertain
from the patient as much as possible
what their options are and what they
want to do with those
options yeah sorry representative
Merchant um you're breaking up a little
bit there on my line the but I
understand your question to be is is um
is it not easier on the uh the court and
the clinical team if the patient has had
conversations beforehand that have
stipulated their wishes that's correct
yeah absolutely absolutely and this
balance of for sure um and the balance
of how much to emphasize those
conversations in the dpoa form right
versus to to look at other more
effective venues and
strategies is a a somewhat challenging
you know discussion and that's that we
certainly came down on the side of
making the dpoa form as simple and
straightforward and easy to complete as
possible with the best possible defaults
and options for the form to be a venue
for that extensive discussion but not
force that form to be the venue for
extensive discussions does that make
sense so you know our goal is to be able
to get more like you know 75 80% of more
people completing at least the dpoa form
and giving an opportunity for them to
stipulate at least basic wishes at least
who they want to make decisions for them
um and uh and an opportunity at that
time to to stipulate much more but not
Place barriers that would significantly
limit the chance that they're going to
fill out this form um and then the other
avenues whether it be three wishes the
Catholic um document which is an
excellent document in my opinion and
conversation project Five Wishes there
numerous different online free you know
strategies to stipulate wishes that
would be adhered to and and can do a
much much better job than trying to
enforce it through a legal Avenue of a
dpoa thank you are there any further
questions for Dr LW representative
kushman thank you Mr chair uh I am Dr
Lawson thank you for taking my question
I just I understand that getting um you
know getting a guardianship in place um
um is important for these Advanced
dementia patients and you know it's
better to have everything in place
beforehand and it can be challenging to
do it after the fact that someone is in
an advanced stage of dementia however
this bill doesn't if this is the heart
of the bill and it's the core of the
bill it it's not really explicitly
stated that way and it it leaves it open
to apply to others besides those who
have advanced dementia so I'm
wondering is there um was there any
discussion about making it specific to
Advanced dementia because another
concern is if a person has say
delirium um from an acute infection and
it's misdiagnosed as Advan as dementia
and then the physician and their
physician's assistant who's pretty
influenced by The Physician and now
they're given Authority Under this to be
one of the designers to say that
someone's without capacity to make
decisions then you know and that person
objects to something I just see a
problem here and I wonder if that was
addressed and the specific language to
dementia was address was
considered yes thank you um
representative kushman it was and in
fact in the living will section we had
specific language around dementia but in
compromise with certain
um subgroups uh that language was
specifically removed um the as an option
you know about when you would would or
wouldn't want um life sustaining
treatment as an option the uh your point
is well taken I do believe the the law
would not allow a PA under the authority
of a physician to be um one of the
stipulating I believe it's specifically
suggests that the physician assistant
isn't under the authority of the
physician just to be clear on that or or
at least it did um in the last draft I
had so I I don't think that situation
could occur but I would have to be a
physician assistant who's not under the
authority so we we specifically
discussed that at some length too um
yeah and there are situations absolutely
where where there could be misdiagnosis
um where uh a um a group of clinicians
as well as an including um family
members you know may make a mistake it
absolutely happens um but the and again
it's sort of a balance of benefit and
risk so we did look at this in regards
to specifically dementia We There was
talk even about a separate dementia
directive um again I would suggest in
our our plan was really to
allow all those to come under j6 so that
you know there are there is the dementia
directive you know it's you can pull up
online I think that's exactly what it's
called the dementia directive um that
allows for this kind of decision making
along with the other tools it's one of
the the the good tools but not to embed
that specifically in the law and that it
it was challenging because uh as Bob
Dunn has
testified um people there there are
significant stakeholders who strongly
believe that we should not be separating
uh Dementia in any way uh in regards to
how we um address you know
decisions around these issues that a
dementia patient should be treated
exactly the same no matter how advanced
their dementia may be so that was a
specific
compromise trust me that like
every we we've been through and I don't
mean that I very much respect all the
representatives and you know input on
this in statements but all these things
in in excruciating detail have have been
um discussed at
length thank you Dr lson we appreciate
that are there any further questions for
Dr
Les seeing none I said earlier that I
recognize Mr Wells if he has something
further decide you may do
so he's muted he's muted and if he
doesn't wish to say anything he's
certainly free to not say anything no
excuse me sorry um again my name is
Robert Wells I'm a senior director in
the trust and the state department at
mlan Middleton I've been practicing in
this area for 50 years I'm also the past
president I'm member of the board of
directors of the Office of Public
Guardian which office handles the great
majority of appointments by the probate
court to deal with individuals with
disabilities um historically speaking I
think it's extremely important for this
group to know that before we had that
provision that Ben so carefully
explained about the treatment against
objection we didn't have it at that
point I worked with then judge Maher who
was the chief judge of the then called
probate court to add this provision and
the reason it was added is that the
court was being absolutely overwhelmed
with emergency guardianship Provisions
proceedings uh because there was no
provision for acting against someone's
uh uh objection uh so what this bill
does is expands that to make sense out
of avoiding having to go to a court for
an emergency Guardianship and a person
has named someone that they trust to
make those statements again against
objection and what are we generally
talking about we're generally talking
about people in a nursing home who
refuse to have a flu shot refuse to have
a CO shot who don't want to have uh some
some type of treatment if they don't
have it they would be required to remove
to move away from the home so what we
have here is a very practical uh
adjustment to our statute to allow
greater Authority for an agent to act to
avoid proceedings in the court what is
also important to know is for those of
you who deal with the Probate Court the
probate court is absolutely overwhelmed
with work and lack of staff and you
impose additional object uh oblig on
them they are not able to perform as we
would hope they could perform that's not
your fault that's a failure of proper uh
investment in our court system which
from which we all now suffer uh so I
think it is extremely important to pass
this bill with this provision about
treatment against objection I do not
believe it will in any way impact a
negative uh group of people uh in any
way shape or form but historically we
need need to understand why we have what
we have and why we need to have this
additional
provision thank you Mr well questions
for Mr
Wells seeing none is there any other
members of the public who wish to speak
the only hand I see up is Dr lon's and
he just spoke I think he forgot to lower
his
hand and he just
did if there are no other hands raised I
will now close the public hearing on
Senate Bill 74 and the committee will be
in recess until 1:30 thank you
[Music]
every
you're
set
[Music]
good
thanl make sure
I
right he
was yes he was on here already do you
want me to give him
[Music]
conf
Co
[Music]
I
all right here we
go
okay I'm going to open the hearing on
162 but before I do unless I forget on
the previous bill Senate Bill
74 we had 25 sign up in support three
sign up in opposition and no one
declared
neutrality on the bill before us 162 we
have five signed up to support six
signed up in opposition and no one in
neutrality over the lunch hour besides
testifying on a bill of mine I met with
um Aaron goule from the speaker's office
and he has said that we can have Monday
May
17th for our next meeting which I hope
will be simply
only um executing bills so I'm opening
the hearing on uh Senate Bill 162 FM and
the chair calls on Senator Bradley to
present his bill
pleas good afternoon Mr chairman and
members of the
committee hope everybody is doing well
this morning Jeb Bradley from wolfboro
and please to be here and sponsor Senate
Bill 162 I was asked by the Department
of Health and Human Services to
sponsor this legislation which makes a
number of technical changes to various
uh laws some are broader than others um
John Williams and his team uh will go
through the bill section by section and
give a delineation for you let me just
hit a couple of the highlights that uh
the Senate uh made changes to and by the
way the Senate uh went through my
committee Health and Human Services then
it went through the finance committee
and the final vote of the Senate um on
the bill was 24
to0 so the first um issue that the
Senate looked at was section five which
is on the first page of the bill um near
the bottom of that page the emergency
service plan um this is a requirement or
in the original bill of lure for both
physical and behavioral health by
hospitals there was a lot of um
discussion in the senate about how to do
this and make sure that there was
collaboration between hospitals and the
Department of Health and Human Services
and so as you can see on line
28 um we called for a plan to be drafted
that um made sure that there was
collaboration between the parties the
hospitals and um the
department so just there are a number of
sections dealing with therapeutic
cannabis I think Mike Hol will um
outline those these were a request of
the department um dealing with
therapeutic
cannabis skipping ahead uh there was
some question raised in the Senate on
page 10 section 48 about the interstate
compact for placement of children I just
want to stress this is not a new law
this is existing
legislation uh that has been repealed
and reenacted and I think when folks
understood that any questions um
disappeared on that
score
there was some
discussion jumping ahead to page 28
section 53 and
54 about the auto
injectors um the camps came to us and we
added the language that you see at the
bottom of page 28 which shall be
reasonably accessible and that's
replicated um
elsewhere in the bill um Section 5
5 uh and 56 these are important um
issues for the division children youth
and family um and I'll I'll just leave
it at that and let Mr Williams and
others talk about
it um on page
32 starting in line
14 the Medicaid work requirement there's
been a lot of discussion about that
right now it's under suspension due to
an injunction in federal court so this
language just clarifies that if a court
holds it's invalid if the center for
Medicare and Medicaid services withdraws
approval um then the program will be
suspended and that just clarifies what
could in fact be the case if it gets
changed in
Washington uh two other things
um section
71 which is the next to last section on
page 75 uh page 35 excuse me was added
as a result of a discussion that
occurred in Senate Bill 140 which was
Senator Rosen wald's Bill about the
possibility of
lure uh for case management and again
like with the hospitals if there is
going to be a discussion about license
ing um case managers we wanted to make
sure that everybody had a seat at the
table um and that's what section 71 does
uh one other thing that I would add that
did get dropped from the bill um was a
section that would have required um
Mental Health Providers to provide
transitional housing there was a lot of
controversy about that um we dropped it
because of commitment that uh the
department and commissioner shanet have
made to deal with that in terms of
Contracting and I believe that um there
will be more information coming out
about that shortly from the
commissioner's office so um thank you
very much Mr chair and happy to answer
your
questions any questions for the
senator representative Marsh yes thank
you senator for appearing before our
committee and and bringing this bill to
our attention my question refers to
sections 12 and 13 which you just
referred to uh page that's on page three
and what this does is it strikes out
language from one of my bills a few
years ago and replaces it with the
language that this chapter shall not
apply to individuals who have been
issued a registry identification card
and so forth uh my read of the new
language is that this means that youth
who've been issued a registry
identification card will now legally be
allowed to go and buy cigarettes at the
corner store and is that your intention
I rather doubt that that's actually your
intention here not my intention and
obviously um that's a question for Mr
Williams and um others when they
testify and as a followup Mr chairman
follow up would would you be dreadfully
upset if I putting an amendment to
remove sections 12 and 13 from this vill
uh probably better to try to rewrite it
to make sure that the Department's
intent is captured but if that if
there's no other way to do it then I
would agree with you thank you very
much any other questions uh
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you senator for taking my question just
to be completely sure that I understand
uh on page 32 lines 14 to 17 if we pass
those as they stand then even if it is
Court action or some other action that
we here in New Hampshire cannot
control if any entity invalidates the
work in community
engagement
waiver then the whole program is
suspended is that
correct the work program not Medicaid
expansion the work program okay the
Workforce program thank you for
clarifying that that relieves my mind
considerably well I would hope so yeah
you had me there for a minute I was
really worried that the whole thing was
going straight away and I did not read
it quite carefully enough thank you
you any further
questions thank you Senator okay thank
you very
much I had a nice conversation with Mr
John Williams recently and he told me
that he has F tested a walkth through
the bill in the Senate and it made
things go very quickly and very smooth
Wiley so having tried it Off Broadway
the chair now
recognizes John Williams to walk us
through the
bill Mr chair and members of the Health
and Human Services healthly Affairs
committee uh for the record my name is
John Williams I'm the director of
legislative affairs and I come to you
today in support of the department
requested Omnibus Bill and it is a a
thoughtful approach to to bring together
the Department's entirety of its policy
legislation in one bill uh for those of
you who are uh in the session or part of
the membership of the legislature back
in 2019 you may recall pre-pandemic
times that we brought forward SB 289
which was the Department's Omnibus Bill
at that time and it worked exceedingly
well in terms of the use of your time in
energy so uh Mr chair with your
permission if we could have uh
researcher Dyer Miss Dyer uh bring up
the text legislation uh what we will do
is give a high level walkr of the uh
pieces of Senate Bill 162 give some
context and also I have with me uh
several other members of the department
that I will call on uh to uh provide you
with background information on the
various sections of the bill I also
wanted to thank uh Senator Bradley for
his graciousness and bringing forth
legislation and also for the the work
they had done in the Senate to actually
get a very good bill uh in front of you
here today so if we can enlarge the
screen just a little bit Miss dyer for
those of us
who are a little bit challenged with
reading glasses fantastic thank you so
section one of the bill uh is a series
of uh nine different sections throughout
the legislation and they are a cleanup
of dedicated funds that are administered
by the Department of Health and Human
Services there is a joint legislative
committee on dedicated funds they've
been in existence since around 2014
2015 and on a fiveyear basis every
agency has to go through a rotation to
justify their various um dedicated funds
one of the things that will be important
to understanding all these nine sections
is that there are two parts that are
essential for a dedicated fund one is
you have to have a fund in the enabling
legislation with the uh with the agency
so and in addition to that you have to
have a corresponding fund with the
Department of Treasury so I'm just going
to repeat that again for clarity that
you have to have two pieces of
legislation for every fund one within
the enabling legislation for uh the
agency and program area and then a
corresponding fund within the treasury
account and those funds in the treasury
account are found under RSA 6 col 12 so
in section one of the bill where you see
application for receipts this is
essentially creating the treasury
account necessary for the um for the uh
funds that are identified uh on line
three and as you see in the lines the
bolditalic is the new sections uh that
are requiring this the first one under
32b that involved a recently passed uh
legislation that was not requested by
the department but certainly one that
the legislature passed and that was
involving the special marriage efficient
license so again that's a special
marriage efficient license and
respectively the underlying Bill uh
failed to have the linkage with the
second required account within the
treasury Department and therefore we're
bringing a technical cleanup uh so that
it actually has a place for the treasury
to receive that those funds the next one
is from legislation from
2015 uh that involved what they call the
Joshua law it's embedded in the uh
criminal code of New Hampshire and it
involves violation prote protective
orders and that a portion of those fees
collected as a result of that uh have a
place to be deposited again we're not
creating the fund but we're just trying
to find a a home for it within the um
within the uh treasury statutes and so
you'll see uh eventually at the very end
on line four it makes reference to the
existing fund that is actually when we
get to I believe a later well it will be
in a later section of this bill you'll
see that we made a corresponding change
to link up those funds uh that you find
within the 173b which are the domestic
violence Coalition funds that are
administered by our agency and provided
to the
Coalition so in in in section two of the
bill uh you'll see also the exact same
thing happening except for this these
are funds that are housed within our
division of Public Health Services we
have our radiological Health that are
identified in RSA
125f and then we have our shellfish uh
such things as glams and other shellfish
uh that are identified in 143 22A and
then we have a corresponding piece that
comes back to our food Protection
Services licensure so again they're just
linking up all these funds and fees that
are being collected into a specific
dedicated account those funds exist this
is just creating the treasury account to
go along with it so moving along to
section three of the bill uh and section
four these relate to um human resource
items within the department section
three is building on the progress that
our agency has made over the last four
years to identify uh unclassified
positions within the department to make
sure that our working in legal titles
align believe it or not at one time we
had a uh a Information Systems director
who was identified in statute as as a
dentist and so we needed to clean up so
that the titles within our agencies
align with the actual people and the
work that they do so in this occasion uh
we're seeking an amendment uh to the
specific uh uh unclassified position in
the GD grade uh for a Medicaid uh
Enterprise development uh uh and that
staff would work directly with Henry
Litman within his
agency section four of the bill uh deals
with compensation of certain officers
also under uh the same statute that
deals with unclassified positions and it
is the vision of uh commissioner shanet
to take away the specific uh qualifiers
for the existing Commissioners uh so
that you'll see that we would be moving
from uh the three associate
Commissioners that we have within the
department we would take away the
qualifiers at the end because uh the
goals here are for greater efficiency in
government to allow uh the commissioner
or any commissioner to be able to align
nimbly uh those particular associate
Commissioners were were needed and to
make those adjustments very clearly and
so the descriptors that were added
within the last five years somewhat
limit and hamper the Department's
efforts to have flexibility to address
those needed resources as directed by
the commissioner so on line 15 you'll
see that we strike the extender and it
carries on to line 16 of Human Services
and variable Health that leaves us with
the uh associate commissioner position
the second of three associate
commissioner positions was of operations
we're striking that and then you'll see
on lines 19 the Department of Health and
services commissioner for population
Health striking that now there was
scribers error already in existing law
that they had provided for an additional
two Commissioners uh positions within
our agency so we need to clean up and
make sure that it it reflects accurately
the three associate commissioner
positions within our agency and
therefore striking um the uh scrier
errors for a fourth and a fifth
associate commissioner position within
the agency found on lines 21 through uh
24 so Mr chair with your permission if I
could bring in attorney uh Melissa St
seir who's our chief legal officer for
the department and she has prepared to
provide commentary on Section Five of
the
Bill thank you John good afternoon Mr
chair members of the committee for the
record my name is Melissa Saint Seer I'm
the chief legal officer for the
Department of Health and Human Services
as for section five uh the department
had um asked for legislation to maintain
or obtain parody for mental health and
physical health in in our hospitals in
New
Hampshire and the original language just
re re ired that both physical and
behavioral health be considered um and
offered in emergenc when when somebody
arrives at the emergency room and uh
Senator Bradley and working with other
stakeholders um changed the we we
changed the language to allow for the
parties to get together the hospitals
the department to get together and uh
make recommendations for future
legislation to help help obtain that
parity that mental health
parity thank you
and Miss Dyer advancing to section six
of the bill this these this section and
two other related sections uh identify a
needed a much needed position within the
the agency that's already in in
existence which is a bureau chief um uh
that would be um with emergency
preparedness and response within the
department and and so what this section
six does and then two other related
sections to the bill is to allow the
department to get the best qualified
candidate and when I say that uh in
terms of the recruitment process we may
be looking for individuals who are
either in emergency services under the
department of safety or law enforcement
and currently they're under the group
two State retirement so this would allow
the department to hire an individual
who's currently in group two and to
bring them in and for them for that
particular candidate if they were to be
successful and employed to maintain
their group to employment which is
really critical because there would be a
disincentive if they were to come into
our agency and lose their group two only
to have to go for uh with the group one
um um uh retirement system it also
allows also and not to the exclusion of
uh other candidates but it allows the
department to look very uh clearly at
who's most qualified to fill that
position and whether they come in uh new
to the department and come in as a group
one or we find somebody who has EXP
experience uh under the department of
safety under group two this allows the
department to hire that person who has
the best qualifications to fill that
position without any inherent uh
disincentives for applicants or
candidates to seek those positions
within the
department moving to section seven of
the bill uh we have radiological health
programs we saw earlier in section one
of the bill that um this is the the
corresponding section that deals with
the dedicated non-aps accounts as it
relates to rad radiological help uh
section eight of the bill involves the
offices of Ombudsman and many of you are
aware that within our agency we actually
have two different udsm we have a
general Ombudsman who represents the
public clients and and works on their
behalf to resolve specific issues that
they may be having with the department
and in addition to that we also have
which is not affected by this section
our um budsman for long-term uh uh care
services and they're called Alito the
office of long-term care um budsman and
they look at issues as it relates to
complaints uh that may be received
regarding the treatment of loved ones
and Care in the nursing facility setting
but again this one deals with
specifically those uh involving uh
customers clients of the department and
we wanted to make sure that the statute
uh clearly identified that the primary
and singular goal of the Ombudsman is to
uh represent those interest uh under
under current law however it also uh
includes the uh word employees which
causes some confusion because there's
already existing process either through
the uh Human Resources through the
division of personnel through um uh
admin services for a process for the
fair treatment and and and regular help
of and support for our employees
including also our employee assistance
program otherwise known as EAP uh for
the support so this is a cleanup to
clarify the role of the Ombudsman to
representing clients within our agencies
the next section section nine is a
grouping of another project we had
discussed earlier a project within our
agency to uh clean up our dedicated
funds to align the funds with the
treasury accounts there is also h a uh
there is also an exercise going forward
within the department to identify uh all
the Department's reporting requirements
including those reporting requirements
that are either uh duplicative of our
our our works they're outdated or
they're redundant and so we had brought
before this committee a series of U of
uh requests for repealing some of the
outdated um uh reporting requirements
that are out there and this includes one
of them in section nine of the
bill section
10 of the bill uh includes the status
and the retirement account and again
this is a corresponding piece of we
spoke of earlier regarding the group two
as it relates to the bureau chief for
emergency preparedness uh uh within the
department uh section 11 uh that is a
repeal of the housing security guarantee
program and we already in have a process
for funding these programs in a
completely different Source that's been
very efficient very effective and
therefore we're requesting uh the repeal
of those sections that are not utilized
by the department and included with that
is the corresponding dedicated funds
within the treasury statute at this time
uh Mr chair if I could ask that uh Mr
Michael Holt with our division of Public
Health Services therapeutic cannabis
manager if he could now walk the
committee through the sections that
involve the therapeutic cannabis program
and also to address the question that
was raised by represent Marsh relative
to sections 12 and 13 and I just would
like to say we look forward to working
with you represent Marsh uh and the
committee on any amendments as they may
be related to those sections
particularly if you believe there's
unintended consequence as currently
written so Mr
H Mr Holt uh yes thank you very much um
my name is Michael Holt I'm representing
Health and Human Services I'm the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program this is Department
requested legislation so obviously the
department supports this bill so uh as
introductory remarks I'll keep them
brief but this bill would make a number
of changes to the therapeutic cannabis
law most of these changes were proposed
in the last legislative session and were
passed by the full Senate both last year
and this year these changes in large
part are in direct response to a per
performance audit of the therapeutic
cannabis program conducted by the LBA in
2019 the LBA recommended that the
department reduce burden for patients
and caregivers streamline and simplify
administrative processes for applying to
the program and seek legislation where
necessary to achieve these goals this
legislation is in direct response to the
LBA audit
recommendations to that end many of the
changes proposed in this bill are
technical in nature and I don't plan to
go through each minor technical change
unless there's a question uh but there
are some policy proposals included which
support the LBA audit findings and the
Department's response to that
audit um now if we go in order of what's
on the screen now um we go to a non LBA
audit related uh matter and this is uh
sections 12 and
13 which
um this is a technical change to better
align and remove conflicts between two
chapters of state law this is a new
proposal this year uh which Builds on
work from previous sessions related to
youth access to tobacco products called
tobacco 21 so this bill would create an
exception within RSA
126k the youth access to and use of
tobacco products law relative to the use
of therapeutic cannabis it establishes
that the youth tobacco law does not
apply to registered patients and
caregivers of the therapeutic cannabis
program nor would it apply to the
state's licensed alternative treatment
centers and this is important with
respect to the therapeutic use of
cannabis this chapter wide exception is
necessary because the therapeutic
cannabis law allows people under 21
years of age to be patients within the
program and because the atc's dispense
products and accessories that overlap
with products that are regulated by the
youth tobacco law so in response to
representative Marsha's concern here the
phrase onlines
2021 with respect to the therapeutic use
of cannabis are critical to address his
con concerns that this language in no
way would exempt people under
21 uh from the balance of the tobacco
law it would maintain the prohibition
for this population against the purchase
and use of tobacco products regulated by
126x and so again that line 20 to 21
it's an exemption with respect to the
therapeutic use of cannabis the New
Hampshire atcs do not sell cigarettes
and a person within who's under 21
cannot show their registry ID card at a
convenience store and buy tobacco
products if this language is found to be
unclear or not sufficient I'd be happy
to work with representative Marsh on
clear language but in no way is this
intended to exempt the under 21
population uh from the uh the the the
tobacco
law so moving on um there are a c a few
more policy proposals here um one policy
proposal would allow medical providers
to certify their patients for the
therapeutic cannabis program for up to
three years at a time the current
duration of a provider's written
certification is one year this bill
would not mandate a three-year
certification rather it would allow
providers the medical discretion
necessary to issue longer duration
certifications when appropriate note
that providers already have the
authority to issue shorter duration
certifications of say six months and
they have the authority to resend a
certification at any
time uh the next policy proposal in the
bill would increase the patient increase
patient access to the state's
alternative treatment centers there are
a number of references throughout this
bill uh that are impacted by this policy
change currently there are only seven
ATC dispensary locations in the entire
State and patients are restricted to
accessing only one ATC at a time this
legislation would allow New Hampshire
patients to access all the ATC
dispensary locations in the state at any
time the last policy proposal I'd like
to mention again not audit related but
would allow authorized employees of the
department to possess and transport
therapeutic cannabis for inspection
investigation and Regulatory Compliance
purposes currently Department staff are
not permitted to conduct these
activities on cannabis products without
the regulated entity the atc's
maintaining control of the products
being inspected this bill would allow
authorized Department staff to identify
cannabis products at the dispensary or
at the cultivation facility for quality
control purposes and IL legally
transport those products to a testing
laboratory in the
state and that concludes my prepared
testimony happy to answer questions
after the full presentation is
over and Mr chair um that brings us to
page seven uh on line 27 to section
33 and I just would ask Miss Dyer if if
director Henry Lipman is with us at the
present time he was doing a briefing
before Senate Finance on for the
division for Medicaid services and if he
has concluded that he's going to jump on
the call with us right now to discuss
the um section 33 of the
bill he's with us able to
speak um good afternoon um Henry Litman
Medicaid director I'm hoping you can
hear me okay
yes um the provision um in um Senate
Bill 162 is identical to the provision
that was passed by the house in um HB uh
2 um the purpose of this uh provision is
to support the compliance with RSA
16764 which was the um agreement between
the state and the hospitals with respect
to um uh compensation for uncompensated
care back in 20 2018 when this um was
adopted it was expected that the um way
in which the state uh would pay
hospitals may need to evolve over time
and what this um provision allows is for
um Medicaid enhancement tax to the
extent it's um already used to pay
providers would be allowed under the
granted Advantage Program for purposes
of complying with the settlement um
agree between the hospitals and the the
state and um as um you know codified in
this uh statute RSA
16764 um again I think I just highlight
that um it is an hb2 um identical as it
is into Senate Bill 162 I'd be happy to
take questions here if there are
any
yeah
I don't see any hands up I appreciate uh
you continuing to support this as it's
very important for our our compliance
and commitment uh with the hospitals
thank
you and Mr shair I may proceed um uh
with Section
34 please proceed thank you so section
34 is is uh related to section 65 and a
couple of other sections so when we get
to that uh regarding the administration
of epinephrine we will cover this in
more detail but essentially this is
repealing within the Department of
Health and services this particular
Authority that's being transferred uh
proposed to be transferred to the office
of professional licensure and
certification and we'll get into more
detail when we get to section 65 uh the
next section dealing with the
communicable uh disease mosquito control
fund if uh Miss D if we can go to lines
five and six you'll see that it relates
to certain funds uh that were to be
deposited not lapsed uh back on June
30th of 2009 since we're doing a
thoughtful cleanup of all the other
funds we just figured this would be a
good thing to add to the list as well uh
where it's outdated and it's already
passed uh the next section deals with
the uh shellfish uh we had already
discussed in section two of the bill uh
the um funds and this is the
corresponding fund uh within the um
actual enabling legislation under uh
under the food protection uh Services uh
we do have members from our food
Protection Services with us in case
there's questions around any of these
items uh but you'll see also section 37
also relates to the same uh dedicated
fund as well as sections
38 so miss Dyer if we can scroll up
please uh section 39 uh nursing home
administrator uh patient account this
starts approximately three or four
sections of the bill that deal with our
uh legal and Regulatory Services Under
under our estate Recovery Unit the
estate recovery Union unit is um
supervised by an attorney and
essentially what their job is is to to
make sure to ensure that taxpayer
dollars are are recovered appropriately
and what I'm referring to is where in
cases where individuals uh receive
medical assistance um including
Long-Term Care nursing facilities that
um there is a an obligation obviously if
there are assets out there uh for the
Department to recover including placing
leans on properties to collect for those
uh expenditures and so all this does is
it changes the jurisdictional
jurisdictional amount from $5,000 to
$10,000 on those um Estates that are are
uh have a very little amount with within
the estate so you'll see that change
throughout uh and when we come to them
we'll stop pause but we have them as it
relates to the nurse and home
administrators the guardian staff
statutes and and another statute uh that
we'll get to uh we did um have a
conversation you know with with the with
the uh bar community and certainly uh
the um working with them they are uh
appreciative and understanding of the
goals that we're trying to reach and um
and uh and so thank you so moving along
to section 40 of the bill that just
deals with the effective date so that
when the courts are making orders that
it's very clear as to when that
particular moment takes place that the
new provision of the $5,000 to $10,000
takes place it's a very thoughtful
approach in terms of a very clear
effective date uh the next one involved
the cleanup of unnecessary reports uh as
part of RSA 151e as it relates to
utilization of uh non- nursing home
services so that's addressed by other
reports that the department already does
the perspectives uh under section 42
Protective Service adults and reports to
adult uh abuse this is a bill that we
brought last session that that was
tabled but was in it was postured for
passage and what it relates to is the
department uh within our Bureau of elen
Adult Services has a unit that protects
um adults so it's called the adult
protection uh Services uh function of
our agency so if there are complaints
about a vulnerable adult whether aged
disabled we investigate um those upon uh
a receipt of uh uh information that we
need to conduct an investigation under
current law however it's currently
drafted that the individual who's the
vulnerable adult has to be alive at the
time that the report is being
investigated and unfortunately there was
a set of circumstances where an
individual who is charged with an adult
who uh had Dementia or some related
disorder uh had a requirement to watch
that person at their residence in
community based care uh every 30 minutes
unfortunately uh um and the allegations
are that that time period was not
adhered to and on a hot summer day
unfortunately that adult uh who
vulnerable adult uh got into their
vehicle and and expired due due to heat
So based upon the fact that that
individual died there was a barrier to
adding that person's name upon an
investigation and a finding of abuse of
neglect to our registry so that that
person could in fact seek employment in
a longterm Care Facility or in a
community based um um uh with without
being caught on on the registry so this
was an important um consideration and a
very important piece that uh was tabled
last session and we're happy to see it
in this bill right here uh sections 43
are also outdated um reporting
requirements as you'll see uh from
sections one through four one of those
sections actually relates to a following
section that we're going to discuss in
in a moment which is RS a 165 colon 20c
and when we uh get to that section we'll
talk about it which is is coming up uh
very soon um so section 44 a to assisted
person's expenses uh to amend RSA
1602 um a that's a cross reference to
removing the repealed 16520 C so that's
just a um OSS catch on where it needs to
be caught in other statutes the public
assistance Financial Disclosure by
applicants re uh and recipients under
RSA
167 four lowercase a Roman six uh also
uh addresses that same issue as it
relates to that um issue so if we can
scroll down Miss Dyer so I can get to
the appropriate section oh right so this
this section here in the very bottom uh
is striking out a reporting requirement
that is since passed and no longer so
this is part of our our cleanup on a
reporting requirement departments so Mr
chair we've now reached on page 10 line
16 section 46 as it relates to the child
protection act and with your with your
okay uh we'd like I'd like you to
recognize uh attorney Rebecca Ross who's
our general counsel and legislative lays
on for our agency's division for
children youth and families and she can
take you through this section as well as
the following sections that actually
make up the bulk of the bill as it
relates to the interstate compact the
attorney is so recognized thank you Mr
chair and members of the committee for
the record my name is Rebecca Ross I'm
general counsel and legislative liaison
for the division for children youth and
families um section 46 investigative
interviews addresses a narrow but
critical Gap in the child protection
system by allowing courts to expressly
have the authority to order an
investigative interview or examination
of a child um in order to complete an
investigation of abuse or neglect um it
is always the division's position that
we work with families um and work
cooperatively with them even when we're
investigating but in the rare instance
that we are unable to get access to a
child we need the court to have the
ability to order an evaluation of that
child um right now the law as written
allows us to access the home with a
court order but it does not actually
allow um an order to speak with or
examine a child and this is critically
important for small children who may not
be in school or daycare full-time if
they are within a home that we are
unable to access and unable to have them
evaluated we cannot complete our
investigations so we believe this would
be used rarely but in critical cases the
next section is um section 47 and this
was is made at the request of another
Bureau of the department it amends the
dcyf central registry which is our
registry of findings of abuse and
neglect um this would allow employers
who are providing services to the
developmentally disabled population to
check to ensure that their employees who
are providing services to a vulnerable
population do not have a prior finding
of abuse or neglect um on a child
the next section is section
48 is the interstate compact for the
placement of children and as Senator
Bradley said this is not a new law this
is seeking to adopt the an updated
version of the law that will not become
effective until 37 or 35 states have
adopted it so far there are about a
dozen that have adopted including the
neighboring state of Maine um there are
a couple key reasons why this is
important to New Hampshire it will the
last time this was amended was 1995 so
it is it is definitely out of date and
in need of updating um it will be
particularly helpful in addressing the
accountability between states so that
when we have um a child who we're
looking to place in another state
potentially with a relative or vice
versa someone wants to place a while
here with a relative through our system
it establishes better cooperation
collaboration and communication
including electronic communication that
is not currently permitted um so that we
have more timely information if we ask
another state to provide us with that
information and we're held accountable
to the other states who are seeking our
assistance so um we are looking to be
one of the proactive states to adopt
that but again it would not be effective
and until 35 states have adopted it um
and John I believe that's the end of my
sections until section
55 and attorney Ross thank you very much
and Mr chair proceeding along that takes
us to page
28 uh down to uh line uh 15 which is
section 51 involving our child daycare
licensing and I would ask attorney St SE
if she's still on if she can walk the
committee through that section uh of the
bill
what page yes may the attorney proceed
this is page 28 line 15
following that is
correct the attorney May
proceed thank you again uh for the
record again Melissa Saints here um so
as for this change in section 51
childcare licensing currently licenses
school age programs which are basically
child daycare agencies that are provided
uh for schoolage children and currently
our statute has restrictions on um age
and so we have asked that those um those
restrictions be changed to four years
and8 months of age or older so that
those children who are entering into
kindergarten can seek out a child or
school age program and become become
enrolled in a school age program prior
to them entering kindergarten so that
that is what this Chang is seeking to do
thank
you and Mr chair that takes us also to
related to our child care licensing to
section 53 of the bill and this involves
the um accessibility or availability of
the um an EpiPen uh as well as an
inhaler you'll see in the following
section and I just wanted to to
recognize the good works done by uh Miss
Melissa Clement within our agency who's
our child care uh licensing um uh person
who oversees that unit and she along
with her supervisor Dorene Shockley
worked very positively with the camp
Community along with Henry Vu who
represented uh one of the key
stakeholders to come with an
accommodation so we appreciate that and
so what this essentially says is that
those items whether an epen or an
inhaler need to be readily accessible to
to the camp uh so that uh from a
obviously from a public health Public
Safety standpoint that they have their
needed inhalers and EpiPen
um that takes us to section 55 of the
bill on page 29 line 10 again that is
section 55 and I invite attorney Ross uh
to um review this section with the
committee
Ross thank you again um this peer
support section is codifying the
confidentiality requirements for the
peer support program that DCF has
developed to support and maintain uh
healthy work work force um as many of
you know over the last few years we've
been trying to to grow that Workforce
and decrease um the training folks and
having them leave shortly after they're
they're up and running um this portion
of the bill mirrors the provision that
is available for First Responders who
are exposed to um crisis and Trauma in
their jobs and we feel that this is
important support for our staff who are
working with families day in and day out
and we'd ask that you provide them with
the same um confidentiality so that they
can seek the help that they need when
they're exposed to situations through
the course of their job and I'm happy to
answer any questions about this
section and Mr chair if there's no
questions at that point if I could have
attorney Ross also continue on page 30
uh starting at line 31 this is section
56 of the bill again page 30 line 31
section 56 of the bill and it deals with
Contracting or procurement for services
through our division for children youth
and
families yes please
continue thank you um this
section codifies the work that we're
doing moving toward
um contracted residential providers
rather than vendored service providers
and will allow us to tailor the um the
the contracts and the services to meet
the specific needs of the population
that we're seeing and um move away from
more of the one- siiz fits-all it's
consistent with the work that's being
done with system of care and the other
system redesign and it's it's purely
codifying that we're moving toward that
that Contracting
model and Mr chair that would then take
us to page 31 line three section 57 of
the bill and with attorney Ros still on
this this is part of the cleaning up of
either outdated redundant or unnecessary
reports and this one relates to
informational materials relating to
missing children so I would just invite
attorney Ross if she had any commentary
uh in support of why that language is no
longer needed or the
report yes
thank you other than it was um a very
old statutory requirement and has
essentially been replaced with the work
that we're doing with our human
trafficking position and some of the
other more upto-date reporting that
we're doing we don't we don't believe
it's a necessary reporting requirement
and there's um other information that is
more readily available and and more
useful at this
time Mr chair that will take us to
sections 58 through 60 which all relate
to each other around developmental
services and we have attorney Melissa St
Seer with us you may recall your
committee had a retain bill that you
worked on considerably so pieces of this
actually relate somewhat back to the
good works that you folks did uh within
the last uh couple of sessions as it
relates to uh gaps in Services
particularly for children uh between the
ages of 18 and 21 uh and and needing
these particular services so um I would
turn over at at your direction Mr chair
to attorney St sier at this
time attorney St sier thank you so
much the sections 58 through 60 relate
to RC 171a which is our funding uh
mechanisms for our developmental
disabilities and acquire brain disorder
uh services that are provided by the
department there are uh sections 58 and
60 are clean up up uh section
59 was a uh the department had
identified that there was a gap in
funding for those aged 18 to 21 there
were certain services such as housing
that were not included in in the funding
um as I as as written as the current
statute is written and therefore we had
requested that the funding for those
individuals for that age group for 18 to
21 be uh included in in this change The
Advocates uh other stakeholders have uh
have some concerns around those so this
language was changed that individuals
from area agencies the Department of
Education the DRC and others would as
well as the department obviously would
get together um and discuss the uh aged
18 to 21 the in and um come up with
potential language for future
legislation um uh and and resolution and
so that's what section 59 does thank
you and Mr chair if there's no questions
for attorney Saints here at this time uh
that takes us to uh line 26 on the same
page page 31 which is um section 61 you
may recall this relates back to section
one of the bill on the dedicated funds
cleanup this is the housing of the
language within the the um uh enabling
legislation for the fund for the
domestic violence Grant so this is just
the reciprocal cross reference to that
those funds section 62 is the grant
Workforce program and uh and represent
Weber uh acknowledged from the
questioning that she had with Senator
Bradley that it does in fact what it
says it does here relative to uh no
requirement if there's no funding and
it's only about the grant Workforce
program not uh the enhanced Medicaid uh
whatsoever so uh that then if there's no
questions takes us to uh page 32 line 18
section 63 of the bill relative to
health facilities lure and uh and so
what this section does um on Section 63
is it cleans up a a rare and I'll repeat
that a rare scribers error by the office
of legislative services that last
session they passed legislation to um
better identify the um appeal process
and the standards that the department
utilizes around special Healthcare lure
and so the problem with the bill as it
was enacted that the uh effective date
for repealing the old manner for the
review happens on July 1st of 2021 and
the new standard to be applied was
effective on July 1st of 20120 so we
just need to align that the old way of
doing things needed to end at the same
time uh contemporaneous with the new way
of approaching the lure we do have
attorney uh St Seer who worked very very
closely on this legislation and I would
invite her uh to add any commentary
because I gave you the very high level
what we're trying to do here relative to
an effective date that just need to be
changed attorney
sing uh I don't I I don't know if I have
much more to add I um the you know just
having the two the two Provisions in in
contradiction of each other they they
can't both stand both of those
Provisions can't stand um together and
and actually make sense and and can't be
executed so this this cleans that up um
and so I think that's that's all we need
to tell you but I'm certainly happy to
answer any
questions so um chair chairman the the
next um section is on line 22 and it
relates to section uh 64 under milk
sanitation I do have if there are
questions for the committee uh Miss
Colleen Smith who is just incredible
person who works in our food Protection
Services if there are questions but
essentially we just need to qu clarify
the term of wash stations as it relates
to uh you know the sanitation of milk
trucks that transport uh milk and that
also relates to uh section 65 of the
bill and this gets back to our
conversation that we had on dedicated
funds so this is just one of those items
part of the dedicated funds cleanup as
it relates to the following section
section 66 and that now Tak us to um
page that takes us to page 34 line 27
again that's page 34 uh line 27 as it
relates to section 67 Guardians and
conservators this is the corresponding
change to the jurisdictional amount for
uh Estates that are uh minimal Estates
from $5,000 to
$10,000 uh for that particular threshold
and then that takes us uh to page um 35
uh section 68 uh dealing with the
achievement statutes under unclaimed
property and abandoned property also the
same jurisdictional change from $5,000
to $10,000 throughout section 669 is the
applicability on the effective date so
that it's upon when the Court's looking
at it it's upon when those affidavit or
claims are filed um and that takes us to
section 70 relative to Retirement System
and this is the third and final piece as
it relates to recruitment of qualified
positions for our bureau chief for
emergency preparedness in response and
allowing those that are in group two uh
specifically to be able to apply for
those jobs without um losing their their
group two membership uh that now takes
us to the Department of Health and
services uh plan for uh
legislation uh and uh and so this final
section here was an accommodation
working with senator Bradley and Senator
Rosenwald as it related to Case
Management Services and like earlier
items working along with the hospital
Association as it relates to emergency
services this section allows us to work
with uh the provider community and
agencies around case management and to
report on November 1st of 2021 with
ideas I do think I inadvertently did
skip over one section that dealt with
the uh the a transfer from our agency to
the department uh rather the office of
professional licensure certification as
it relates to training for the
administration of epinephrine and uh as
most of you are aware there are three
different settings that are set up in
current statute for the administration
of um epinephrine and the first setting
is related through K through 12 schools
uh and then there's a whole section uh
that deals with postsecondary so at
universities what needs to be done
relative to the training and
administration of epinephrine or epipens
and there's a third that is a
non-academic uh setting such as
Appalachian Mountain Club Lodge or or
other uh settings uh that uh may need
the use of an epinephrine uh or EpiPen
that currently was housed within our
agency the prior to that I discussed we
certainly provide information were
resource but they were administered by a
different state agency uh the department
of Ed um for for the most part as it
related to the educational settings this
one however uh had our agency tagged
with being the ones who have to
administer the training for this program
and a very collaborative discussion we
had with the office of professional Li
Insurance certification they recognized
and agreed that it was better suited
with them under the Board of Medicine to
provide direction for training for the
use uh of epinephrine pens by uh
physicians in those non um
non-educational settings so it was a
great um exchange we worked along uh
with uh attorney uh uh um Lindsay
Courtney uh who is the uh executive
director for oplc I I would invite uh
attorney Melissa Saint Seer uh if she
had any other thoughts because she had
worked along with others in the
department around that
section I I don't have any additional
thoughts thank you John well Mr chair um
it did we did take us a little bit
longer and I think we probably did even
a more thoughtful job with your
committee on the initial walkthrough uh
but we were able to do this uh time
check here within one hour of over 26 to
34 different legislative initiatives so
at this time if there are questions from
the committee either I or others are
certainly available to feeli them uh as
as as needed thank
you see a hand up I don't know who it is
Shapiro representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Williams for that
extraordinary detailed presentation I
have two questions um on page one um
number
five
um you mentioned parity between mental
health and physical health services and
emergency um rooms is this is this
another attempt to deal with the
emergency room boarding
crisis and Mr chair in in response to
represent Shapiro's question if we could
recognize attorney Melissa
uh on that question from represent
Shapiro attorne s thank you represent
Shapiro for your question the
Department's goal in this is uh in this
legislation was
to allow for mental health parody in our
hospitals when somebody arrives at the
emergency room to receive Services
whether it is a mental health or a
physical health that they receive the
same care attention and level of care
that they would they would no matter whe
whether it is physical or mental health
so that is that is the whole reason
behind the legislation if it is if it
assists with the ER boarding crisis um
wonderful but but it really is to ensure
parity follow
up first I would say if it if there
really if parody is created that would
certainly be um a help because right now
A lot of people are getting very limited
or no U Mental Health Services in the
emergency room I'd like to move on to um
page
um the section about um I guess it would
be
62 on actually starts on 31 the section
about um work in community engagement
program with expanded Medicaid and I am
just curious why it is written the way
it is written um to say if the work in
community engagement waiver is held that
invalid when my understanding is that it
already has been revoked by the current
Administration and Mr chair if I may
respond to represent Shapiro's
question is is absolutely correct around
that we just need to make sure that we
clarify that within the context
of the proposed legislation and and
certainly is a timing issue we put
together this legislative proposal back
in the fall so that is some of the
factors that are involved uh we also I
conc certainly have director Chris Sello
who is at um um at um a telephone ready
standpoint if you need additional
information beyond that and certainly
could have her discuss with you offline
uh those services that are in fact still
being provided uh through the uh
Department of Employment Security to
support uh those individuals
thank you and representative
rber you're on mute
repres sorry about that uh now I have
questions raised by the answer to
representative Shapiro
because I'm not understanding Mr
Williams what you meant when you said
there are
still
supports I I guess my brain has bounced
with respect to this provision because
I'm wondering what supports the granite
Workforce program is
currently
providing because I thought it that what
we were talking about was the um
the work
requirement so there are there are
supports in addition to the work
requirement that are provided through
this program and they would also be
suspended I I'm
really provision yeah we we do have
director Litman who is at the ready to
address uh represent Weber's
question and then just Mr chair I do
have my original question on beyond
that hopefully um this is Henry Litman
Medicaid director hopefully I can
clarify here I think connected to
representative Shapiro's original
question connecting to representative
Weber's question I I think that issue
here is that um CMS has withdrawn the
waiver with respect to the community
engagement requirement um there is
however still a Supreme Court case
that's in um that has not been dispos of
it's technically held in a bance um it's
it's in all likelihood um you know not
going to potentially be heard but it's
still an open case at the Supreme Court
level is kind of where the community
engagement stands um CMS has revoked the
the 1115 waiver for Community engagement
and the states where it had granted
[Music]
it Mr chair this is Melissa ster I can
also I can also follow up a little bit
more to that if if if you would like yes
great thank you so
much uh currently the way that the
statute is written the granite Workforce
program is a piece of the work and
Community engagement that was created um
although the working Community
engagement has been withdrawn the
approval for the wer waiver has been
withdrawn the way that the statute is
written it that doesn't subsequently
also withdraw the granite Workforce
program they're linked but our statute
doesn't didn't link them enough enough
to allow for if the community work
requirement if the community engagement
went away that the work Grant Workforce
program also would so so we're trying to
make that link because they are they are
in fact linked but the statute didn't
didn't quite make that link in addition
the um New Hampshire employment security
does have a role in some of the items
that the granite Workforce program
initially
uh was created for and we've been
working very closely with New Hampshire
employment security to conduct some of
those activities although the granite
Workforce program is going going away
because of the fact that the grant the
community engagement requirements are
going away New Hampshire employment
security does continue to do some of the
things that was uh conceptualized for
the grant at work force program hope
that
helps thank you and then Mr chair may I
revert to my original question you may
thank you on a completely different
subject to return to the group to the
the folks who upon moving to
administrative position can keep their
group to Retirement Systems which I
recall dealing with again and again
every single time a new person was hired
through Ed normally through
Edna um how many positions are we
talking about there was one I saw the
reference to Homeland Security but are
there other positions that these
Provisions would uh apply to and how
many positions total would it apply
to and Mr chair I I this is John
Williams I can respond to Rend Weber's
question and so it actually only relates
to one position that we're seeking
Recruitment and the title for that
position as you'll see in the first
section section that I'm trying to catch
up very quickly uh to where it's located
deals with a bureau chief essentially
for emergency preparedness uh within the
division for p uh division for public
health services so it is only one
position however because the recruitment
could come from the um Department of
Safety from a Emergency Management
person from that entity there's a
specific provision in RSA 100 that
relates specifically to what they call
Firefighters for one a better word
there's another section also in section
100 that relates to law enforcement and
and police and so that section also
needed to be uh amended so that it would
allow for the Recruitment and Retention
of group two if they came from either
one of those two um uh
areas and then and then that I'm sorry
that completes my
answer thank you so the maximum
uh exposure to the concerns which might
be expressed on behalf of the retirement
system um goes only to one specific
position no matter how many different
places you have to put in the statute
depending on where they're coming from
is that right that is correct okay thank
you any further
[Music]
questions
wow thank you chairman um I'm not quite
sure who would handle this um I was very
interested in the interstate compact for
the placement of children since it is a
a rather large section of this Omnibus
Bill
um just for some background information
who developed this and um how many
states are already in it who who sets
the um standards
for uh the home visits and placements
and all of
that and Mr chair if we could invite
attorney Rebecca Ross to come in and to
respond to those questions but as
Senator Bradley said in his overview of
some of the key sections that there
already is existing law that it relates
to the compact with this does is it
upate it updates the the current law
that has not been updated in some time
so it's not creating a new law out there
and it also requires that a certain
number of states have to sign on and
ratify this for it to be to be effective
but I think attorney Ross is in a much
better position to provide a level of
detail to representative fom's uh very
good
question good afternoon thank you John
um thank you representative for for the
question this um is drafted by a group
that all of the states belong to um it
is as John said updating um the current
version that we adopted into law in
1985 um it provides for the adoption of
regulations once the requisite 35 states
have adopted so the states that have
joined will work together to come up
with um the regulations to implement the
act so we don't have those yet but we
would be a participating state in
developing the specific regulations for
the different parts of the program we
would still be um like we are now using
our own foster care and adoption home
study rules and doing things in New
Hampshire way other states would still
be using their process and it sets the
the minimum standards and the
obligations that are required um when
working with the other states I hope
that answers your
question thank you um when the 37 States
sign on first of all it's been since
1985 so that's quite a few years and
we're not at 37 States yet um is there
um a hope to when that might happen and
then also with that is once it does
reach 37 states does it become a
federal um program at that
point um it doesn't become a federal
program at that point it's still
something that we as New Hampshire
choose to be part of um but so since
1985 we've had a version of the
interstate compact for the placement of
children on the books this proposed
draft has not been um in the work since
1985 this is more recent although um I
don't have it in front of me it has been
a number of years it stalled and there
was um increased enthusiasm over the
last couple years through the National
Organization to to bring it back and
work toward the electronic Communication
System right now we do things by facts
it's very slow a lot of things go back
and forth by mail there are undue delays
because we don't have a system in place
to be able to communicate essentially in
real time we also don't have um the
current compact doesn't have any
enforcable deadlines for other states so
we could have a a child in New Hampshire
with relatives that are in the best
position to take care of that child in
another state and um we are are at their
whim as to when they complete that home
study and get back to us this will will
correct that and include um penalties
for not cooperating and and working with
States in a timely manner to get that
permanency for
children representative gay thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question and clarifying this um so I'll
say some things and then you tell me
whether I have this right or not
currently we do have compacts maybe not
called the compact that way but we do
have arrangements with other states for
transferring children to other places
where they'd be better they have
somebody to care for them but we don't
have anything to hurry them up if
they're if they have a long delay that's
acceptable in their state we're stuck
with that
so I'm going to guess so that's question
one the other question is this sounds
like if we're talking about 37 States
this sounds like a federally proposed
program that just never has gotten the
the 37 states to sign on which which
seems to me a little strange since it
would benefit people I don't understand
why it requires all 37 before you can
initiate the program so is that indeed a
federal program and we're stuck with the
requirements
no it right now we have RSA
170a which is our current version of the
interstate compact on the placement of
children so we we do have one in place
and absolutely that's what we operate
under um and that that's what all of the
states are operating under right now
there's been a proposal through the
states that are the are are members of
this organization to update that and
that's what this is so the decision was
made that they we essentially need
two-thirds of the states to decide to
move forward with the new program and
and that's what we're in the process of
right now is each state working with
their own legislature to ratify these
changes and as soon as there's
essentially 2third then that would be
operationalized until then there's not
sufficient buyin for the state to update
the process so that that's very common
with these interstate compacts and and
how they're developed and and
operationalized and so um it doesn't it
doesn't make it a federal program it
does bring us into um compliance with
how we we work with the feds for placing
kids out of state but we are not out of
compliance by operating on the old
agreement either and this is this is a
um a group of states working together
rather than a federally mandated law
that is being imposed on
US Representative Felson thank you um
thank you uh Miss Ross for taking our
questions on this um it just it's
something that uh definitely interests
me because I I um used to live in Alaska
and had to deal a lot with placement of
native American children and that um
there's a lot of a lot of bread tape
involved in that so that's why this
caught my eye but um what is the name of
the organization that you all belong to
that all all the states participating
currently belong
to the ICPC is through the American
public Human Services Association or ASA
um can you can you you said some letters
there right at the beginning and I don't
have those um American public Human
Services Association
apsa and I'm I have the link to um their
web page and has the comparison of the
old and the new version and some
additional FAQs and information I'm
happy to send that on if that would be
helpful that would be wonderful thank
you you're
welcome anyone with any further
questions
representative sorry representative
Weber thank you and and as a matter of
clarification for M Ross is it not true
that if if 37 States ratify the
compact it doesn't bind any of the
states that have not ratified the
contract is that
correct that's correct it would just be
the organization moving forward with the
compact so it's and and is it not true
that sometimes despite the fact that
this is an interstate compact states
have individual variations in their
version even though it's sort of based
on a cohesive hole so each state really
does very much
retain control over its own
procedures yes absolutely
thank you and then if may I have one on
a different subject sir sure um at some
point somebody mentioned that we were
transitioning from vendor services to
contracted services and I'm not sure I
got those terms right it it had to do
with services for I think
developmentally disabled persons and I
just wanted to know what the difference
was between
vendor services and contracted Services
because um I would have thought they
were the same thing so if anybody could
explain that to me I would be
appreciative this is Rebecca Ross again
I'm I'm happy to representative Weber So
currently for um residential Child Care
um we have licensed and certified
providers and if a provider is licensed
and certified um they can take
placements we do individual contracts
that go to governor and council with
them we are moving toward that in order
to be able to tailor those so instead of
having minimum certification
requirements and anyone in everyone that
certifies can provide services um we're
looking at
um really redefining what services
they're providing and we're doing that
both in our residential services but
also putting out a number of our
community- Based Services for child
protection through contract so that we
can um better identify what we're
purchasing and what will meet the needs
of the children and families we're
serving so the the vendor providers
right now are licensed and certified but
they do not have governor and Council
approved contracts with us okay thank
you I'm getting a check from Christina
Dia regarding the info and she says the
AFA
AA who writes it is uh that information
is in the guideline that she emailed us
to help us walk through the
bill any other
questions uh representative G yes thank
you Mr chairman oh the last question
that was answered could you clarify more
for one thing we couldn't understand
everything you said because your voice
tailed off but the the still the
difference between a contract and a a
contracted service and a vendor is not
clear to me do they address different
categories of people do they address
different um lengths of time that you
care for these kids um is it like a
residential you're comparing residential
to
daycare yeah please please explain a
little
more be happy to um no you can use
either either model and throughout the
department we have different services
that are provided under different models
oh for example Medicaid pays in
different ways but for historically for
dcyf our providers have been um just
essentially enrolled as long as they're
enrolled they can they can take um
clients and we will pay them the rate
and and that is for both community and
residential services that we pay for for
um children in DCF care and custody
that's changing um to provide a better
service array so that we can identify
what types of services we want out there
and ensure that there's a provider there
to do it right now providers are under
no
obligation to um provide a service they
are eligible to take um clients but they
don't have any obligation to by going in
a contracted model we can require that
they provide a certain service to a
certain number of Youth in a certain
area um to really better purchase what
we're looking for instead of
um only having available what
providers are inclined to
provide thank
you we see no further hands I think we
have three choices before us with this
bill one is to
wait because somebody or somebody's may
have an amendment or more coming so we
should wait for those
or nobody's got an amendment coming but
we might want to sit on it for two weeks
still up to testify I'm so I am sorry
you are so
correct but hold that
FR and I I see that uh and thank you
representative Marsh for pointing out
that to me uh we have a Mr Andrew Shori
from Center tufton B who wishes to
testify in the hearing and Mr shagari if
you could put your hand up and you'll be
recognized to come into to the
meting thank you Mr chairman and
committee uh my concern first off I'm
chief of police and Tuftonboro I've
served in the past on the
therapeutic cannabis advisory Council uh
and I have concerns about
sections 12 through 14 I think it's kind
of worded poorly uh
I think the better way is to exempt
those products and have a a
particular uh what products that they're
referring to maybe that's the way to
look at it instead of giving a blanket
exemption to a whole chapter of
laws uh more particularly though I I
came on to talk about the rest of the
therapeutic cannabis section here
sections 14 through
um I
guess I like I said I I've been familiar
since the start I was on the therapeutic
advisory
Council um we were when this was program
was put in place we promised a tightly
regulated program that was for the
seriously ill people and it passed under
that guys if you will under that intent
uh then there was a five-year report
issued saying it was that should stay
along those
lines this these changes being proposed
first I uh when my cult talked about
this uh audit I looked at the audit the
audit had to do with why licenses
weren't being issued within the
statutory period of 15 days it had
nothing to do with many of these changes
here and I will send a copy of the audit
so you can all look at it um what it
happens when this if these changes go
into effect sections 14 through 32 we
will no longer have a tight program we
will have a very loose program give you
some ideas one patients will no longer
be linked to an ATC they could go
anywhere to any of the atcs and buy it
it' be impossible to track whether or
not they bought more than two ounces at
any of the atcs because right now if
they're tied to one that one knows if
they've come in more than more than uh
once in 10 days or how much they bought
within that 10 day period this this will
exempt them from being able to track
that I know it adds a penalty for doing
that but there realistically it's
unenforceable uh in other states you
would call this uh in Colorado they
called it looping when people would come
back and back and and buy over and over
again um and in this case you have the
caregiver could buy along with the
patient and there'd be no way of
tracking it in other words somebody
could go to the Chai Chester dispensary
and buy their two ounces and the
caregiver could be going over to the one
and over buying two ounces and then
you don't know how how that's going to
be tracked it and if they think they're
going to track it more that's going to
be tougher to track than anything else
this also will allow the atcs to grow
more
marijuana because right now they're
allowed a certain number of plants and
then a certain number based upon the the
number of patients that are tied to
their
ATC this says they can grow it for
everybody who has a card well recently
my CLE testified in another hearing they
11 th000 cards so instead of having the
two or 3,000 that might be ATT tied to
one ATC they're now going to be able to
grow plants for all 11,000 of any
cards uh it's gonna I believe it's going
to allow out of state patients to buy
from New Hampshire atc's there's no way
to verify out ofate
cards uh then also here's a big loophole
that's going to come up it's caregivers
are not going to have a limit on
patients it's presently is five patients
they can they can help five patients
with no limit they can carry almost any
amount of marijuana they want with them
uh there's no way to verifi There's no
practical way to verify that in the
field if a police officer contacts
somebody and they've got a bunch of
marijuana on them there's no way to
verify that in the field the one time I
tried calling there I got it was a
Friday about 10: in the morning and
instead of being able to verify it I got
a call several hours later but here's
the other problem that happens when you
have no limit on
patients other states have had that and
they've had problems with it Washington
Colorado Maine
Michigan that becomes a loophole that
gets
exploited in Maine they have what are
called um caregiver
storefronts so caregivers are able to
have a storefront where they
can hand out give out marijuana sell
marijuana they can't sell it but they
can exchange it for their cost of
expenses if you will Maine has them look
them up this they're called caregiver
storefronts and they're not subject to
any regulation relative to because they
have home grow there too but there's no
subject to regulation as far as uh uh
and they're fighting that the the
caregiver storefronts are fighting
Main's attempts to add regulation to it
Washington had these pop up Michigan had
a bunch of these carger storefronts by
not linking limiting the patients you'll
see what's called what they call in some
states they call them cooperatives
they'll have delivery services caregiver
storefronts I think uh I think it's it's
a lot of unintended consequences here
and there's a lot more work and
discussion before anything like this
passes and none of this I repeat again
none of this was in that audit that
audit had to do with them not meeting
the statutory deadline for issuing cards
within 15
days you should be aware that why I
brought it the home grow into this there
is another bill that has gone through
I'm not sure if it went through your
committee or not
HB 350 which talked about caregivers
having home grow and patients having hom
grow and be able to collectively home
grow you're GNA have you're gonna have
some problems if this passes as written
um and the other part of that that that
employees of DHS program will be exempt
from marijuana drug laws if this passes
there's no requirement for them to have
any proof that they're involved with a
regulatory uh scheme while they're doing
this this just says if they're involved
regulatory which is an easy thing to
anybody could claim that another problem
with this bill eliminates the address
for card holders why do we need an
address for card holders because we do
search warrants and and marijuana is
still technically illegal unless you
meet certain threshold
requirements um like this program for
example it's an exemption from our
marijuana laws without an address
somebody could claim any marijuana
anywhere as theirs because I don't
expect a patient to carry all their
marijuana with them all the time so if
we went to apartment A five five Main
Street Apartment a uh and we found some
marijuana in that house in the course of
an
investigation any patient could claim
it's theirs because there's no name
attached to them as far as I know there
there's very limited requirements for
for any kind of labeling other than what
the strain is at the dispensary they can
change the packaging this it's really
pretty open as to what they do and and
I'm not saying it shouldn't be that way
don't don't mistake that I'm not
advocating for a change in that what I'm
saying is without an address for a
patient we can't say that that stuff we
found at a certain place actually
belongs to them and so if it actually
belonged to somebody else they could get
their buddy as a card to claim it for
him and and and get an exemption if you
will from the laws I think there's a lot
of loopholes in here I think it needs a
lot of work and frankly I didn't see
anything that had to do with the
audit if they need more staff they need
more staff but extending them out three
years I don't know how that helps with
the audit maybe that arguably might have
something to do with the audit making it
less that they have to do every year but
it also talked about adding staff and
training
them thank you representative
clerk yes yes thank you very much um I
had a question sir you had commented
about uh kind of a blanket exemption
with to Tobacco in sections 12 and 13
and I have to confess when I first read
it that's how it impressed me but I
thought we had a fairly clear
explanation with the phrase with respect
to the therapeutic use of cannabis can
you explain why when it's restricted to
with the respect to the therapeutic use
of cannabis that you think it is a
blanket loophole that would allow them
to buy tobacco at a
store I wasn't saying that at all what I
was saying was that if there's a certain
what do you talked about was some of the
things that they do maybe it's rolling
papers he's talking about because that's
covered under that statute
well if that's the case why not just
give them exemption to sell Rolling
Papers rather than give them a whole
exemption from the whole SE section of
the law I I think that's a better way of
doing it if there's some specific thing
they need some paraphernalia or
something like that I'm not T I didn't
say I read I understand what Mike col
said about that with therapeutic
cannabis and I understand your point but
I think what I was getting at was maybe
it needs to be rewarded to about those
particular programs in the atcs that or
or the products that they're trying to
sell that might put them in violation of
that section name them rather than just
give them a blanket exception to the
whole law if you will you little more
specific is what I was getting at I
realized it does not allow them to buy
under 21 to buy
tobacco
represent follow up yes well but you
used the word blanket exemption again
and I I think the concern is that we can
see that if things change in the tobacco
law then we have to come back with a
statute that might be important to be
able to exempt that particular thing
like initially might be vaping and other
time it might be uh rolling papers and
we have to keep coming back uh with the
therapeutic cannabis program to ask for
the exemptions one by one if we exempt
them with regard to the therapeutic
cannabis program only would that not uh
allow them just to simply be able to do
what's necessary in their ATC but would
not allow this the purchase of tobacco
products in a store was why would that
not work
well I said blanket exception to little
statute as it relates to their
exemption to therapeutic it's kind of
twisting my words around let me give you
an example this this bill as written as
I read it doesn't just apply to atc's
they could go into a general store any
store and buy Rolling Papers a patient
because not just the ATC selling but it
also talks about patients with cards
being giving exemptions right I mean
that's how I read it to if it's just the
atcs that's one thing but it talks about
patients getting Exempted too so they
could go to a store and rolling papers
is probably the big thing that comes to
my mind because it's specifically stated
in the statute so I I I think it needs
work I think it needs work to accomplish
the goal they said they wanted to
accomplish with it that's that was my
point I'm not saying it gives him a
blank exception because it does have
that those few words in there um about
therapeutic cannabis um but is there's
another there's another part of that too
and that's Gramma and I'm not a an
English major by any of the word but uh
it does
say or alternative treatment centers
under RSA 126 X7 with respect to the
therapeutic use of
cannabis the or is disjunctive and the
New Hampshire Supreme Court has said
they're separate they could live alone
somebody could argue I'm not saying that
it's true I know that's not the intent
somebody could argue that individuals
would not be required to follow it under
the therapeutic cannabis use a cannabis
act because that only applies to the
atc's like I said I'm not an English
major I'm not gonna I'm not a lawyer but
I'm telling you that sometimes the or is
disjunctive and it's not clear that that
necessarily applies to both somebody
couldn't make that argument I'm not
making that argument but I think it
needs
Clarity I'm just saying it should be
worked on for clarity in that
section follow up again follow up again
okay would not the or mean that the
individual purchasing for example
rolling paper or a vaping pen would not
be subject to prosecution but nor would
the person who is providing it isn't
that why the word or is there is to take
away the risk for the individual and for
the uh ATC who would be selling the
product well it also applies to
individuals with cards uh not just ATC
so uh store CL with a card is also
Exempted to some degree too it's it's
poorly worded that that's my point as
we're arguing back and forth how it
could be interpreted I think that just
shows it I think that reinforces my
point it needs work it needs work it's
I'm not saying it's I'm not saying it's
badly intended I'm not saying it should
to not do it I'm just saying it needs
work on the wording so it's clear that
because it says individuals who have
issued registry card um that also
includes clerks and stores right I mean
they they're issued cards
they could have cards working in a store
and they could decide to sell to
somebody who they think is using for
therapeutic cannabis at a regular store
it's not specific to within the confines
of an ATC or if it's intended it needs
to be reworked that my point the wording
is kind of poorly phrased and and
subject to multiple interpretations as a
discussion we're having right now and It
ultimately would have to be clarified by
a court if somebody decided to push it
that far I don't know anybody that would
but I'm just saying that's I think it
should be clear of the intent and what
is meant to be I heard what he said but
the writing doesn't necessarily give you
that
Clarity any further questions for the
chief saying none thank you chief for
your testimony thank you for your time
do we have anyone else who has not
testified who wishes to
testify what was his name the chief
chief I don't have anybody on my list
those of you who have your computers in
front of
you
no okay now I'll go back to what I was
starting to say a minute ago and thank
you again for interrupting me because I
missed the chief uh we could do one of
three things so let me ask is there
anyone here who is wanting to work on an
amendment okay we have one person who is
wanting to work work on an amendment in
which case that ends that we will wait
two weeks and with that I will close the
hearing on Senate Bill 162 we had five
sign up in support six
opposed no we've got a little bit of
time so Mr representative Shapiro has
had his hand up for quite some time and
I think it related to that last bill
well I didn't see it and nobody else did
and nobody else told me but that's
irrelevance so representative
Shapiro I just wanted to say that um I
was going to request that we wait before
we EXA that bill but I do not
necessarily um know that I will have an
amendment um I just felt like I didn't
get a full answer to my question about
the work requirement and I've emailed U
Mr Williams to ask him who I can speak
to to get a fuller answer so I I would
request the wait but I'm not suggesting
that I'm necessarily going to have an
Amendment thank you very much and our
next meeting will be Monday May 17th and
that gives us two weeks to do that
sometimes we just need to sit and think
on something for a
while with that I would like to ex go to
exact the two bills from last time uh
Amendments have come to us and I think
we've all had a chance to see them and
with that I open the executive session
on Bill
120 and I call on representative to mer
for an
amendment thank you sir um yes I would
like to bring forward amendment number
11 187 which I mailed to the committee
last week I think on Monday or Tuesday
in any
case this sorry
I so I would move uh the amendment uh
1187 and I'd like to speak to it if
that's available allowed representative
Marsh seconds it and representative KK
coner excuse
me okay yeah okay uh just simply um you
I got together with uh a handful of
people um representative Marsh Merchant
Weber and then we got together with also
the Pas particularly the VA uh person
Richard laflam so that we went back and
forth came up with what we thought was a
perfectly fine one um put it out and um
Gary Merchant gets the Eagle Eye award
for picking out one more error that was
still in that we processed that again
and then came up with this final
Amendment if you look at it it really
basically it just replaces the whole
bill the whole section one um and the
point is that we just tidied up things
saying that this didn't have to do with
where they were from but licensed by
this is line
789 licensed by another state or
territory United States or another
country but that has to do with the PA
not the physician or uh who's the
supervising physician and then going
down to lines uh oh sorry we also tidied
up the issue that it was offering
Services that's line 11 offered through
the VA so it didn't have to be at the VA
because sometimes it was uh offered
elsewhere again n lines 14 through 19 um
this is about the Pas who are employed
by the VA offering their services and
requesting licensure can be supervised
by a physician license in any state or
territory United States uh providing
that that supervising physician has a
license and good standing in that state
or territory but we got rid of that word
of our other countries because we did
not want uh Physicians from other
countries
supervising and um that was basically it
the listing was again just this is z 223
and four uh the listing is autostate
licensed Physicians who accepting that
responsibility that that information
will be given uh to op oplc so that was
all it just tidied up those few little
problems that we identified again I
thank the whole committee for that kind
of segue that we did into an uh ad hoc
executive session after the hearing uh
when we kind of word Smith at the first
bit but we did go back and make some
changes and this is the final product of
it
anyone else wish to speak representative
Shapiro representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative kerk I might have
missed this when we had our original
discussion about this but does the PA in
question have to be um requesting lure
in New Hampshire or can they just
practice in New Hampshire given that
they work for the
VA my my understanding is they can
practice since they work for the VA but
if they wanted to get the license Ure we
require that they be supervised by a New
Hampshire licensed physician and this
was just allowing that it didn't have to
default to that because their supervis
supervising physician on site may be
licensed for example in Massachusetts
but not here thank you that is my
understanding representative
gay thank you um do we have to that's a
changeing wording uh if we're talking
about onsite that is really a different
situation from what apparently is going
on because the um man I mean I I sent
yall all late this this last night my
wording which is almost exactly what you
are talking about but I left out the
word on
site which may not be in this either
because that was a real issue of
discussion do you need a supervisor if
it was was a New
Hampshire um a New Hampshire licensed
person PA
working in a regular Hospital not in
VA we would require the onsite I think
but because this is the VA they run by
their own rules we don't put on site in
there because apparently they're
allowing a doctor from Main to
supervise what was the fraction
one4 or three4 of all
Vaas are being supervised by
somebody in main or at least uh at least
not with them not with the Pas not
physically with them so I thought onsite
was a very
interesting concept to discuss and to
see whether you keep it or not it
doesn't sound like if it's the VA use on
site if it's a New Hampshire PA licens
to work anywhere in New Hampshire you
would use the word
onite that I'm confused on what you're
trying to say I I'm sorry but I really
couldn't follow what what you're saying
I'm sorry you just said on site in your
last statement the supervisory position
you said something about it on site um
I'm sorry if I did I think I misspoke uh
what it is um The Otter State licensed
Physicians um the that are going to
supervise they have to provide have to
have a license in good standing in their
respective state or territory I don't
think I we have no language in here that
says it has to be onsite supervision
what we did talk about was that the it
was the care um offered on site that was
confusing in the first what we changed
it to was offered to the VA we had
actually Wordsmith that together in the
group because of the fact that the care
may be given um not at the VA but
through the VA to Veterans and we wanted
to be sure it was covered for care that
was given let's say as Home Care by a pa
um or in a nursing home or something
like that I think that's is that what
you're
saying yes I just wanted to clarify when
you brought the words up on site I I
thought you were talking about the
supervision so I no the no that was had
to do with where this where the services
are offered I'm sorry not on the site at
the VA but um through their
system got it now I'm sorry anyone else
with anything to ask or share we're an
exec session it does not have to be a
question Mr
chairman representative
Merchants thank you Mr chairman um see a
couple of the docs on our committee does
a PA have to be on site to be supervised
by a physician as in state of New
Hampshire is it required for the
position to be on site and have direct
supervision of
a um May I answer
that uh representative Mar be you to it
and then you may go ahead yeah my answer
I know of instances where that is not
what's
happening
yes I supervised Pas and I uh did meet
with them once a week but I was not at
the same practice facility of the PA
that I was supervising for uh three or
four days of the
week okay anybody
else there uh the
amendment uh 11
187h to Senate Bill 120 has been moved
by representative kerk and second by
representative
Marsh and with no objection would the
clerk please call the role on the
amendment thank
you representative Marsh votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative
Nelson yes representative
[Music]
Acton
yes representative gay yes
representative kushman yes
representative fulsome yes
representative Kelsey yes representative
King yes representative kofalt yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative
kerk yes representative Solway yes
representative
Canon
yes sorry representative nut upam
yes representative
Shapiro yes representative Woods yes
representative Merchant yes
representative
query yes and representative Pearson yes
and that's 21 in the affirmative the
chair recognizes representative Marsh
for motion yes Mr chairman I move that
Senate Bill 120 out to pass as amend
mooved by representative Marsh seconded
by I'll second
S8 well since the amended bill is now
the bill there should not be any
discussion but I have to allow for it
seeing none hearing none when the clerk
is ready please call the roll on Senate
Bill 12 as amended by Amendment 11 187h
moved by representative Mar second by
representative thank you representative
Marsh yes representative McMahon yes
representa Nelson yes representative
Acton yes representative gay yes
representative kushman yes
representative bsam yes represent ative
Kelsey yes representative King yes
representative cofal yes representative
Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative
kerk yes representative
Solway yes representative Canon
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes yes
representative
Woods you're
muted representative Woods unmute
please yes thank you representative
Merchant
yes representative
query yes representative Pearson yes
that's 21 21 to zero representative
Marsh Mr CH I with consent consent
calendar would you please write the blur
thank you very much and that is the exec
session on Senate Bill
12 I open the exec session on Senate
Bill 45 and we start with an amendment
representative Marsh Mr chairman I move
Amendment
12538 I'll second that and that sounded
like Merchant was
it it did sound like him yes who was
that
seconded
shy I asked representative Merchant did
you second that yes I did thank you
you yeah to speak to the motion the
hardest part of this amendment was to
put in contingency language so whether
or not U House Bill 2 becomes law and
whether or not this Bill gets passed
prior to or after House Bill 2 the
appropriate line language that we want
to put into place actually get put into
place um the second issue that this
amendment addresses is the issue of
retired practitioners who we all agree
ought not to be able to uh uh access the
control drug prescription the pdmp uh
without a reason to be accessing it uh
and representative Merchant to help us
with a good bit of that language
therefore his name is on this amendment
as well so those those are the two
issues that are addressed by this
amendment any questions or
discussion somebody just say very
briefly what the issue
is would you
just in 25 words or
less about the control drugs all right
well the the issue that's being changed
by the amendment is at present time
certain retired individuals would have
no reason access in this database
currently still have access to the
database and it makes it so that they
would not have access to the
database and if I may there's people who
retire but there also people who are
working clinical people who work in
administrative positions that no longer
work clinically but have a clinical
license so therefore would apply to them
as well so anyone who doesn't have a
reason to be into the program therefore
should not be in the
program
any further discussion questions
representative Woods is that yellow
thing over your right shoulder your hand
up or is it a
constellation those are all galaxies
Galaxy
okay uh just U partly for my own
edification um OS I mean the office is
oplc
correct uh that is correct yes the
conditions are except for the ones that
are changed in the amendment the
definitions remain what they are under
current existing law and what what
relationship do they have say if do they
if they see something that's a little
irregular do they are they mandated
someplace else to communicate with the
Board of Medicine the nursing board uh
what what is that mandated you know if
there is something incorrect going on
where does it uh
fall uh that I would have to look into
because it's not being changed by this
bill as proposed was just yeah okay just
I wanted
to
off anyone
else and we have Amendment 1253 H to
Senate Bill 45 moved by representative
Marsh seconded by representative
Merchant when the clerk is ready please
call the RO
thank you representative Marsh votes yes
representative McMahon yes
representative Nelson yes
representative
yes representative Kay yes
representative kushman yes
representative fulson yes representative
Kelsey yes representative King yes
representative kofalt
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
kerk yes representative
Solway
yes representative Canon
yes representative nut upam yes
representative Shapero yes
representative Woods yes representative
m Merchant yes representative
query yes and representative Pearson yes
and that's 21 in the affirmative
representative Marsh is called upon for
a motion uh Mr chairman I move that
Senate Bill 45 out to pass this
amendment second at that and that was s
like represent Merchant
yes well
since this is exactly what we just did I
hope there'll be no discussion but you
never know but I'll give you about three
seconds would the clerk please call no
would the clerk please call the role on
Senate Bill 45 as amended by 12538 moved
by representative Marsh seconded by
representative
Merchant thank you representative Marsh
votes yes representative McMahon yes
representative
Nelson yes representative
Acton representative Acton we'll come
back to you
representative okay thank you
representative gay yes representative
kushman yes representative fulson yes
representative Kelsey yes representative
King yes representative Kofa yes
representative representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
kerk yes representative Solway yes
representative Kon yes representative n
upam yes representative Shapiro yes
representative Woods yes representative
Merchant yes representative
query yes
and representative peton yes and without
objection to consent and would you the B
yes thank you uh what we have done today
let's just take a look at that I know
there are um at least one Amendment
coming on
149 the B we did in the afternoon we
want to think on so that only leaves the
question of Senate bille 7
four um what is the committee's pleasure
is anyone likely to come forth with an
amendment on 74 the advanced
directives I would come up with
one even just an extremely simple one
representative G would like to come up
with an amendment so we will wait on
this two weeks as
well uh actually that a minute ago just
closed the exec session on Sen B um 45
45 thank you and um with no other
business before us we will meet two
weeks from today at N9
o' so this uh hearing of the session of
the house Human Services noly Affairs
committee is
concluded bye everybody good to see Mr
chairman
bye everyone bye everyone have a good
week bye everyone all to